[Musique]
Messieurs, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Sébastien
Tom Alexandre. Sébastien à toi la
parole. Donc je suis Sébastien Gouspiou,
je suis un entrepreneur et je suis
spécialisé dans le mining de Bitcoin
depuis 8 ans.
Où ça ?
L'entreprise de départ est en France
mais maintenant on a des activités un
peu partout dans le monde.
Tom Benoît entrepreneur également. J'ai
dirigé plusieurs agences immobilières.
J'interviens régulièrement dans les
médias. Je dirige un magazine qui
s'appelle Géostratégie Magazine et qui
est on va dire particulièrement orienté
sur l'économie.
Alexandre Stachenko, je suis
entrepreneur aussi. J'ai fondé une
entreprise il y a une dizaine d'années
dans le conseil autour des cryptos
surtout Bitcoin que j'ai cédé à KPMG où
je j'ai passé 2 ans en tant que
directeur de laation crypto. Et depuis
début 2024, je suis directeur de la
stratégie chez Premium qui est une des
plus anciennes plateformes d'échange de
Bitcoin en France et en Europe. Donc qui
propose des services de conservation,
trading et cetera.
Donc comme vous avez pu le remarquer, on
va parler couture.
Exactement. On va on va parler
cryptoonnaies, on va parler Bitcoin, on
va parler géopolitique, on va parler
banque centrales, on va parler euh
on va parler argent, on m'a dit
on va peut-être parler argent mais je
vois que c'est un sujet qui vous
intéresse beaucoup et et donc qui veut
prendre la parole pour me répondre et
ensuite passer la la parole à son voisin
sur pourquoi les banques centrales
sont-elles en train de s'intéresser aux
cryptoonnaies ?
Je peux prendre la parole si
si tes si tes voisins sont d'accord.
Absolument. Tout à fait.
Alors, dans la question, il y a déjà un
une forme de présupposé à savoir qu'elle
s'intéresse aux cryptoonnaies euh comme
si c'était un tout homogène. Euh en
réalité, c'est souvent une fiction que
beaucoup de gens qui ne sont pas dans le
dans le secteur pensent, croire.
C'est-à-dire que il y a en gros une
forme de tout homogène dans lequel il y
a les cryptonnaies. En réalité, c'est un
peu différent. Il y a vraiment un
éléphant dans la pièce qui s'appelle
Bitcoin euh qui est la première
cryptomonnaie qui a été crée en 2009 et
surtout qui est encore aujourd'hui la
plus sécurisée, la plus adoptée, qui
représente un peu plus de la moitié de
la capitalisation totale du marché de
toutes les cryptomonnaies et qui est un
peu la seule crypto avec une vraie
prétention monétaire en tout cas. Après
voilà, est-ce que ça adviendra ou pas ?
Ça c'est c'est les analyses qui vont
après. Euh et en fait quand on dit les
banques centrales s'intéressent aux
cryptoonnaies pendant un moment elles
s'en sont pas vraiment intéressées parce
que pour ell Bitcoin était vraiment un
truc de geek dans un garage et puis on
ça va mourir de toute façon un jour. Et
puis aujourd'hui, finalement, elles
comprennent que il y a un enjeu autour
du du questionnement monétaire,
c'est-à-dire le modèle de la banque
centrale qui d'une certaine façon pour
fonctionner a besoin qu'il n'y ait pas
d'échappatoire et bien vient de trouver
un échappatoire en la présence de
Bitcoin. Donc il prévoi leur propre
réponse qui sont les les MNBC notamment.
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler. Euh
mais donc c'est pour ça qu'elle
s'intéresse au monde des
cryptomonnaaies. C'est plus pour essayer
de c'est un émésis pour elle d'une
certaine façon en version synthétique.
Tom
moi je dirais autre chose, c'est que
pourquoi les banques centrales ne
s'intéressent pas aux cryptomonnaes ?
Parce que les banques centrales ne
s'intéressent pas du tout aux
cryptomonnaaies. Vous avez effectivement
un OVNI monétaire gigantesque qui
s'appelle Bitcoin qui est apparu qui a
été inventé par un homme qui n'existe
pas. Satoshi Nakamoto.
Donc 95 % des volumes de transaction
passent par une société qui s'appelle
Binance qui est une banque commerciale,
on va dire pour cryptomonnaie qui est
installée aux îles Caillement dont
personne ne connaît l'adresse du siège
social et qui a été approuvé par la
Banque centrale européenne qui a été
approuvée ensuite par l'Autorité des
marchés financiers et les banques
centrales notamment et pas seulement les
autres régulateurs pour ainsi dire ont
dit bah pourquoi pas il y a finalement
cet OVNI monétaire qui vient faire
concurrence aux monnaes traditionnelles,
nous le laissons faire. Nous ne nous
intéressons pas à ça. Quant au MNMBC,
MNBC, les monnaies numériques de banque
centrale CBIDC en anglais que convoquait
mon mon voisin de de gauche, on n'est
pas sur un territoire de cryptomonnaie,
on est sur un territoire purement
monétaire. On a simplement une banque
centrale,
l'occurrence européenne ici, mais c'est
la même chose à la réserve fédérale. Une
banque centrale qui émet une seconde
structure monétaire. C'estàdire qu'on a
une banque centrale qui dit "Je vais
émettre pour la BCE par exemple de
l'euro, je continue à garantir l'euro
qui a cour légal et qui est le souverain
monétaire de cette fédération européenne
que nous avons aujourd'hui comme
précédemment le franc avec la Banque de
France ou le dollar avec le USA. Et
cette même banque centrale dit, je vais
émettre également une monnaie numérique
de banque centrale. Ça veut dire qu'il y
aura pas de billet pour il y aura pas de
pièc et de billet. Cette monnaie sera
seulement une monnaie numérique. Il y
aura pas de banque commerciale non plus
et vous aurez votre compte directement à
la banque centrale. Ça c'est les
monnaies numériques de banque centrale
mais il y a pas de blockchain.
Je vois Alex qui secoue la tête. Je leur
donnerai la parole après.
Sébastien, est-ce que vous tu ouv
rebondir ?
Oui, tout à fait. Alors, ben je suis
assez d'accord avec Tom sur le fait que
ce sont pas des cryptonnaies à
proprement parler les les MNBC que
proposent les enfin que vont proposer
les banques centrales, il y a pas de
blockchain. Euh donc, on peut penser que
c'est Bitcoin qui les a
qui les a titillé jusqu'à ce qu'elle
sorte un un un un produit qui ressemble
à la performance de Bitcoin. En
revanche, là je suis pas d'accord sur le
fait que les banques centrales laissent
faire. D'abord le fait que Binance c'est
80 % des volumes. Je sais pas si ce
chiffre est exact. Je peux pas ce
chiffre d'ailleurs ? Oh
vous le trouvez de partout, vous pouvez
faire checker sur internet.
Oui, je le conteste pas. Je le je le
connaissais pas mais c'est absolument
anecdotique. Moi je le connais
c'est absolument anecdotique. On s'en
fout complètement qu'aujourd'hui Binance
c'est 80 % des Ça se trouve l'année
prochaine Binance n'existera plus. La
plus grosse plateforme avant Binance
c'était FTX. Elle existe plus. Il y en a
eu la première grosse plateforme ctx
elle n'existe plus.
Absolument. Donc c'est totalement
anecdotique cette plateforme-là. Binance
pourra disparaître demain effectivement.
Mais c'est pas que les banques centrales
ont pas voulu s'opposer à Binance, c'est
que Binance c'est suffisamment malin
pour mettre des sièges sociaux à des
endroits où ils ont pas le pouvoir de
les contraindre parce que quand ils
veulent contraindre
et si GP Morgan disparu c'est unotique
pour vous.
Alors pas tout de suite Tom. Non, ça n'a
rien à voir. Ça n'a rien à voir. Je veux
dire que le fait qu'aujourd'hui Binance
a 80 % des volumes, c'est totalement
anecdotique. N'importe quelle autre
plateforme prendra ces volumes là si
Binance disparaît demain pour des
raisons ou de HAC ou de ou de maleté des
dirigeants ou de contrainte
gouvernementale ou d'État. Ça c'est
vraiment pas un souci pour Bitcoin.
Alexandre ?
Ouais. Alors, je suis pas d'accord sur
beaucoup de points qui ont été évoqués.
D'abord, bah factuellement, je pense que
le déjà je pense que factuellement le
chiffre est faux, mais de mais je pense
qu'il est à cause aussi d'une confusion.
C'est-à-dire que ce dont Tom parle,
c'est les volumes cryptos, c'est pas les
volumes Bitcoin. Parce que sur le volume
crypto, effectivement Binance, c'est une
plateforme sur laquelle il y a quantité
de cryptos qui ont pour vocation de
mourir le lendemain ou la semaine
d'après. Un peu comme une forme de
casino où on va gagner de l'argent en
une forme de ponzi
ou il y en a beaucoup qui sont des ponz.
Oui, tout à fait. Donc effectivement sur
le volume de de ce qu'on peut appeler
des shitcoin dans le milieu,
oui, Binance a une grosse partie du
marché sur Bitcoin tout seul. C'est pas
vrai. Déjà, il y a une partie
substantielle.
Parler du Bitcoin hein, pas du volume
crypto.
Bah en l'occurrence sur les volumes
d'échange, moi c'est pas les chiffres
que j'ai en tête. Moi j'ai des ordres de
grandeur qui sont différents mais comme
je connais pas le chip et pas vous
donner de source mais pour moi 80 % même
90 m'avait l'air extrêmement loin de la
source.
C'est intéressant mais c'est combien
alors selon vous ? mon mon ordre de
grandeur d'en tête de mémoire c'était
c'était en dessous de la moitié donc
c'était pas ça mais bon en fait je ne le
sais pas de puisqueon l'a dit juste
avant ils sont un coup au î caillement
un coup au s'échelle on sait pas où ils
sont donc en fait le vérifier est très
difficile.
Par contre, sur la partie
banque centrale qui effectivement n'ont
pas empêché, là c'est effectivement
complètement faux pour être entrepreneur
le secteur entre les nombreuses
fermetures de comptes bancaires, les les
empêchements de de vivre, les
déménagements, les
les multiples opérations d'enfumage sur
ce sujet-là. Euh il faut faut pas avoir
entrepris dans le milieu pour penser que
les banques centrales n'ont rien fait.
Et je terminerai sur un point par
rapport à la raison pour laquelle les
banques centrales sont entrées. Et là,
c'est assez facilement vérifiable. Vous
pouvez regarder sur Google Trends. Sur
Google Trends, vous mettez CBC, donc
l'acronyme anglais pour mon numérique de
banque centrale et vous verrez que
globalement tout le monde s'en fout
jusque à peu près 2008-29. Le moment où
le sujet commence à être évoqué, c'est
juste à la suite de Libra euh qui était
l'annonce de Facebook. Donc Facebook,
ils ont aussi un petit peu surfer sur le
le sujet des cryptomonnaies et donc ils
ont annoncé, je crois mémoire mi 2019,
peut-être 18, je sais plus, mais sans c
là qu'ils allaient sortir leur propre
cryptomonnaie. Et en fait pour beaucoup
de banques centrales à ce moment-là
c'est passé du statut de projet de geek
qui va mourir à en fait il y a un des
gars femmes qui est en train de sortir
un projet de crypto. Or ils ont pas
l'habitude de faire n'importe quoi. Et
donc à ce moment-là ils ont lancé leur
grande opération de com on va faire des
mon numériques de grand centrale dont
l'objectif est en fait sous-jacent de
dire aux différentes populations, vous
n'avez pas besoin de Bitcoin puisque'en
fait on va prendre Bitcoin et sa
technologie et on va faire un truc un
peu plus régulé. On va faire un truc où
on va prendre tous les avantages de
Bitcoin mais de manière un peu plus
lisse et donc vous n'en aurez pas besoin
de ce Bitcoin. Mais en réalité pour
plein de raisons, mais je veux pas
monopoliser la parole, la MNBC euh en
fait le meilleur ces scénarios c'est
qu'elle n'advienne pas euh parce que ce
sont euh les seuls qui ont advenu
aujourd'hui, c'est typiquement la Chine.
C'est la suite du Crédit social. Donc
c'est pas c'est pas le modèle que je
On va rebondir ensuite sur la suite du
crédit social plus tard. Tom
ce que dit monsieur oui tout à fait
juste par rapport au MNBC.
C'est Alexandre. Voilà, ce que dit
Alexandre est tout à fait juste. On peut
dire monsieur sur les MNBC et moi non
plus je
souhaiterais qu'elle n'advienne pas.
Mais ce qu'il faut noter, c'est que elle
ne pourrait pas, quoi qu'il en soit être
opérée par une technologie blockchain.
Si on parle de la blockchain du Bitcoin,
la consommation énergétique du maintien
du Bitcoin, je crois que c'est
équivalent pour le total à un pays comme
le Danemark ou la Suisse. Peut-être que
je me trompe un peu mais on va dire
cette ordre de grandeur à peu près.
Voilà, sont pas des chiffres lancé
voisins, je veux dire à peu près
Danemark ou Suisse.
Qu'est-ce que vous entendez par maintien
? Bah tous les nœuds qui tournent les
ordinateurs. Voilà, parce que vous avez
des validateurs de partout qui ont Je
discutais avec un ami qui est en jeune
ami c'est même pas un ami mais j'ai
sympathisé avec lui, on se connaît pas
mais on parle de de cryptoonnaie, il est
installé Emmanuel Macron. Non non, il
est installé en en Norvège et il m'a dit
"Je vais probablement m'équiper, ça me
coûte une vingtaine de milliers d'euros
et en même temps ça chauffera mon salon
puisque quoi qu'il en soit plutôt que de
payer une facture d'électricité pour
rien, je ferais tourner un nœud chez
moi, ça chauffera mon salon." Donc pour
donner l'ordre de grandeur quand même de
la consommation d'un équipement pour
pour miner du Bitcoin et pour entretenir
pour valider des des transaction et et
ainsi de suite. Mais par rapport au
monnau de banque centrale, je pense que
pour répondre tout à fait à ta question
initiale que les banques centrales ont
voulu parce que c'est dans leur habitude
mais comme beaucoup d'États et de
régulateurs, séduire la population. Et
évidemment aujourd'hui, on peut être
séduisant si on dit monnaie numérique.
On est à la mode, on s'habille à la mode
et on séduit un public assez jeunes
également. Mais après, la question va
être est-ce que ces monnaies numériques
de banque centrale vont être comme
toutes les monnaies régies par le
système de Breton Woods ? C'est-à-dire
que vous allez avoir la banque des
règlements internationaux qui est à Bal,
le fond monétaire international qui est
à Washington, la Banque mondiale qui est
aux États-Unis et des réunions avec tous
les banquiers centraux qui se réunissent
en disant on entretient ce qu'on appelle
le système financier. C'est ce qu'on
faisait jusqu'à présent.
On avait des paniers de devises par
exemple au fond monétaire international,
on avait on a toujours qui avec le yan,
le le le yen, la livre pour les fameux
droits de tirage spéciaux du FMI par
exemple qui faisait partie justement des
devises les plus sûres de tout le
système financier. Puis après, il y a
d'autres devises également, il y a
d'autres monnaies mais qui font
également partie du système financier
parce que les banques centrales, chaque
pays a sa banque centrale et il y a une
coopération. Sauf que là, si on prend
l'exemple de la Russie qui est très
évocateur, par exemple, les Russes ont
été virés de la banque des règlements
internationaux. Ça veut dire que depuis
2 ans, il y a plus un seul russe qui va
à la banque des règlements
internationaux à balle et qui participe
à des réunions. Ils ont été virés, on
les invite plus, on les convit plus.
Donc demain, si les Russes créent leur
monnaie numérique de banque centrale et
que nous on lance neuronumérique
et les Américains en dollar numérique,
vous croyez que les Russes vont dire
"Bon, OK, on participe à votre euh grand
cahier des charges, on le signe et on
vous donne un blancin pour gérer aussi
notre modé numérique ?" Non. Donc la
question des CBDC, c'est est-ce qu'il va
y avoir une polarisation du système
monétaire par de nouveaux de nouvelles
structures monétaires émises par les
banques centrales des États ou des
regroupements d'État ? en l'occurrence
pour l'Europe qui conduit donc à la
dislocation du système financier.
Seb
en tous les cas sur le début de la
démonstration, ça peut pas être des
blockchains parce que la blockchain
Bitcoin consomme autant que la Suisse.
Je vois pas du tout le lien pour le
reste
je sais pas moi, je suis pas banquier
central. Je sais pas pourquoi elle crée
ça. Je me suis toujours posé la question
hein parce que euh quand on demande, ça
fait des années que je demande pourquoi
vous voulez une monnaie numérique de
banque centrale, quel est l'intérêt ? Ça
n'a aucun intérêt. Il y a aucune
demande. Il y a pas un citoyen qui
demande ça. Donc c'est évidemment pour
nous he de toute évidence un moyen de
contrôler la population et de d'avoir la
main sur ces échanges et être en
capacité de de suspendre les échanges
par exemple pour acheter de la viande
parce que tu as déjà mangé tes 3 kg de
viande depuis le début de la semaine
donc c'est fini.
3 kg par semaine c'est beaucoup on t'a
dit hein.
Ça dépend de la taille de la famille.
faire bizarre,
ça dépend de la taille de la famille
mais voilà par personne ou par famille.
Non non, par famille. Par toujours
est-il que nous on n'y voit qu'un piège
hein, absolument aucun intérêt. Les
monnaies sont déjà numériques donc et je
pense que les banquiers doivent le voir
encore plus comme un piège parce que
l'idée c'est quand même que les banques
centrales se passent des banques pour
diffuser leur leur monnaie. Je reviens
quand même sur l'histoire de l'énergie
parce que ce que je comprends que disait
Tom, c'était que c'était pas tenable
pour des banques centrales de faire de
la monnaie numérique avec une blockchain
style Bitcoin parce que ça consomme trop
d'énergie.
Ce qui est pas du tout le cas. On
pourrait absolument créer un quelque
chose en proof of work pour toutes les
monnaies deci par
de banque centrale.
Proof of work. Proof of work.
Ah c'est le c'est le protocole Bitcoin.
C'est le système de validation et de
sécurisation du réseau Bitcoin qui pour
qui peut être différent. Etherum par
exemple a un système qui s'appelle proof
of stake et qui lui ne consomme pas
d'énergie, c'est ça travaille pas
pareil. Donc on pourrait tout à fait
avoir une blockchain proof of stake pour
assurer les systèmes MNBC monnaie de
banque centrale. Ça c'est absolument
indéniable. C'est pas le choix qui est
fait. C'est trop transparent la
blockchain. Donc la banque va préférer
avoir un système totalement propriétaire
mais le propos n'est absolument pas le
problème de la consommation d'énergie
parce qu'il existe pas. C'est un faux
problème. Mais
moi je suis étonné par rapport au fait
par ailleurs que tous ces régulateurs
si on enfin je sais pas moi, j'ai
toujours eu des j'ai toujours aimé les
voitures, j'ai toujours eu des grosses
voitures et de
c'est pas vrai.
Il dit ça parce qu'il aime bien ma
voiture et une
belle occasion d'ailleurs.
Voilà exactement et aujourd'hui si on
roule avec une voiture qui est un peu
trop motorisée, on est mal vu. Et
bizarrement motorisé ta voiture
justement c'est son gros problème c'est
qu'elle elle a une physionomie de
voiture motorisée mais elle est
sousmotorisée mais mis à part cette
migression
et si on roule avec une voiture
justement oui mais je peux entrer en
Suisse justement parce que si j'arrive
en Suisse j'ai le critère de et je suis
étonné par exemple que les régulateurs
sur le Bitcoin ne nous disent pas mais
attendez il y a un gros problème avec
cet OVNI là qui vient d'apparaître ça
consomme une énergie énorme et du
charbon chinois
on l'a jamais entendu
ils le disent pas fort he j'ai pas
entendu j'ai pas entendu un ministre de
l'environ français ces derniers temps se
scandaliser sur le Bitcoin.
Une proposition Union européenne pour
interdire le Bitcoin sur cette raison.
Alors, je vais vous dire une chose. Il y
a l'autorité des marchés financiers par
exemple qui a signé cette semaine une
charte qui s'appelle jamais sans elle
pour qu'il n'y ait plus une seule
réunion où il n'y ait pas de femmes
présentes pour les réunions à l'autorité
des marchés financiers. pour vous dire à
quel point l'autorité des marchés
financiers s'inscrit dans
une pte à la fois féministe écologiste
qui est en vogue aujourd'hui. Cette même
autorité des marchés financier approuve
Binance l'année passée qui fait partie
pas approuvé l'enregistré.
Elle l'a enregistré elle l'a enregistré.
C'est
très différent hein.
Non mais elle l'enregistré. Elle l'a
officié.
Elle a pas le choix. Elle est obligé de
l'enregistrer. Ah bah bien sûr que si si
les documents sont correctement remplis
ils peuvent pas refuser d'enregistrer.
Ils donnent même pas leur adresse.
L'adresse du ciel social. On peut faire
valider. On peut faire enregistrer une
entreprise sans donner l'adresse du CH
soci. J'ai jamais vu ça.
Il y a une différence juridique. Il y a
une différence parce que c'est des
risques de sécurité. Si moi je je suis
une plateforme d'échange qui gère 3
milliards. Si je vous donne mon siège
social Morgan gère beaucoup d'argent et
Visa Mastercard également. Moi je suis
pas le porte-parole de Binance donc j'en
sais rien. Mais le là sur ce qui ce qui
vient d'être mentionné, il y a quand
même une différence à faire.
Effectivement, il y a des sujets. Alors
pour le coup pour ceux qui veulent
remonter dans mon historique, je suis
pas le plus grand fan de Minance. Je me
suis déjà exprimé plusieurs fois sur le
fait que il y avait une hypocrisie assez
forte des pouvoirs publics français
là-dessus où d'un côté avec une main,
ils disent "Lein c'est nul, les cryptos
c'est nul, c'est le terrorisme, ça
détruit la planète une fois par jour".
Et de l'autre béb
et les bébés f plusieurs euh enfin c'est
c'est on c'est à peine caricatura à la l
des titres de journaux. Je me souviens
quand j'avais fait l'expérience de taper
Bitcoin sur les en gros les 5 à 10
grands titres de presse en France, il y
en avait un des articles qui était
Bitcoin et pour les animaux. C'est
c'était vraiment donc on n'est pas sur
Bitcoin à une super image. Il y a quand
même une une donc il y a cette
hypocrisie où ils ont beau dire ça en
2021 ou 22 je me souviens plus ils
accueillent Binance à Ber tapis rouge au
ministère de l'économie. On est très
content d'avoir les investissements
tout en anglais en anglais Cédico.
Cédrico et le boss de Binance qui parle.
Nous ça nous avait beaucoup choqué en
tant qu'entrepreneur français. Nous, on
nous a toujours mis des bâtons dans les
roues et le premier entrepreneur qui
reçoivent, c'est le patron de Binance à
Paris. Donc nous, ça nous a scandalisé.
On sait que c'est un casino, un casino à
crypto. C'est un truc qu'on aime pas du
tout. On n'est pas client de ce truclà.
Et donc
moi c'est un concurrent donc je vais pas
voilà
dénoncer Binance pour dire Bitcoin c'est
pas bien, ça n'a aucun sens. On est les
premiers à cracher sur Binance. C'était
là où je voulais en venir.
Crache pas ici.
Ailleurs qu'ici.
Là, là où je voulais en venir, c'est que
ça participe de ce par quoi j'ai ouvert
l'émission. C'est-à-dire que en fait,
faut être précis de sur ce dont on
parle. Est-ce qu'on parle de Bitcoin ou
est-ce qu'on parle des cryptos ou est-ce
qu'on parle des plateformes d'échange
dont le business tient en partie des
cryptos ? Et en fait, c'est des choses
complètement différentes. Binance euh je
termine là-dessus, je encore une fois
c'est mon concurrent donc je vais pas
m'attarder sur eux mais c'est pas tout à
fait dans la même catégorie quand même.
Paraître mon concurrent, ils sont
enregistrés, on
respecte son compte concurrent.
Exactement. Donc c'est pour ça que je
veux rétablir la vérité sur ce qui a été
dit. Binance Binance France d'ailleurs
qui est une société autre, je laisserai
chacun regarder l'actionnariat. Euh ils
sont enregistrés en France mais la
France a un régime juridique avec deux
vitesses. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a un
enregistrement et un agrément.
L'enregistrement, c'est une procédure
qui est plus simple que l'agrément parce
que ça consiste juste à obtenir un
numéro auprès de trackf pour leur
remonter des informations sur le
blanchiment et le terrorisme. Mais il y
a pas de contrôle sur l'honorabilité des
dirigeants, il y a pas de contrôle sur
la cybersécurité, il y a pas donc dès
que nous par exemple si jamais il y a
une boîte de l'écosystème qui est
enregistrée auprès de la MF qui dit
"Nous, on a été agréé par la MF pour
être sûr que la MF va les contacter pour
leur dire vous enlevez ça, vous n'avez
été validé par personne, vous êtes
enregistré parce qu'il y a une loi et
qu'on respecte la loi." En terme
d'agrément en France, il n'y a que
société générale Forge aujourd'hui qui
est agrée. Le reste pour l'instant c'est
que des enregistrements et la
réglementation européenne, elle va être
en place à partir de l'an prochain.
D'ailleurs, ça arrive un peu trop vite.
Non, mais moi ce que je vois qui est
très particulier, c'est qu'on laisse
finalement se créer un nouveau système
et que tout le monde trouve ça
formidable sans se poser de questions.
Je veux dire, il y a quelqu'un qui est
arrivé, comme je dis, on connaît pas son
nom, il y a des sociétés comme ça qui
apparaissent sorties de nulle part,
elles sont toutes installées aux
États-Unis, elles sont toutes
américaines, hein. Et on déplore,
la fondation, on le déplore. Voilà. Mais
je veux dire quand même, il faut se dire
donc le le si on part du principe que
Bitcoin c'est quand même la
cryptomonnaie phare hein, c'est le poids
lourd des cryptomonnaes. Les cinq plus
grosses cryptomonnaies c'est 90 % de la
capitalisation totale de toutes les
cryptomonnaes.
Moi j'aurais pas dit comme ça. C'est ce
que j'ai dit au début. En fait c'est un
autre sujet, c'est pas les
cryptomonnaies.
C'est bon Bitcoin c'est pas une
cryptomonnaie.
C'est en fait c'est il y a un sujet
Bitcoin et après il y a le sujet des
investissements du venture capital.
Non on parle de cryptomonnaie. Bitcoin
est une cryptomonnaie que je sois quand
même d'accord. C'est la plus grosse.
Là où je m'inscris en faux, c'est que en
faisant ce raisonnement là en fait on on
fait on fait un raisonnement par
assimilation dans lequel ensuite on va
dire des trucs pas bien sur les autres
cryptos. Donc Bitcoin non, il y a
Bitcoin.
Si je vous dis que le franc congolais
par rapport au dollars vaut 2000 francs
congolais pour un dollar ou un petit peu
moins même en ce moment, vous allez me
dire non mélangez pas le franc congolais
le dollar si ce on peut les comparer.
Il y a que Bitcoin qui a une prétention
monétaire. Donc si vous voulez parler de
la monétaire, on reste sur Bitcoin. Et
qui sait qui a la prétention monétaire
pour Bitcoin tr fanatique et de plus en
plus mais c'est tout.
Il un pays accessoirement mais
Ah oui d'accord. Non mais un pays c'est
pas mal quand même non ? Oui. Bah ben je
je connais le viceprésident. Voulez que
je vous raconte une anecdote quand j'ai
rencontré le vice-président du Salvador
voilà je lui pose une question, je lui
dis mais lorsque vous avez choisi le
j'oublie son prénom c'est Pedro ou
on retrouvera vous m'excusez voilà pour
ça
et non pas du tout mais j'oublie
Félix voilà Félix voilà
demandez si vous voulez des infos sur le
Salvador.
Très bien. Non non sur le sur le nom.
Merci. Et je lui demande, je lui dis
lorsque vous traitez avec les le Bitcoin
et vous avez quand même choisi le
Bitcoin comme monnaie officielle,
seconde monnaie officielle parce qu'ils
ont dollar
il vous avez gardé le dollar. Je lui dis
mais avec
Uyola
ou Yola, ouais, avec qui est-ce que vous
traitez ? On avait un traducteur,
qu'est-ce qu'il fait ? Il lève les yeux
au ciel et il baisse les yeux. Après,
j'avais l'impression qu'il cherchait la
Vierge. Il a levé les yeux au ciel et il
m'a répondu après avoir levé les yeux au
ciel en me disant "Mais il y a pas de
C'est comme si vous parliez à à c'est
c'est comme une religion."
Et pendant il avait tout dit. Voilà.
Pendant 2000 ans, tout le monde a fait
ça avec monsieur Or que je ne connais
pas et qui a servi de monnaie à
l'humanité pendant 2 ans. Mais
sauf que l'or c'est quand même un min.
Oui mais là c'est le grand sujet. Voilà.
Je veux dire, on a quand même quelque
chose qui va
rebondir sur les matières premières sur
tout ça. Je voudrais faire parler
Sébastien. Il il le vice-président du
Salvador devait être effondré que vous
ayez un tel niveau de méconnaissance du
Bitcoin pour lui demander qui lui avait
avec quelle entre bah si regarde le ciel
c'est quand même qu'il doit se poser des
questions. C'est il y a pas d'entrepris
qui représentent Bitcoin et et qui font
la promotion de Bitcoin auprès de pays.
Si elles sont toutes américaines, moi je
vous le dis. Toutes les entreprises,
c'est la fondation fondation. Je n pas
américaine
la mais vous êtes marginal vous. Ça n'a
rien à voir la foin.
Totalement. Bah bien sûr monsieur est
concurrent de de Binance, je veux bien
l'entendre. Je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec vous.
Mais mon entreprise est bien plus grosse
que que Premium que son entreprise.
Je suis pas du tout marginal. Je
vous entendu quelquefois me dénigrer sur
les réseaux sociaux mais mis à part ça,
j'ai jamais entendu parler de votre
société cher monsieur.
J'ai jamais entendu parler de la vote.
Non plus. Si vous voulez qu'on se fasse
ce genre d'amabilité. Moi j'ai une
nouvelle comp monsieur
mais je me compare pas du tout au grand
pas de déplacer sa de quoi vous me
parlez
moi je vous comparais à la fondation
bitcoin on parla des ben moi je vous
l'ai dit circle tter la fondation
bitcoin tes est pas
amé
ouais non ben
le siel de tes est à le bougano en
Suisse. Ouais. Non mais non mais vous
d'ailleurs une magnifique ville
tousch au on se détend.
Il est à Louano en
donc Tom
j'en suis désolé
la parole reviendra tout de suite après
Sébastien.
Donc il y a un tas d'entreprises Bitcoin
dans le monde entier hein. C'est pas du
tout les entreprises sont pas aux
États-Unis. Il y a des grandes
plateformes effectivement peuvent être
aux États-Unis mais les plateformes
d'échange crypto ce ne sont pas des
sociétés Bitcoin.
Il y a vraiment une confusion totale
quoi.
Sébastien, le le chiffre d'affaires de
votre société est déclaré en France.
J'en sais rien.
Ah bon ? Ah ben c'est vous
vous êtes bon pour travailler avec Bruno
Lebert.
Non non je suis pas le directeur, je
l'ai déjà expliqué. C'est étonnant hein.
Je suis pas le directeur financier de
l'entreprise. Donc si les gens veulent
Ça c'est formidable ce que vous dites
là.
On va laisser terminer.
Pardon. C'est dans votre ancien monde
vous vous connaissez vos chiffres par
cœur. Moi je m'en fous totalement. Je
suis un développeur. Le chiff d'affaires
de l'année dernière m'est égal. Ce qui
m'intéresse, c'est mon carnet de
commande et et l'avenir de ma société.
Voilà. De savoir combien je fais de
chiffres. En France, on a sep sociétés.
Je connais pas tous les comptes des sep
sociétés. Non, j'en suis désolé. Faut
dire, c'est qu'on n'est pas aux
États-Unis.
Vous employez combien de personnes ?
80 à peu près.
Le Salvador, on vient dessus. Vous
connaissez bien le Salvador. Pourquoi ?
Je connais bien le Salvador parce que
quand le président Bouquellé a déclaré
Bitcoin monnaie légale, mon entreprise
c'est s'est rapproché du gouvernement et
donc on est consultant pour le
gouvernement.
La DJVCE vous aidé ou pas
pour la partie mining ?
La DJE vous a aidé ou pas ?
Pas du tout. On est jamais moi tout mon
travail de relation avec les
gouvernements étrangers sais que j'en
j'en fréquente pas mal. C'est toujours
hors ambassade on narrive pas comme
français mais comme ambassadeur du
Bitcoin et du mining.
Pays en ce moment avec qui vous traitez
c'est qui ? euh différents pays, les
deux Congos, euh le Paraguay, Ouan, la
Finlande en Europe, euh j'en oublie
sûrement parce que l'Éthiopie, euh on
est en train de traiter avec euh
l'Angola par exemple.
Revenons au Salvador.
Hm. Donc le Salvador, je connais bien
pour y être allé dès 2021, y être aller
souvent et donc
moi je parie habité hein, donc c'est
vraiment un pays qui me plaît beaucoup
et et donc je pense apporter une valeur
ajoutée à ce pays-là. C'est pour ça que
je suis très intéressé d'y aller parce
qu'il y a un projet qui s'appelle la
Bitcoin City qui va être la prochaine
capitale du Salvador qui est basé sur
l'énergie. C'est-à-dire que on va l'idée
est de créer des des centrales
géothermiques. Il y en a déjà deux
actuellement au Salvador qui
fonctionnent très bien qui font 100 M
chacune 100 MW. Et donc l'idée là, il y
a un énorme une énorme capacité du côté
de la ville de Berlin et donc là il y
aurait moyen de mettre 2000 MW peut-être
plus. Et donc l'idée de construire les
centrales électriques et de construire
la ville moderne autour en s'appuyant
sur la rentabilité immédiate du mining
qui va permettre le développement de la
ville en le finançant.
Tom
non quand même être raisonnable je veux
dire après il y a une forme de logique
quand je disais quand même
non mais probablement mais quand je veux
dire globalement toutes les sociétés
aujourd'hui qui font le chiffre
d'affaires qui correspond justement au
volume de transaction des cryptonnaaies
sont des sociétés en grande majorité qui
sont installées aux États-Unis ou qui
ont lien étroit avec les États-Unis.
C'est une réalité, je l'ai cité
précédemment, Binance en premier qui a
un lien particulier avec les États-Unis
et vous avez par exemple la Security
Exchange des États-Unis qui a quand même
préparé un terrain formidable pour que
Bitcoin continue à prendre cette
ampleur. Vous allez à Los Angeles, vous
pouvez retirer du Bitcoin, vous avez des
guichets de retrait de Bitcoin. Moi dans
aucun monde jusqu'à présent et dans
aucun pays, j'ai vu les Américains, les
États-Unis, quel qu'ils soient, vous
appelez ça comme vous voulez hein,
l'État profond, la CIA, le FBI, le le
gouvernement, les administrations, qui
que ce soit. J'ai jamais vu un américain
laisser entrer sur son territoire
quelqu'un qui pouvait détrôner ou qui
pouvait déstabiliser le dollar. Je n'ai
jamais vu ça. Et par contre ce que je
vois par exemple, c'est que dans l'été,
j'étais à Monaco dans l'été, j'ouvre un
journal, je vois qu'en Iran on euh donne
je sais plus combien de de c'est pas ça
par rapport à leur monnaie, ça valait
rien, mais l'équivalent, on va dire, de
40 € ou 40 dollars pour dénoncer son
voisin lorsqu'il mine du Bitcoin. Ça
veut dire que les Iraniens font alors le
prétexte c'est pour pas déstabiliser les
installations électriques iraniennes qui
avaient été mené à rue d'épreuve par les
les conditions météorologiques. Mais je
vois que les Iraniens sont sceptiques
par rapport au Bitcoin et je vois que
les Américains par contre eux préparent
vraiment le terrain pour que le Bitcoin
devienne un gérant. Mais j'ai vu
Hollywood précédemment, j'ai vu des
stars américaines, j'ai vu le dollar,
j'en ai vu des choses comme ça aux
États-Unis et là je vois le Bitcoin
apparaître. C'est tout ce que je suis en
train de dire. Voilà, c'est je veux
dire, il y a une forme de feeling aussi
dans les choses.
Je vous laisse donner la parole soit à
votre gauche, soit à votre droite pour
Je peux la donner aux deux. Moi, je suis
pas autoritaire. Voilà, tour.
Je je rebondis sur ce qui a été dit.
Alors, c'est pareil aux États-Unis,
présenter l'arrivée de Bitcoin comme un
long fleuve tranquille qui aurait été
toléré me semble à peu près
l'antiréalité. Enfin, c'est pas ce qui
s'est passé. La SEC vient d'autoriser le
ZF en début d'année. Pourquoi ? parce
qu'ils ont fait 10 ans de procès et
qu'ils ont perdu et que c'est un état de
droit.
Euh mais même en en moment où ils ont
perdu ce procès, donc ils ont quand même
ralenti pendant 10 ans. Les ETF ils sont
failés depuis depuis
sont des produits financiers qui
permettent de faire rentrer dans une
case. Mais en gros, il
font indiciel disons. Voilà, c'est c'est
on crée du Bitcoin papier en quelque
sorte.
Exactement. Donc là, en l'occurrence,
ils étaient interdits aux États-Unis
pendant très longtemps. La SEC a une
bataille qui est pluriannuelle contre le
Bitcoin et d'ailleurs les autres
cryptomonnaaies
en disant que justement c'est dangereux,
c'est spéculatif et cetera. Donc ils ont
interdit ces placements financiers
pendant très longtemps. Il y a plusieurs
sociétés qui ont fait des procès. Les
procès ont été ralentis par la SEC.
D'ailleurs, quand ils ont autorisé les
ETF, une commissaire de la SEC qui
s'appelle Hester Pierce euh a même
elle-même révélé au moment de l'annonce
en disant "J'avoue que nous avons pas
respecté la loi." Ce qui est quand même
ce qui est quand même assez gros pour
une personne qui est commissaire à la à
la à la SEC de dire ce genre de choses.
Donc non, en fait quand on travaille
dans le milieu, on sait que aujourd'hui
tout ce qui est fait y compris
extrajudiciaire, c'est-à-dire allonger
les procédures, utiliser d'influence et
cetera, n'est absolument pas fait pour
faciliter Bitcoin. Globalement, tout est
fait pour empêcher Bitcoin de se
développer. On parle des CAR
hollywoodiennes quand on parlait, bah
elles ont pris un sponsoring avec une
marque qui les a payé comme sur
n'importe quel autre placement. Je sais
dans les années 90, on avait Catherine
Deu qui faisait la pub de Suède, hein.
Donc ça ça arrive partout. Donc là euh
pour moi c'est vraiment mal se
représenter ce qui est en train de se
passer. Euh les les États-Unis sur le
sujet Bitcoin, ils sont dans un dilemme
euh alors qui est un dilemme de long
terme et ensuite on peut-être à plus
court terme, il y a un sujet politique
avec les Républicains et les démocrates.
Le dilemme de long terme, c'est le même
dilemme qu'ils ont eu avec internet.
Je tr d'accord hein, ils sont en train
on verra. c'est que ils ont un sujet qui
est similaire à celui d'Internet,
c'est-à-dire euh internet, il y a eu un
côté euh on vient faire un réseau
décentralisé qui change la donne dans la
distribution et la communication de
médias. Euh d'un seul coup, on avant on
était obligé de passer euh par l'ORTF en
France et puis euh bon bah maintenant on
a YouTube, on a plein de médias, on a
des blogs et cetera. Euh les États-Unis,
ils ont réglé ce dilemme en disant de
toute façon, ça va advenir. Donc en
fait, on va laisser l'innovation et on
aura les gafas chez nous. résultat, ils
ont les gaffes chez eux même si les
médias traditionnels se portent moins
bien et cetera
puisque devenir ils ont été à l'origine
de l'internet
bien sûr avec Nco là sur euh Bitcoin ils
ont le même dilemme mais en plus grand
parce que on vient pas attaquer la
communication on vient attaquer la
monnaie et donc c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure c'est que Bitcoin est une
porte de sortie avant il y avait pas de
porte de sortie donc très bien
finalement les gens sont prisonniers
dans un système fiat dont on pourrait
dire beaucoup de mal là ils ont une
porte de sortie donc en fait ils
essayent de mettre des rustines partout
en disant non ça c'est ça on va
retarder.
Je peux vous couper ?
Oui.
Donc une porte une porte de sortie parce
qu'il y a un affaiblissement de la
confiance dans les monnaies. Il y a il y
a quoi ? C'est l'inflation qui fait
peur.
Il y a pour moi enfin là ce serait un un
sujet très long. Alors on a le temps
mais je pense qu'on va le faire en
plusieurs étapes. Effectivement le
système monétaire, on l'a dit tout à
l'heure en parlant de Bretonoods un
petit peu aujourd'hui, le dollar
américain, il est au centre du système
monétaire mondial. Euh, il a été
installé à ce centre euh en gros au
début du 20e mais surtout après euh la
2e Guerre mondiale. Et donc, ils sont
assis sur une une mine d'or, c'est le
cas de le dire, mais ils ont un atout
dans la lutte géopolitique mondiale
parce que c'est
papier quoi, une mine de papier.
Une mine de papier parce qu'ils font ce
qu'ils veulent euh avec leur monnaie et
que euh comme c'est la monnaie qui est
utilisée comme référence dans le monde,
ils peuvent en gros typiquement le
chèque Trump quand il y a eu le Covid,
bah il est payé par le monde entier.
Donc en fait les Américains en dévaluant
leur monnaies, il dévaluent les avoirs
d'autres pays parce que tout le monde
stock en dollar. Donc c'est un pouvoir
qui est quand même très important.
C'est quoi le proverbe ?
Euh je ne sais pas.
C'est notre monnaie, c'est votre
problème.
Exactement. Tout à fait. Notre monnaie,
votre problème.
Donc on a un problème avec le système
Fiat qui tant qu'il n'a pas de porte de
sortie en fait emprisonne les gens dans
les alternatives qui sont souhaites par
ce système économique, c'est-à-dire soit
consommer, soit investir, mais pas
épargner. Euh et dans le cadre de
Bitcoin, en fait, il y a une porte de
sortie qui a émergé et donc maintenant
ils sont en panique parce que cette
porte existe. Il y a encore 5 ans, il
disaient que c'était nul. Maintenant,
ils sont obligés de s'y intéresser. Je
termine par ce point-là. Quand je disais
le dilemme à court terme, c'est que aux
États-Unis, les Républicains se sont
intéressés au sujet Bitcoin avant les
démocrates parce que déjà ça
correspondait probablement plus aux
États qui ont un enjeu économique autour
de Bitcoin. Je pense au Texas en
particulier qui est devenu un un vrai
laboratoire à ciel ouvert. Il y a plus
de je crois 3 GW de minage installés au
au Texas. C'est absolument monstrueux.
Donc en fait, ils ont été obligés parce
que au aux États-Unis maintenant, il y a
à peu près 20 % de la population qui
possèdent des cryptos. Donc en fait, si
on est un parti politique et qu'on dit
n'importe quoi sur les cryptos, on prend
le risque de perdre potentiellement 20 %
de son électorat. Et donc ils ont été
obligés de changer de discours.
Très
moins bon si vous êtes pas exposé vous
perdez pas grand-chose. Mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que dans la sociologie
des gens qui ont des cryptos, ça va être
des jeunes, ça va être surtout des gens
de gauche d'ailleurs, c'est assez
intéressant, c'est plutôt aux États-Unis
euh mais c'est des gens qui maintenant
en font une ce qu'on appelle une single
issue vote surtout aux États-Unis, c'est
qui vont voter avec cette cette
problématique là et
qui a fait l'étude de qui détient quoi
là ? Alors pour le 20 % c'est Paradigme
qui est une société d'investissement sur
un échantillon représentatif américain.
Mais en gros les sondages sur les
Américains et la cryptof il y en a un
par un. Soit c'est TripleA, soit c'est
Paradigme, soit c'est La Fed. Souvent
l'ordre de grandeur est autour de 15 %
15 20 % des gens qui ont des cryptos.
Seb, on rebondit sur ce qui a été dit,
on amende, on complète. Alors mais en
fait parce que je vois bien que il y a
il y a un problème central dans
l'acceptation de Ské Bitcoin par Tom et
il revient toujours au fait que c'est
une fabrication américaine et que les
États-Unis favorisent.
Il y a pas lui, il y a pas lui qui il y
a pas que lui qui dit ça. Bon
pratiquement si j'ai été le premier
monsieur le mérite en tout cas de
reconnaître.
J'entends ça depuis que je suis dans le
Bitcoin.
La NSA, la CIA la Fed, on a eu droit à
tout mais surtout je vois pas l'intérêt
de se focaliser sur qui a créé le
Bitcoin. Est-ce que les États-Unis
favorisent l'adoption et le
développement de Bitcoin ? Ça c'est
évidemment non. On a tellement souffert.
Tu te mets un peu sur la gauche parce
que j'ai mon caméraman qui est en train
de gueuler
et mes collègues américains aussi.
La gauche c'est dans l'autre sens. Non,
c'est bien là que je vais te rapprocher.
Donc bref, ça n'a pas d'importance. Même
si les États-Unis même si la Fed avait
inventé le Bitcoin et même si
aujourd'hui elle essayé de le favoriser,
dans quel but ? Elle n'en tire aucun
avantage, elle ne maîtrise rien.
Moi, je connais bien la mentalité
américaine. Il trouve assez rapidement
le but. Laisse terminer.
Mais il y a aucun intérêt. C'estàd que
elle n'a pas la Fed n'a pas le pouvoir
sur le Bitcoin. Donc tout ce qu'elle
peut faire effectivement c'est
Si je suis si je suis détenteur de
beaucoup de Bitcoin et j'ai descendu
j'ai décidé. Non, heureusement.
Non, mais je parle de la Fed.
Ah oui.
Euh s'il y a un gros acteur qui tient
beaucoup de coup de Bitcoin et qui a
décidé de faire baisser le Bitcoin,
qu'est-ce qu'il fait ? Ah bah ça c'est
le jeu des baleines. C'est pour ça que
vous avez une telle une telle volatilité
sur le cours he ça c'est sûr hein.
Et s'il y a une baleine si je suis les
arguments de Tom, s'il y a une baleine
qui est proche du gouvernement
américain, qui est proche de protéger le
dollar, qui est proche de défendre les
intérêts américains, qui a décidé
"On va faire baisser le Bitcoin
aujourd'hui" ? Il peut
Oui, il peut certaines grosses baleines.
Oui. Mais
et comment on fait pour chasser les
baleines ? Ah, on peut pas ça. En fait
le au départ, il y avait que des
baleines parce que il y avait quelques
mineurs. Donc les gars sont retrouvés
avec 100000 200000 500000 bitcoin et au
fur et à mesure ils les ont vendu. Et
donc ça c'est ça s'est euh ça s'est
répandu. Euh voilà, au début ils avaient
tout hein. Euh aujourd'hui on a miné
pratiquement tous les bitcoins qui vont
sortir. On est presque arrivé au 20
millions pour au 21 millions en 2140.
Donc il y a des baleines, il y en a de
moins en moins de enfin il y en a de
plus en plus mais avec de moins en moins
gros portefeuilles en en nombre de
Bitcoin et je vois pas où le
gouvernement américain est impliqué dans
cette histoire.
Là vous connaissez mieux que moi, mais
la moitié des Bitcoin qui ont été minés
se trouvent dans quel pays aujourd'hui ?
Ben on nen sait rien par définition
internet sur
onarrive pas à loger le
il y a pas il y a enfin moi par exemple
j'ai des entreprises dans plusieurs
pays. Personne ne peut dire où sont mes
Bitcoin. Moi non plus ils sont sur la
blockchain Bitcoin. C'est là qu'ils sont
les Bitcoin. Il bouge jamais hein. Il
faut bien comprendre ça. Ça ne bouge pas
de la blockchain Bitcoin.
Vous êtes français que je sache. Oui.
Voilà. Donc vous êtes considéré comme un
français. Si si vous étiez un américain,
vous auriez je sais pas peut-être 40
millions de Bitcoin ou 400000 €. On
dirait que vos 400000 € sont logés en
France ou logés aux États-Unis. C'est
comme ça que je l'entends.
Bernard c'est un milliardaire français.
Voilà. En l'occurrence c'est exactement
la même chose.
Donc qui qui a l'argent du Bitcoin ?
Vous voulez dire qui a le plus quel pays
? Dans quel pays ? Voilà. Quel pays ? Il
y a des chances que les États plus de
Bitcoin que la France. C'est un plus
gros pays avec plus d'habitants. Mais
vous avez énormément de gens qui ont du
Bitcoin en Chine. Plus qu'aux
États-Unis, je dirais. Oui. Plus qu'aux
états je pense beaucoup plus qu'aux
états
beaucoup plus qu'aux États-Unis, je
pense. Oui, en Chine. Oui,
de toute façon dans les attends, tu as
fini ? Oui.
Donc en fait en fait ça n'a aucun
intérêt parce que l'inventeur de Bitcoin
même si on arrive à déterminer que c'est
la Fed ou la C
ou la NSA, ça ça n'a aucun intérêt ça
change rien. On a pas besoin de savoir
qui est le fondateur du Bitcoin parce
que ça lui a échappé. Alexandre et
ensuite Tom pour le rebondir sur ce
qu'il disait précédemment aussi
pour l'anecdote juste pour ajouter après
je laisse rebondir vite mais
effectivement dans les analyses
transactionnelles quand on regarde ce
qui se passe sur la sur la blockchain
Bitcoin pour le coup donc les
transactions qui ont vraiment lieu, pas
celles qui ont lieu sur au sein de place
de marché le classement des pays qui
s'en servent le plus où il y a le plus
d'adoption il y a le plus d'adoptions
notamment chez les particuliers on
retrouve pas les États-Unis le top 3
c'est de mémoire je crois que c'est Ind
Nigéri Vietnam il y a pas les États-Unis
les États-Unis ils arrivent en 5 ou 6e
position mais c'était pas le sujet de
Tom hein qui dit que c'est le volume du
Bitcoin qui est déu par des Américains
avec toi c'est que mais ça
ça ne fait que représenter leur part
dans le PIB mondial c'est tout c'est
exactement
Alexandre disait tout à l'heure dans son
au cours de son discours que euh les
Américains et vous le confirmiez
également avaient mis beaucoup de temps
à approuver Bitcoin
plus que ce qui voilà les ETF mais donc
par l'intermédiaire des ETF et de cette
appro Bah sûr
non parce que
le récepteur HF tu le sors de de ton
potin pour éviter de t'asseoir dessus
parce que voilà impeccable
et tu le mets sur le côté.
Très bien. Définis approuver Bitcoin
parce que il y aura des modifications à
apporter je
mais moi ce que je disais au départ
c'est que vous avez un Bitcoin qui
apparaît quand même pour la première
fois en 2008 c'est bien ça9
en gestation. Voilà, à partir de 2008,
on commence 2009 et là on est en 2024
aujourd'hui et vous avez quand même la
Security Exchange qui vous dit
finalement on considère le Bitcoin comme
une marchandise à l'instard de l'or.
Non, c'est la CFTC qui dit ça mais la
SEC justement se bat avec la CFTC pour
ça là ils viennent de la mais la SE le
dit aussi
maintenant ils viennent de capituler
parce que c'est un sujet politique. Donc
c'est bien ce que je dis pour
je parle d'aujourd'hui. Oui. Donc je dis
que la Security Exchange reconnaît donc
la Security Exchange reconnaît quand
même en 15 ans le Bitcoin à l'égal de
l'or sous ce plan là, c'est-à-dire comme
de matière première et on est en train
de me dire qu'ils ont mis énormément de
temps pour approuver Bitcoin. Mais
défin approuvé parce que j'ai pas
compris ce que ça voulait dire. Ben moi,
à partir du moment où c'est pas
interdit, je considère que c'est
approuvé quand les régulateurs, je dis
l'autorité des marchés financiers ici,
la banque centrale là-bas, la Security
Exchange dit bon, on reconnaît une
plateforme d'exchange qui fait passer
des volumes de transaction. regardez la
Non mais c'est étroitement lié parce que
la plupart des gens qui nous écoutent
peut-être aujourd'hui et qui ont du
Bitcoin ou de si on parle de français
par exemple, est-ce que vous croyez
qu'ils sont allés acheter une clé Ledger
qu' l'ont branché et qu'ils ont inscrit
en mot de passe pour rentrer sur la
blockchain ou est-ce que vous pensez
qu'ils ont ouvert un compte sur Binance
qu'ils ont mis sur la plateforme de
paiement leur numéro de carte bleue ?
Ils ont envoyé 500 dollars et ils ont
euh cagnoté leurs 500 dollars, ils les
ont changé en Bitcoin. Ils se connectent
sur l'application, ils regardent et ils
voient "J'ai 500 dollars de Bitcoin."
C'est parce qu'ils ont fait ça, les USA
l'ont approuvé. Non mais là on parle
d'un sujet, c'est parce que vous me
disiez que les plateformes d'change
n'ont rien à voir. Moi je vous dis, les
plateformes d'exchange n'ont rien à voir
avec le Bitcoin au même titre que BNP
Pariva, GP Morgan, la société générale
n'ont rien à voir avec la Banque
centrale européenne et la Fed. Sauf que
c'est étroitement lié parce que lorsque
vous avez la Banque centrale européenne
qui émet de l'euro par exemple, elle
garantit de l'euro, l'euro à cours légal
dans tous nos états de l'eurozone et
elle garantit de la monnaie banque
centrale. Ça veut dire que les billets
par exemple et les pièces qu'elle aimé,
c'est de la monnaie banque centrale. Ça
c'est le c'est le le la cou zéro. Et les
banques commerciales qu'on appelle
banques de second rond, BNP Paris-bas,
société générale ont un compte à la
banque centrale et elles ont elles aussi
de la monnaie banque centrale cumulée,
cagnotée, on va dire, euh sur le leur
solde sur leur compte auprès de la
banque centrale. Vous particulier, vous
n'avez pas de compte à la banque
centrale. Vous avez un compte auprès
d'une banque commerciale et là et vous
avez donc de la monnaie commerciale, de
la monnaie de second rang et du cash.
Ça veut dire non, vous avez pas de cash.
Lorsque vous avez sur moi aussi,
j'ai du cash moi. Respece en fait.
Respectez-vous à ne vous couper pas la
parole. D'accord.
Non non mais ça me dérange pas parce que
ça fait évoluer le débat. Mais je veux
dire vous avez du cash. Qu'est-ce que
vous appelez du cash ? De l'argent
liquide. Mais ça c'est plus à la banque.
Si vous avez il est sorti mais je l'ai.
Ce que je veux dire c'est que j'ai un
accès à la banque à la monnaie banque
centrale.
Ah vous avez un accès mais ça veut dire
que la banque en fait on voit pas où le
raisonnement pour
le raisonnement je vous le donne.
C'estàut dire que il y a déjà eu des
fêtes bancaires et au moment par exemple
où une banque s'effondre, vous aviez eu
la on va dire la confiance de déposer ce
que vous considériez être votre monnaie
banque centrale, donc votre monnaie
banque centrale à la banque commerciale
qui elle vous a dit tant que je tiens,
je vous garantis de substituer la
monnaie commerciale que je vais vous
donner l'impression d'avoir en monnaie
banque centrale. sur votre compte je
comme si c'était de la monnaie centrale
puisque les états reconnaissent la
monnaie centrale et là les plateformes
d'change ont un point central aussi
central que les banques commerciales
dans le système financier parce qu'elles
font exactement pareil et il y a plein
de concitoyens aujourd'hui qui croient
avoir du Bitcoin, ils ont des bitcoin
non ils ont envoyé 2000 € 10000 € sur
une plateforme d'écur ben vos 10000 €
équivalent à temps au cours du moment du
Bitcoin c'est tout simplement ce qui est
en train de se produire La différence
majeure, c'est quand même que par
rapport au système qui vient d'être
décrit, en fait, c'est pas du tout le
système Bitcoin. C'està-dire que dans le
système Bitcoin, il y a pas de banque
centrale.
On est d'accord.
Le Bitcoin n'est pas une créance de qui
que ce soit.
Donc c'est un actif oporteur.
Donc les Américains pourraient
l'interdire puisqu'il serait que de
particulier en particulier. Pas de
rapport. Et pour la fin du raisonnement,
ce que ça veut dire c'est que euh moi la
différence par rapport à une plateforme
entre une plateforme d'échange et une
banque, c'est que pour le coup dans la
banque je ne peux pas retirer mon
argent. Si je veux le retirer, c'est
soit sur un autre compte bancaire. Ben
non, en liquide.
Soit en liquide. P
au Lipan, au Liban, ils ont une
technique imparable. Vous pouvez
Oui, mais
pourquoi vous dites que vous pouvez pas
?
Je peux pas si je veux être intégré à la
mondialisation globalement, sauf si je
veux si je veux être intégré dans
l'économie mondialisée, je suis obligé
d'avoir accès à un système de paiement
numérique.
Ouais.
Ou alors, je vis que dans mon quartier.
Bah,
les Russes, c'est un gros quartier quand
même.
Bah, ils ont un autre système de
paiement numérique.
Il y a pas longtemps, en Allemagne, on
pouvait acheter une voiture à 30000 €.
un rapport au cash, c'est différent. Le
ce que je veux dire par là, c'est que
dans le système Bitcoin, cette
impossibilité de retirer en propre son
propre argent sur son wallet à soi, elle
n'existe pas. C'est principe, c'est
précisément ce qu'apporte Bitcoin, c'est
qu'on peut retirer sur un wallet
personnel. Donc faire la comparaison
marginale de personne.
Mais qu'est-ce que vous en savez ?
Bon, on va donner la parole au plus
vieux.
Ouais.
Seb,
je vois pas où va le le débat en fait.
Ah bon ? Ah ben moi je je vois pas du
tout Valdea. Le Bitcoin c'est un produit
paire à paire.
Vous voyez très bien.
Non pas du tout pas du tout.
Bitcoin est interdit par
Alexandre s'il te plaît.
C'est
la question c'est si c'est interdit par
les États-Unis.
Non ça ça viendra après.
D'accord.
Pourquoi le raisonnement de Thomas de
Tom pardon
est caduc à vos yeux ? Ah
je sais pas s'il est caduc. Je vois pas
où il mène la démonstration de Tom,
c'est de dire ça n'existerait pas si les
États-Unis n'acceptaient pas que ça
existe. Vous
êtes contre déjà vous, est-ce que vous
êtes contre mon raisonnement ? Oui ou
non ? Celui que je viens d'exposer la
question c'est ça, je crois.
Oui mais en fait je je ne comprends pas
ce raisonnement.
Ce que je viens d'exposer, vous le
comprenez pas.
Non je le comprends pas du tout. Tu vois
pas le rapport avec le Bitcoin en fait
en aucun cas. Mais oui parce que vous
connaissez pas bien le Bitcoin. Vous
avez pas lu, vous avez pas lu de livre
là-dessus. Il faudrait que vous lisiez
les liv
quel livre on viendra sur les conseils
de lecture après
? Je vais vous donner un un livre.
reformuler votre point de vue et ensuite
je redonnerai mais
je suis sûr que vous n'avez pas lu de
livres sur le MITcoin, ça j'en suis
certain parce que sinon vous sauriez
tout ce qu'on a vécu comme porte fermé
par les États et tout ça. Il y a qu'un
seul état qui a essayé de enfin il y a
que des États absolument
antidémocratiques qui ont essayé de
d'attaquer le Bitcoin et de l'interdire
notamment la Chine qui l'a interdit 38
ou 39 fois et c'est encore un des pays
où c'est le plus échangé les Talibans,
l'Afghanistan. Exactement et tout ça.
Donc ça c'est le genre de pays qui
interdit Bitcoin parce que c'est une
liberté. Qu'est-ce que ça ? Pourquoi on
interdirait à deux gars de s'envoyer des
jetons euh d'un ordinateur à un autre ?
Parce que ça concurrence la monnaie.
Oui. Alors, en tous les cas, je vois pas
l'intérêt de cette démonstration.
Les États-Unis n'ont pas interdit le
Bitcoin mais ont essayé vraiment de
contraindre les exploitants du Bitcoin.
C'est ce que propose aujourd'hui l'Union
européenne, de pénaliser les acteurs du
Bitcoin. C'estàdire que moi, je m'en
vais de France essentiellement pour ça
parce qu'il parle de nous pénaliser,
c'estàd de nous mettre en prison parce
qu'on défend parce qu'on est c'est notre
métier le Bitcoin. Il y a déjà des devin
qui sont en
J'ai des copains aux États-Unis qui sont
qui se sont retrouvés avec un bracelet
électronique, qui sont retrouvés
interdit bancaire pendant des années.
Moi moi personnellement 2017, je me suis
fait je me suis fait euh comment on dit
geler tous mes comptes bancaires,
comptes de l'entreprise, compte
personnel, compte d'épargne. Je me suis
retrouvé premier jour des vacances avec
plus un sous, plus une carte bancaire
qui marchait. Le CIC donc c'est
sont sympas au CIC.
Certainement toutes les banques sont
très sympas et j'ai très j'avais très
bonnes relations avec les acteurs
locaux. J'ai eu la même chose avec la
Caisse d'Épargne 5 ans après sans aucune
raison. Ça
sympa aussi la Caisse d'épargne.
Absolument. C'est ils sont très sympas
mais c'est une banque qui nous a suivi
pendant 6 ans qui est venu visiter la
ferme qu'on avait à Nant parce qu'on on
avait une ferme à Nant historiquement la
deuxième qu'on a ouverte après Odessa.
Donc ils savaient exactement ce qu'on
faisait.
Ça c'était pas la bonne adresse
non. Ils ont ils ont vu notre volume
grimper et au bout de 5 ans, ils nous
ont dit "En gros, vous êtes trop gros.
Je venais de faire le supplément weekend
des échos et j'avais mon portrait dans
le dans les échos, hein. Et et ça ça
leur pas plu au banquier. Donc le
directeur de la Caisse d'Épagne Ouest
m'a dit "Tu as été trop visible, ton
chiffre d'affaires monte trop et ta tête
dans les échos, ça passe pas." Donc
Nati6 nous a demandé de couper tout tes
tous tes comptes. Voilà, il nous
déteste. Il faut bien comprendre que
l'organisation bancaire nous déteste
aussi bien en France qu'ailleurs. He
est-ce que vous proposez une alternative
à ce monopole ?
Bah bien sûr, de toute évidence. De
toute évidence, ce que disait euh ce que
disait Alexandre, c'est qu'en fait on
est coincé dans un système, on peut pas
s'en échapper. Donc il existe une
expression qui s'appelle la fuite devant
la monnaie, mais on a rien pour fuir.
C'est aujourd'hui, on a complètement euh
rendu très difficile d'avoir de l'or aux
gens. Moi, je conseille à fond l'or,
hein. Je suis pas exclusif.
Pas là pour donner des conseils
financiers. C cette interview n'a pas
souvent il souvent il nous oppose
vocation à vous donner des conseils
financiers ou quoi que ce soit.
On le précise
je pense que je pense que d'avoir de
l'or moi j'en ai pas mais c'est même pas
un conseil financier. C'est juste
Mais pourquoi vous conseillez si vous
n'en avez pas ? Alors
parce que c'est difficile à garder.
C'est la différence avec Bitcoin.
Pourquoi c'est difficile à garder ?
Bah parce que moi je peux pas le
sécuriser chez moi. Ma maison est pas
assez sécurisée.
Vous avez bien une banque ?
Il est hors de question que je je prenne
de l'or pour me protéger des banques et
que je le met dans un coffre à la
banque. Sur.fr faire il vous loge à 5
vous
Oui. La semaine dernière on a découvert
que or.fr ou l'équivalent je ne sais
quelle boîte.
Il faut pas criminer des gens si vous
avez pas des sources fiables ou quoi que
ce soit.
Non non la semaine c'est très fiable.
C'est en tous les journaux la semaine
dernière il y a une de ces boîtes là qui
vont de l'or et qui les met dans des
coffres sécurisés pas hors poid machin
là et qui a et qui a déposé le bilan.
Donc l'or c'est très bien si on sait le
sécuriser. Et moi je sais pas sécuriser
l'or c'est pour ça que j'en ai pas.
C'est ce que je veux dire. C'est un très
bon euh c'est une très bonne matière
première mais c'est difficile à à
stocker et à sécuriser à la différence
du Bitcoin qui est très facile à
sécuriser du moment qu'on a une certaine
gymnastique.
Tom pour rebondir une dernière fois
sur ce qu'a dit Sébastien si Sébastien a
terminé.
Absolument.
Bah je suis pas du tout à fait d'accord
sur la la comparaison. Non mais voilà
mais on peut pas comparer une matière
première qui existe depuis des milliers
d'années qui est
moi je vais faire l'avocat du diable et
je vais prendre la défense de ça
pourquoi pas
pour miner du Bitcoin il faut des
calories électrique par charbon par nuit
nucléaire par
par hydro
par hydro pour aller chercher de l'or
dans une mine il faut le pékin avec sa
pioche la nourriture pour le pékin pour
sa famille pour l'éclairage donc des
calories
et du sienure aussi pour tout le
narratif fait le même que sur l'or
justement.
Donc et donc l'or c'est du stockage de
calories.
Ouais.
Et le Bitcoin est-ce que c'est du
stockage de calorie ?
Absolument. Vous allez chercher quelque
chose si je peux répondre puisque et
après je vous laisse, je suis bref mais
vous allez chercher avec l'or quelque
chose qui fait partie de la nature. En
philosophie, on peut dire que la nature
est Dieu. Auparavant, avant Spinoza, on
considérait que la nature c'était Dieu,
hein. Donc ça veut dire que vous allez
chercher la nature, vous allez chercher
l'énergie, vous prenez votre pioche et
vous trouvez quelque chose de rare et
que la nature a produit. Si vous creusez
beaucoup, vous trouvez du pétrole aussi
par exemple. Voilà, vous pouvez le
transformer en énergie. Avec l'énergie
que vous allez investir pour chercher du
Bitcoin, vous allez trouver quelque
chose qui s'appelle Bitcoin et qui a été
créé par quelqu'un qui n'existe pas il y
a 15 ans. C'est la différence.
Et le qu'est-ce que j'ai supposé ? J'ai
l'impression que la différence est
énorme. Vous allez vous retrouver avec
un un un numéro qui fait partie de ce
qu'on appelle une blockchain,
c'est-à-dire d'un protocole qui
correspond dont l'origine vient d'un
livre blanc, une quinzaine de pages
écrit par quelqu'un. Est-ce que vous
pouvez me dire pourquoi alors ce Bitcoin
si formidable puisque vous inventez les
mérites et la limpidité, la transparence
a été inventé par quelqu'un dont
l'identité est tenue secrète ? Je tiens
à répondre à ça.
Alexandre a donné l'exemple de la
monnaie Facebook et moi j'avais tweeté à
l'époque pour pouvoir proposer un
système monétaire concurrent du dollar,
il faut prendre un nom japonais et
disparaître de la circulation. Donc
voilà, il a fait exactement ce qu'il
fallait. Il aurait il n'existerait plus
Satoshina comme moto. Il aurait été
assassiné mais en prison ce que vous
voulez. Et donc il a enlevé une
ils auraient assassiné quelqu'un mais
ils n'interdisent pas le produit. C'est
pas assassiner quelqu'un. Vous n'arrivez
pas à comprendre qu' Non
mais la cocaïne c'est interdit. Je veux
dire moi vous savez j'ai un exemple très
précis c'est que la cocaïne par exemple
en pire tout pire il y a plein de gens
qui s'en vendent à l'heure où on parle
mais par contre s'ils se font arrêter
ils partent en prison parce que oui
c'est interdit je veux dire ben je vous
le dis le rapport ça veut dire que
aujourd'hui la cocaïne est interdite. Je
veux vous dire mais vous ne pouvez pas
empêcher les gens de s'en vendre ils
vont quand même le faire. Ils vont
braver l'interdit. Je vous dis oui mais
ça va être si marginal qu'il y en a très
peu qui le feront et effectivement c'est
le cas et surtout vous n'aurez pas le
droit et vous serez en proie des
sanctions avec Bitcoin. Il suffirait de
l'interdire
et donc Tom tend la perche et ensuite
quelqu'un saisira la perche.
Dans les années 70, les États-Unis ont
interdit la possession d'or si je me
trompe pas.
Non, ils l'ont rétabli dans les années
60.
Ouais, ils l'ont réétabli dans les
années 70 dans les années en 1933
jusquen 72 ou 76, c'était interdit de
détenir de l'UR.
Oui, tout à fait.
Et ça d'ailleurs été même fait de
manière très cynique puisque ils ont
fait la dévaluation du dollar juste
après avoir saisi l'or.
Oui. Oui. Bah, tant qu'à faire.
Tant qu'à faire. Oui, bah
mais les gens l'avaient gardé donc
et donc la question pour rebondir sur ce
que dit Tom, c'est imaginez-vous que le
dollar soit trop menacé parce qu'il y a
une fuite face au dollar parce que il y
a trop d'impression, il y a trop de
quantitative easing, qu'il y a de
l'inflation partout ou que les
États-Unis ou que les États-Unis font
n'importe quoi, les gens ont décidé
d'utiliser une autre monnaie. Ils se
mettent sur Bitcoin. Si les États-Unis
interdisent la possession,
les transactions,
ce qu'ils peuvent faire
quoi
avec votre cocoine aux États-Unis,
les États-Unis ne sont pas le monde
entier, c'est aussi pour ça que est-ce
que vous avez vu les difficultés quand
vous sortez de Swift ? Bah sur quand on
utilise Bitcoin, on s'en fout, ça passe
pas par SIF.
D'accord,
nous on s'en fout. Mais ce que je veux
dire, c'est que même si un état et je
pense que il y a eu plusieurs majorités
qui sont euh succédé aux États-Unis
depuis la création de Bitcoin qui sont
pas d'accord entre elles et personne n'a
interdit n'a tenté de d'interdire
Bitcoin pour pas se ridiculiser au aux
yeux du monde parce que l'interdire là
c'est le dynamiser ailleurs et c'est se
priver de cette mane financière qui
arrive aujourd'hui aux États-Unis qui
crée énormément d'emploi qui bouffe
énormément d'énergie perdue au Texas
mais également au Missouri et dans
différents États. Donc c'est une manne
financière énorme que les États-Unis
comme d'habitude comme avec internet ont
compris qu'elle était pour eux et qu'ils
allaient motiver les entrepreneurs à
être chez eux, à rester chez eux et à
venir chez eux à la différence de
l'Europe où on fait tout pour nous
pousser dehors.
Alex ?
Ouais. Alors plusieurs points d'abord
là-dessus euh je pense que les
États-Unis aussi ils regardent ce qui
s'est fait tout simplement. Il y a des
pays qui l'ont interdit, on l'a dit tout
à l'heure, ils ont des points communs
qui sont assez peu recommandables entre
la Chine, les talibans, de mémoire, on
peut en rajouter quelques autres
gloralement
Iran je sais plus, je voudrais pas
m'exprimer, je connais pas le sujet le
mais en tout cas bon bref, ce sont
ce sont pas spécialement des des des
pays très démocratiques. Si on constate
que la Chine avec son milliard et demi
de personnes avec une puissance
coercitive à minima sur son marché
domestique qui a quand même avancé a
interdit le Bitcoin et que ça marche pas
il peuvent essayer les États-Unis, il y
a pas de problème et ça continuera de
tourner. Donc il y a une forme de
théorie des jeux qui s'est mise en place
dans laquelle c'est trop tard. S'ils
avaient voulu l'arrêter ça aurait
peut-être été possible effectivement
2011-212out
le d'ailleurs c'est ce qui s'est passé.
C'est pour ça que quand tout à l'heure
Sébastien disait que c'est pas le
premier à dire que ça vient de la NSA,
de la CIA, il y a un épisode dans la vie
de Bitcoin où en 2011 quand quand c'est
encore très très confidentiel, fin 2011,
il y a ou fin 2010 pardon, il y a Julien
Nassange qui s'en sert pour la première
fois en disant bah nous on vient de se
faire bloquer tous nos comptes PayPal,
tous nos comptes et cetera. On a besoin
d'une solution alternative. On lui parle
de Bitcoin. Satoshi écrit sur le forum
"Surtout ne faites pas ça. Si vous
faites ça, on va prendre un coup de
projecteur, on n'est pas prêt." Julien
Nassange dit "En gros, je vais attendre
quelques mois, il le fait." Il le fait.
Satoshi disparaît, on a plus entendu
parler de lui depuis. Ce qui se passe,
c'est que 4 5 mois après, celui qui a
repris le flambeau, Gavin Andresen, est
convoqué par précisément la CIA pour
venir leur expliquer Bitcoin. Donc à ce
moment-là, on sait que la CIA déjà est
en train de mettre un pied dedans. Ils
l'ont pas arrêté, ils ne savent pas
comment faire, ce n'est pas possible.
Donc ça c'est un sujet qui est à mettre
de côté dans la mesure où même si ça
arrivait, bah on s'en fout. les
États-Unis sont pas le monde entier et
puis on ira faire autre chose ailleurs.
Mais pour revenir à ton à ton propos
tout à l'heure parce que pour moi c'est
c'est le cœur de ce qu'on se racontait
et ça me semble hyper important. Tu
disais effectivement il y a un lien très
fort entre monnaie et énergie et je
pense que ça il faut que les gens
effectivement l'aient en tête que la
monnaie globalement en version un peu
rapide c'est de l'énergie qui traverse
le temps et l'espace. C'est une façon de
résoudre un problème économique euh
qu'on a pas trouvé aujourd'hui d'autres
solutions pour résoudre à savoir la
double coïncidence des besoins, être en
capacité de faire des échanges
volontaires. Bah pour faire ça, si moi
j'ai un marteau et que toi tu as une
tunique et que tu veux me donner le
marteau et la tunique, en fait, il faut
qu'on soit au même endroit, au même
moment avec le même besoin qui est
précisément ce que l'autre a besoin.
Quand on a cette problématique là qui se
pose, on est soit recours, on a soit
recours au crédit, ce qui peut
fonctionner dans des petites sociétés où
les gens se font confiance, soit on a
recours à une marchandise qui va servir
d'intermédiaire d'échange et qui va nous
permettre de stocker de la valeur dans
le temps. C'est-à-dire qu'on peut
travailler, sortir un surplus et le
ressortir dans 10 ans en le transformant
dans une marchandise de quelqu'un
d'autre, soit le transformer dans
l'espace. C'est-à-dire que c'est plus
facile de porter une pièce d'or que de
porter un troupeau de un troupeau de
beauvin ou ou quoi. Donc ça c'est
l'utilité de la monnaie. Par contre, ce
qui s'est passé sur les derniers siècles
et en particulier sur le 20e siècle,
c'est qu'effectivement il y a une
perversion de la monnaie. Et en fait on
si on comprend pas
une perversion, une militarisation,
les deux. La militinarisation fait
partie de la perversion. Si on comprend
pas ce qui s'est passé sur la monnaie
sur les en gros 150 dernières années,
effectivement on peut pas percevoir
l'utilité de Bitcoin. Et ce qui s'est
passé, c'est que le monde globalement,
alors je le fais en version très
synthétique, mais on pourra euh
développer s'il faut, à converger vers
les talons or. Donc le monde entier vers
la fin du 19e dit "Bon, en fait, l'or
c'est super sympa pour préserver de la
valeur. On va tous se mettre d'accord.
L'or sert à s'échanger de l'argent au
niveau international." Et puis arrive la
Première Guerre mondiale dans laquelle
on suspend les talons ors. Pourquoi ?
parce qu'il faut financer une boucherie
et que effectivement on ne sait pas
faire si on a les contraintes de la
nature, c'est-à-dire un stock fini, de
l'énergie à dépenser et on ne peut pas
dépenser de l'énergie qu'on a pas
dépensé auparavant parce que pour
dépenser de l'or, il faut l'avoir miné.
Donc les
peu importe mais le pour le coup les
substitutions monétaires sont y compris
dans le colonialisme ont été un un
exemple monstrueux dans l'histoire
d'appropriation euh du pouvoir de bon on
pourra développer si s'il y a besoin
tout à l'heure
des perches hein
évidemment si on peut développer mais
euh effectivement dans l'histoire
monétaire la rareté a été très
importante dans les unités monétaires
que ce soit alors on a utilisé plein de
trucs en tant qu'humanité hein le
de tulipe
non ça a pas duré ça c'était vraiment
une spéculation voilà mais par contre on
a utilisé du sel qui a d'ailleurs donné
des mots français he solde salaire tout
ça vient du sel épices qui a donné les
espèces on a l'argent qui a évidemment
donné l'argent donc on a utilisé plein
de trucs différents mais il y avait
quand même une caractéristique
fondamentale c'est qu'il fallait que ce
soit difficile à produire parce que si
c'est facile à produire bah n'importe
qui peut me manipuler la quantité de
monnaie et donc flouer l'économie parce
que je peux inonder le marché de monnaie
et donc m'approprier le travail des
autres qui sont persuadés qu'en fait ce
que je leur donne est une représentation
de travail importante alors qu'en fait
pas du tout dans le colonialisme ça a
beaucoup servi parce que notam notamment
alors il y a eu un cas proche des
irokois et un autre en Afrique de
l'Ouest où les les monnaies utilisées
étaient soit des coquillages soit des
perles et en fait les Européens avaient
des techniques modernes. Donc eux pour
récolterier des coquillages ou des
perles, prend un bateau chalutier, on
ratisse le fond de la mer, on arrive et
en fait on s'approprie l'entièreté du
pays puisque tout le monde est persuadé
que cette monnaie là est rare et en fait
ça leur prend 5 ans de se rendre compte
qu'en fait pas du tout mais c'est trop
tard, on s'est approprié en entièreté du
pays. Donc je termine mon raisonnement
parce que je vois que mon
on fait la même chose avec le dollar.
Non
justement c'est là qu'on en arrive au
20e siècle. C'est que le 20e siècle on a
eu cette première suspension de l'étalon
or parce que bah si on voulait pouvoir
financer une boucherie, il fallait
s'enlever les gardes fous de la monnaie.
ça a été fait et Kanes même en parle
comme d'une une manipulation masterful,
je sais pas, je sais pas quelle serait
le la traduction en français, mais où il
y a eu une émission d'obligation au
début de la de la Première Guerre
mondiale par la Banque d'Angleterre pour
financer parce queà l'époque quand on se
finance c'est par l'impôt ou par la
levée de fond auprès de la population.
Et en fait, personne n'a souscrit,
quasiment personne, ça a été souscrit de
mémoire à 20 ou 30 % euh que par des
banquiers londoniens. Et en fait, ils
ont simplement émis des billets sur la
base d'or qu'ils n'avaient pas et ils se
sont autosuscrits leurs obligations pour
faire croire que avaient réussi une
super campagne de lever de fond. En
fait, il y a pas des entreprises qui
font ça aussi de temps.
Il y a beaucoup d'entreprises mais on
converge et on voit qu'effectivement on
converge vers cette manipulation où une
fois que ça a été fait une fois sans
trop de problème, bah c'est tentant pour
l'État de recommencer la même opération.
Donc déjà, on a eu les l'entre de guerre
pendant lequel ça a été un bazar monstre
parce qu'il fallait rattraper
l'inflation. On a eu la 2e guerre
mondiale où on a refait la même chose,
Bretton Woods dans lequel on met le
dollar et ensuite on a abandonné Bretton
Woods en 71 parce que les États-Unis
entre la guerre du Vietnam et les
programmes de Lindon Johnson, ça coûtait
beaucoup trop cher. Donc on est
maintenant, c'est c'est ça qu' faut que
les gens aient en tête. Pourquoi Bitcoin
est une solution ? Bah parce qu'il y a
un problème en face. Le problème c'est
quoi ? c'est que pendant quasiment toute
l'histoire de l'humanité, quand on avait
une unité monétaire, on avait un bout
d'énergie dépensé par quelqu'un dans le
passé. C'est une preuve d'énergie la
monnaie. Aujourd'hui, on est passé dans
un système de monnaie dette.
C'est-à-dire que toute la monnaie qu'on
émet, c'est de la dette. Elle est créée
au moment du crédit, hein. Quand on fait
un emprunt pour avoir un appartement,
bah on crée de la monnaie avec ce nilo.
Et donc le problème, c'est que ce n'est
plus contraint par le monde physique. La
seule contrainte de la monnaie d'ête,
c'est la capacité à promettre. Dieu sait
si ça n'a pas beaucoup de contraintre.
promettre du travail ou de la calorie
future.
Bah parce que le sous-jacent de la
monnaie aujourd'hui, c'est la
solvabilité dans le futur des agents qui
contractent les crédit. Donc en gros, si
et ça c'est parfaitement manipulable, ça
s'appelle un taux directeur. Si on fait
passer le taux directeur en négatif, ce
qui je le rappelle a été le cas pendant
presque 10 ans par exemple au Japon et
pendant 5 ans en Europe, en fait ce
qu'on est en train de dire d'un point de
vue économique, c'est qu'on est en train
de dire le futur est certain, on vous
enjoint à consommer autant que vous
voulez, à faire des crédits autant que
vous voulez. De toute façon, demain on
remboursera. Mais évidemment et pour
moi, c'est un des éléphants dans la
pièce du sujet écologie et Bitcoin,
c'est que ce système monétaire porte
dans son ADN déjà la croissance. Sans
croissance, il ne fonctionne pas parce
qu'il faut des crédits pour rembourser
les intérêts et donc il faut enfin de la
croissance pour rembourser les intérêts.
Euh et donc on est dans une forme de
fuite en avant dans laquelle on est
obligé de se cogner de l'inflation alors
que ce n'est pas le l'état normal de
l'économie est un état d'flationniste.
Les gains de productivité tendent à
faire diminuer les prix. Donc on est
dans une forme de fiction depuis à peu
près un siècle, un peu plus dans
laquelle et d'ailleurs sur les 50 ou 60
épisodes d'hyperinflation connus, il y
en a deux ou trois de mémoires qui ont
pas lieu au 20e siècle. Tout le reste
c'est 20e et 21e siècle. Euh donc on est
dans cette fuite en avant où s'il y a
une porte de sortie de la monnaie, ben
en fait le système s'effondre. Bitcoin
représente une possibilité de porte de
sortie.
Tom et ensuite Seb.
Alors si je peux me permettre parce que
vous êtes mon aîné ce que vous dites est
globalement de 1 an. Voilà, globalement
structuré, cohérent mais assez juvénil
quant à la structure du réseau de
brance.
Ça s'est déplacé.
Oui.
Allons-y. C'est pour ça que j'avais
préparé en préambule une boutade. Voilà.
Allons-y. C'est pas grave.
Et Juvénil en ce sens que vous amalgamez
la création monétaire par les banques
commerciales et
Sébastien il est en train de dire "Si on
pouvait me dire que j'étais juvénile
aussi, ce serait bien."
Non, j'aime pas ce mot. et les réserves
de change qui sont de la dette d'État
parce que ce qui compte beaucoup
également c'est ça quand on parle
d'endettement c'est l'endettement des
États aujourd'hui et pas seulement
l'endettement du particulier qui va avec
sa compagne acheter un appartement et
faire grandir le foyer familial c'est
surtout l'endettement des États et des
États-Unis et de l'Europe qui va se
surendetter. Là aussi, on pourrait faire
une parenthèse, mais c'est une
digression sur les monnaies numériques
de banque centrale. Vous pouvez tout à
fait imaginer que dans quelques temps,
les Chinois par exemple avec la banque
centrale de Chine se disent "Bon, nous
on n' pas vraiment un problème de de
prestation sociale ici. On va faire une
monnaie numérique de banque centrale
pour réserver la valeur. On va réunir
nos réserves d'or justement puisqu'on en
a beaucoup. Ils en achètent énormément.
Ils continuent à en acheter énormément.
En ce moment, ils font les provisions de
matière première.
Il continuent. Voilà. et on va indexer
notre monnaie numérique de banque
centrale qu'on appellera le China Coin à
euh l'or. Voilà. Et vous pouvez avoir
Christine Lagarde ici ou son successeur
qui vous dira euh de concours avec
Emmanuel Macron, les dirigeants italiens
allemands dire il y a de gros problème
pour payer les prestations sociales, on
narrive plus à lever l'impôt, je crois
que vous en avez entendu parler, on a
des états largement déficitaires. Ben
nous, on va faire de l'euro numérique
qui permettra finalement de signer des
chèqus spéciaux à tour de bras quand il
y a ils ont fait le chèque chaussette
l'année passée, ils ont fait le chèque
énergie, ils ont fait le chèque des
chèqus pour tout. à signer d'échecs avec
de l'euro numérique et dans l'intervalle
grâce à cela, nous n'abîmerons pas notre
euro traditionnel puisque ce sera une
autre structure monétaire. Donc là déjà
ce qu'on peut imaginer Ah non, ça
restera pas l'euro parce que ça ce qui
est bien précisé par la la Banque
centrale européenne c'est que l'euro
numérique sera une seconde structure
monétaire. Ça veut dire qu'il y aura pas
la d'ailleurs le compte ce qui est prévu
c'est 12000 € au maximum en en euro
numérique he à peu près 10000 12000
voilà ils ont même dit 3000 après voilà
donc il il modifient mais donc ça n'aura
rien à voir avec l'euro et le ça sera
une seconde structure monétaire donc là
au raisonnement que j'ai exposé
précédemment est tout à fait plausible
par rapport à ce que vous disiez donc
sur le la militarisation de la monnaie
mais donc j'ai pas compris où c'était
Jun enfin où est-ce que c'était pas bon
le
je vous le dis parce que vous amalgamez
la création monétaire par les banques
commerciales
les réserves de change des banques
centrales qui sont essentiellement de la
dette d'État et de la dette américaine
principalement et aussi le fait que dans
la rue vous pouvez vous vendre je ne
sais pas un article ou un autre en
faisant du troc en vous disant il y a un
problème avec la monnaie. Je suis
d'accord avec vous sur le fait qu'il y a
un problème avec la monnaie, mais on
peut pas mélanger les les les réserves
de change qui sont des titres
obligataires des gros états, le crédit
et en même temps le fait d'échanger de
faire du troc dans la rue et d'échanger
de la de faire ça avec de la monnaie et
que le Bitcoin, je termine mon propos,
je vous laisse la parole ensuite et que
le Bitcoin pourrait être finalement une
grande solution à tout ça. Le
quantitative easing, c'est-à-dire
l'assouplissement quantitatif, l'achat
de titre massif en l'occurrence pour ce
qui concerne la BCE depuis l'ir Dragy
sur le marché secondaire pour faire
baisser les taons. Je l'ai dénoncé dès
le départ. Je fais partie de ceux qui le
dénoncent avec le plus de férocité si je
puis dire aujourd'hui dans les médias.
Les dérives de la monnaie par
l'endettement excessif des États, je les
dénonce également. Par ailleurs, que
l'on me dise aujourd'hui que le Bitcoin
est la solution, ça revient au même
principe que de vous dire aujourd'hui la
viande est de mauvaise qualité parce
qu'on pique les bêtes. Plutôt que
d'arrêter de piquer les bêtes, on va
créer de la viande végétale et on va
tous manger un sac végétal. Demain, les
États sont régis par des personnes
cohérentes et structurées et on ne fait
plus d'impression de monétaire démesurée
et on revient à un équilibre monétaire
tel que nous l'avons connu précédemment.
met le chocolat dans le papier
d'aluminium.
Oui, c'est là il y a une naïveté
monstrueuse dans la
monnaie, il y avait pas des talons or
dans les années 40. Ah si
et ben alors vous pouvez pas le faire ça
vu l'état de l'économie actuelle si vous
voulez retourner à l'étalon ça veut dire
en gros diviser le niveau de vie de tout
le monde par
parce que ce que vous disiez sur une
dernière chose sur Bitcoin et je vous
laisse la parole quand vous dites et là
où je disais Julien ça aussi parce que
quand on vous a parlé de Bitcoin j'ai
entendu vous en premier puis vous
Alexandre dire non mais nous on s'en
fout même si on l'interdit h
h
ça veut dire quoi on s'en fout c'est en
ce sens que je veux dire juven c'est
interdit aux États-Unis moi c'est
interdit en France je m'en fous pas
voilà oui mais on sait très bien quand
même que ce qui est interdit aux
États-Unis rapidement être interdit en
Europe après hein, je veux dire jusqu'à
présent d'expérience dans ma courte vie
même généralement précurseur sur les
interdictions.
Non, pas vraiment mais à part ça, je
veux dire vous dites on s'en fout très
bien. Et vous dites on s'en fout
pourquoi ? Parce que nous on fait quand
même avec Bitcoin en pire tout pire.
Mais moi je vous dis non pas du tout
vous rêvez. Je vais vous dire pourquoi.
Parce que vous pouvez le détenir votre
Bitcoin, mais là vous avez euh une
matière première selon vos précepts.
Vous avez une matière première
numérique, allez, on pourrait dire mais
par contre, vous n'allez pas payer dans
la rue avec hein un commerçant. Parce
que si vous voulez sender le Bitcoin,
vous pouvez fuir, ben fuyez, partez.
Mais je veux dire, vous allez partir et
ailleurs, vous ferez rien de plus avec.
Par contre, au moment de payer,
fini le saucisson.
Fini le saucisson. Au moment de payer,
on va vous demander
pour le scinder le Bitcoin, comment on
fait pour scinder du Bitcoin si on passe
pas par des plateformes d'exchange et
pour payer la valeur de 2 € en Bitcoin
ou un paquet de cigarettes ? Comment on
fait pour s'en servir de mon ? Quand
quand je vous dis que vous avez pas
étudié le sujet, Tom,
ça veut dire que pour une transaction,
pour acheter les échos à 3,20 €, il va y
avoir quelqu'un qui va valider la
transaction derrière
ou Lightning,
ça va être ça.
Comment ça ? Alors,
non, mais le Bitcoin, il va y avoir à
chaque transaction. Je vais passer comme
ça euh au bureau et moi là, on peut
s'envoyer 20 satoshi, ça va prendre 2
secondes et ça nous a côté zéro.
Et vous passez par quoi ? Alors
moi je les veux bien.
Ça s'appelle du paire à paire en fait
c'est le principe du Bitcoin. Et
c'est validé de quelle façon ? Par des
validateurs que je vois bien
par mes ordinateurs entre autres. Oui.
Non mais il y a des validateurs derrière
sinon on pourrait faire passer n'importe
quelle transaction. Vous êtes d'accord
avec moi ? Vous
n'avez absolument aucune connaissance du
protocole.
Répondez à ma question. Mais les
validateurs sont les ordinateurs. Euh
mais il y a des gens derrière les
ordinateurs qui sont les bitcoiners.
C'est comme ça que ça fonctionne. On est
bien
Ah bon ? Ben alors je
ben vous devriez lire sur le Bitcoin
monsieur.
C'est juste un tout petit peu mon métier
depuis 8 ans. Il y a pas de validateur
qui valide transaction.
Vous avez débarqué Tom, je suis désolé
avec tout le respect que je vous dois.
Vous avez débarqué dans le game il y a 6
mois en disant j'ai tout compris à
Bitcoin mais je je réalise là à votre
inter. Ça c'est vilain aussi ça.
Absolument jamais dit ça.
Est-ce que
Bah si vous savez qui l'a créé ? C'est
la Fed.
Pas du tout. J'ai dit que je savais pas
justement.
Vous avez dit que c'était la Fed. Je
suis désolé.
J'ai dit que c'était l'état profond
américain.
Après je vous ai dit qu'on l'appelle
Cait c'est pareil. C'est la
Oui. Donc évidemment pour nous d'abord
ça n'a aucun sens parce que les faits
ont montré depuis 2009 que les l'état
poser à ma question. Alors
oui
pour valider, il y a bien des
validateurs qui valident des
transactions
et alors comment est-ce qu'elles peuvent
être continuez à vous couper la parole
je vous laisse avec le stagiaire il va
vous massacrer. Non non mais je laisse
la parole parce que vous parce que vous
vous trompez. Je suis désolé. Je vous
vous trompez. Il y a pas de validateur.
Il y a des non. Tom va reposer sa
question une fois.
Poser très courtement
et Sébastien va répondre.
Si vous fonctionnez en pire tout pire
Oui.
et que le système est ouvert en quelque
sorte, qu'il y a pas de validation parce
qu'il y a pas un organisme centralisé,
une banque, une banque centrale,
on est bien d'accord qu'il peut y avoir
un jour ou l'autre une attaque sur le
Bitcoin.
il a tous les jours mais il y a une
communauté on va dire de il y a combien
de de validateurs aujourd'hui en
activité définiss validateurs parce que
c'est un terme qui existe pas dans
Bitcoin.
Oui mais parce que dans le Bitcoin il y
a des termes totalement que pour que
personne comprenne ça veut dire que vous
avez des ordinateurs, vous avez des gens
qui sont branchés qui ont un ordinateur
qui fonctionne qui tourne chez eux et
qui valident des transactions. C'est ce
que j'appelle des validateurs bitcoin.
Ouais mais en fait du coup c'est pas ça
en fait
moi quelqu'un qui valide une transaction
c'est une
il a personne qui valide de transaction.
Il y a des nœuds, il y a des nœuds qui
sont des gens qui ont téléchargé
l'entièreté du registre. Ça, il y en a
20000 connus public. Ben vous venez dans
le il y en a 20000. Voilà.
Bah, il valide pas les transactions.
Ah bon ? Ils valident pas les
transactions. C'est
non, ils ont un historique de des
transactions.
Il y a 20000 têtes de nœud. Il a 20000
public valide les transactions.
Il y en a plus mais il y en a 20000 de
connu.
Mais ils valident les transactions et
ils sont payés pour valider les
transactions.
Non mais Tom, je suis désolé, vous vous
êtes dans l'erreur totale. C'est
absolument pas. Les validateurs ne sont
pas rémunérés. Ce sont des ordinateurs,
des serveurs qu'on laisse là dans un
coin. Don on peut pas se servir. Ça
prend toute la toute la capacité de
puissance de mon PC, moi qui valide par
exemple. Ça me rapporte pas un sous, ça
me coûte de l'argent en électricité. Ça
ne me rapporte rien. Il faut bien
comprendre ça. Et je ne suis pas
validateur. J'inscris j'inscris les
transactions dans la blockchain et les
transactions me sont déjà amenées par le
mining. Donc c'est non, je vous assure
qu'il y a un véritable problème de
compréhension. Il y a pas des gens qui
valident. Il y a il y a quelqu'un qui
décide de mettre un PC pour valider. La
preuve de travail c'est quoi alors ?
Vous prouvez quoi ?
Alors ça c'est encore autre chose hein.
Valider quelque chose.
Ah oui mais ça n'a pas rien à voir avec
les nœuds. Donc valider un bloc.
Tom Tom Tom laisse-le terminer pose des
questions après Alex prend la parole.
Très bien. Très bien. Je vous la
Non
non mais on part de très très loin parce
qu'en fait on pourrait dire que les
nœuds sont des validateurs même si le
terme est impropre mais le mining
absolument pas. Le mining assure la
sécurité du réseau empêche la double
dépense. Ça ça n'a rien à voir avec de
la validation.
Le dans le minage donné la parole. Non.
Alors tu as fini ?
Oui.
Donne la parole à Alex. Alex, vas-y,
précise.
Euh, dans le dans le
Alex, tu donneras la parole à Tom.
Ensuite,
bien sûr. Dans le réseau Bitcoin, il y a
plein de types d'acteurs qui sont
différents, qui n'ont pas les mêmes
prérogatives sur le sur le réseau. Les
rôles sont assez bien distribués, ce qui
fait que personne n'est capacité d'avoir
le contrôle sur le réseau à lui tout
seul. Il y a les nœuds qui sont pas des
validateurs, ils sont simplement des
gens qui hébergent le registre dans son
entièreté. Donc, ils ont téléchargé les
transactions depuis 2009, ils savent
tout ce qui s'est passé. Il y a tous les
tout le lien euh Michel a envoyé à Bob,
envoyé à Alice et cetera et cetera. Euh
donc le terme validateur, il est adapté
à d'autres blockchains comme Ethereum où
on parle effectivement de validateur
mais c'est pas le cas dans Bitcoin. Les
euh les donc eux les nœuds, ils
garantissent l'historicité de la chaîne
et le fait qu'on puisse pas revenir en
arrière. Donc le fait que tout le monde
a une partie de l'entièreté pardon du
registre. Les mineurs eux leur job c'est
de créer du consensus. C'est pas
exactement la même chose. Leur but,
c'est simplement de faire en sorte de
résoudre le problème initial technique,
à savoir qu'on ne savait pas faire avant
Bitcoin. Euh et d'ailleurs, la
blockchain n'a pas été inventée avec
Bitcoin. Ça faisait depuis 1982 qu'on
savait faire. Euh le minage, c'est quoi
? c'est de dire on a besoin d'une
technique qui nous permet de générer un
fait, peu importe ce fait sur lequel
tout le monde est d'accord sans qu'il y
ait d'autorité centrale qui n'est eu à
intervenir. Il se trouve que pour
trouver ce fameux fait qui est vrai de
manière universelle, Satoshi a proposé
les maths parce que c'est vrai que c'est
pratique pour avoir un truc universel en
disant on va résoudre une équation et la
le il y a une compétition dans le monde
pour résoudre cette équation. La
première personne qui trouve, le premier
ordinateur en l'occurrence, premier
mineur qui trouve la réponse à cette
équation, bah il a il a un chocolat euh
dans le dans le sens où il a créé le
consensus puisqu'il a une preuve de
travail, il peut prouver qu'il a résolu
une équation avant tout le monde.
Comment il le prouve ? Bah parce qu'il a
la solution et que si quelqu'un d'autre
a la solution avant, bah il avait qu'à
le montrer avant. Une fois qu'il a fait
ça, le réseau, il vient de résoudre un
problème informatique qu'on ne savait
pas gérer depuis l'informatique existe,
c'est-à-dire générer un consensus sans
autorité centrale. Une fois que ça c'est
fait, ce que Satoshi a amené dans le
réseau Bitcoin en terme de vrai de vrais
apport de Satoshi parce que la
cryptographie on savait faire, le pair,
on savait faire, la blockchain, on
savait faire et cetera. Le seul apport
de Satoshi Nakamoto, c'est qu'il a dit
"On va rémunérer ces gens avec un jeton
qui est endogène au système." Endogène
donc, voulant dire, il n'existe que dans
le système euh en l'occurrence Bitcoin.
Et en faisant ça, on vient de rajouter
une théorie des jeux dans laquelle c'est
intéressant pour des gens de venir
apporter de la puissance de calcul à ce
réseau-là. Mais si vous faites une
transaction qui est absolument alors je
sais pas ce qu'on appelle valide pas
valide d'ailleurs parce qu'il y a valide
au sens de respecte les règles du
protocole et il y a valide au sens c'est
pour des activités criminell si vous le
faites pour des activités criminelles.
Non non non pas du tout ça c'est légal
ça
valider ça veut dire que la transaction
est passée si
elle est conforme au protocole c'est pas
les en fait c'est tout le monde.
C'est-à-dire vous allez soumettre une
transaction et tout le monde va vous
dire bah elle est pas elle est pas
conforme. Donc je la prends pas.
Donc elle n'est pas validée
mais elle n'est pas intégrée du tout en
fait.
Voilà. Oui.
Mais parce qu'elle respecte pas les
règles d'un protocole. C'est comme si
vous envoyez un message sur internet et
que ça respecte pas http. Bah bon
courage.
Bah oui mais ce que j'étais en train de
dire
sur quel internet ? Celui qui est crollé
ou celui qui est pas crollé ?
Il y en a un qui est interdit que je
sache hein.
Mais en tout cas du coup c'est pas enfin
c'est pas exact ce qui a été raconté.
Ah ben moi ce que je dis c'est tout ça
Tom et ensuite Seb.
Voilà je rends la voilà merci et je
rendrai très rapidement. c'est que
aujourd'hui et moi je le dis très
clairement, il est impossible si euh il
n'y avait pas de plateforme d'exchange
tell qu'elles sont établies accepté
aussi bizarrement que je le décrivais
précédemment avec une opacité totale de
faire passer de multiples transactions
en Bitcoin comme on les fait passer avec
une carte bleue Visa ou Mastercard. Donc
le rêve de tous les bitcoineers
maximalistes de faire de Bitcoin,
premièrement une grande monnaie
d'échange et j'entends même parfois une
monnaie de réserve après euh me fait euh
doucement sourire parce que pour le
premier point vous pourrez pas tout
simplement avec un système qui repose
sur la on va dire la le la bienveillance
de tous les contributeurs et de tous les
passionnés de faire tourner les nœuds et
de et de le de le faire prospérer
pendant des décennies et en faire une
grande monnaie d'échange et d'autre part
vous ne pourrez
convaincre tous les États de dire vous
allez donner cours légal à comme je le
disais une structure
d'actifs ou de monnaie sorti de nulle
part mais qui permet justement de
dépasser. Vous regardez en Russie par
exemple les Américains au début de la
guerre en Ukraine et l'Europe les deux
et les Britanniques disent "On bloque
Swift quelques temps après." Pourquoi
ils ont bloqué Swift ? Aujourd'hui, si
vous allez à Gazprom Bank, vous pouvez
plus récupérer d'argent de Gazprom Bank
pour le faire viraler la BNP Paribas.
Euh, c'est sûr.
Ah oui, là oui. Oui, on peut pas. Je
c'est absolument possible aujourd'hui
ça. On peut retirer de l'euro. Par
contre, si vous allez à Gasprom Banque
et que vous disz vous dites "Je veux
100000 €" il vous les sortent par
contre. Après, prenez l'avion,
débrouillez-vous, sortez avec vos 100000
€ c'est compliqué mais vous pouvez
sortir avec du cash 1 € et ils en ont
beaucoup en l'occurrence encore
aujourd'hui. Par contre, le faire
passer, c'est pas possible hein, ça
passera pas. Et depuis le 1er septembre,
la Banque centrale européenne a dit à
toutes ces banques, vous ne devez plus
faire passer de paiement transfrontalier
quand elles ont des filiales là-bas. Il
y en a qui sont comme Unicrédit, par
exemple italienne ou des luxembourgeois
particulièrement ennuyés. Par contre
Binance au début est victime de même pas
de sanctions parce qu'on en parle pas,
mais se met à la mode en quelque sorte
des sanctions occidentales à l'endroit
de la Russie au début du conflit.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils font ? qui crée une
seconde plateforme qui s'appelle Comex
ou c'est Comex
Comex c'est autre chose Tom.
Non non mais oui oui non mais j'en suis
pas à ce niveau-là à ce que voudrais
insinuer monsieur mais qui qui s'appelle
Commex qui est dirigé par des anciens de
Binance et qui fait passer des paiements
justement Bitcoin. Voilà. Mais quel est
le rapport avec Bitcoin
les ben le rapport c'est que vous avez
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus de facilité à
sortir 100000 € en Bitcoin de Russie
pour les retrouver ici et après les
refaire virer sur votre compte que de
passer par le système bancaire. Et
comment se fait-il que les autorités ne
font pas tout justement pour empêcher de
contourner ? Bah elles peuvent autant
qu'elles font sur les banques. Elles
sort de doigt de leur faire la clé sous
la porte. Une ICR a fait des montants
record en bénéfice l'année passée en
Russie et aujourd'hui elles vont se
faire sanctionner. C'est bon crredé en
l'occurrence et les luxembourgeois aussi
par les Russes qui sont en train de dire
non mais en quelque sorte vous acceptez
les dictac de votre banque centrale
européenne mais on le voit pas comme ça
là on est à Moscou on est en Russie et
vous n'acceptez plus vos engagements de
banque et d'organismes bancaires. Et par
contre donc ça on met les banques dans
l'embarras les banques commerciales nos
banques européennes mais par contre sur
les plateformes de d'exchange de
cryptoonnaie on la joue au pas qu'on
laisse faire ils en créent une seconde
et on sait que ça ça passe. Voilà il y a
pas de tapage.
Ar, on a bien compris que vous aimez pas
les exchanges, mais nous
plus
et je vois encore une fois pas le
rapport si si notre propos
Ouais, mais premium ne fait que de
l'échange euro Bitcoin et depuis peu
Ethereum. Donc, mais c'est
c'est pas une plateforme d'échange
crypto comme Binance qui a peut-être
1000 jetons dans à proposer, qui est
vraiment un véritable casino, mais
surtout je vois pas le rapport avec le
le propos. dans tous les cas euh libre à
chaque état d'interdire Bitcoin s'il le
souhaite. On sait que c'est pas
efficient. Qu'est-ce qu'ils peuvent ils
peuvent interdire ? La possession, les
transaction sur les deux, ils peuvent
pas contrôler. Et le mining, ça le
mining, ils peuvent contrôler. Ils
peuvent décider de virer tout le mining
des États-Unis s'ils le souhaitent. Mais
ça va être
pour ceux qui ne savent pas, c'est
calculer le problème avec une carte
graphique. On reparlera de Nvidia un peu
plus tard.
Ah, il y a pas de Nvidia dans le
Bitcoin.
Ni ni de carte graphique. Ça n'existe
plus depuis 10 ans. Qu'est-ce qu'on
prend un coup de vieux d'un coup les
gars là ? Donc ce sont des machines
spécifiques qui s'appellent des des
asiques. Et donc le seul moyen de
rétention que peut avoir un état et
c'est ce qu'avait tenté la Chine en 21,
l'embargo sur les pièces.
Non, ils ont interdit le mining dans
leur pays. Enfin, ils l'ont pas vraiment
interdit. Ils ont demandé aux
électriciens de couper tous les mineurs.
Voilà. Et donc toute la presse
occidentale s'empresse.
Interdit le miningur Linky aussi.
Oui. Non mais c'est très visible une
ferme de mining. C'est c'est un très
peu comme les exploitations de cannabis
dans les
c'est beaucoup plus gros, beaucoup plus
visible. Non mais ça n'a rien à voir.
Une exploitation de cannabis s'il y a 1
kWh c'est de consommation c'est c'est le
bout du monde. Une ferme de maning on
parle oméga.
Il y a 10 ans, c'était plus que ça.
Même si c'est 10 même si
Salvador
même si c'est tout en compteur
électrique de 24 kWh, c'est c'est
epsilon. Une ferme de mining, c'est
gros. Donc ça se voit. Donc les les
électriciens ont coupé tous les mineurs
à la demande de du parti communiste et
les ont allumé au fur et à mesure en
fonction de de analyse. Ce que je veux
dire c'est que toute la presse
occidentale s'est emparée de ça en
disant "Regardez le la Chine interdit le
mining, c'est vous dire si ça pollue."
Voilà. Et alors que ça n'avait
absolument rien à voir, hein. À ce
moment-là, la Chine a obtenu des
électriciens que ça coupe le mining.
Tout ce qu'on sait que c'est 6 mois
après, à peu près la moitié du mining
chinois était était revenu et
qu'aujourd'hui il pèse entre 20 et 30 %
du mining mondial. Il est revenu parce
qu'il était parti au Kazakhstan fut.
Non, il est resté en fait la moitié est
resté en Chine. Une bonne moitié est
partie aux États-Unis, au Kazakhstan, en
Russie, un peu partout où ils ont pu
bouger. Mais beaucoup de Chinois étaient
partis du principe nous on a une boîte
de courtage en Chine à Shenzen, donc on
connaît vraiment bien le marché chinois
et nos collègues chinois nous disaient
"Nous, on est chinois, on reste en
Chine, on ira jamais se mettre au
Kazakhstan, en coupe gorge là-bas et
tout ça." Donc les gars ont attendu que
ça se tasse et ils ont rebranché. Et
donc les inspections locales ont
déterminé que bah quand l'électricien
avait besoin, il gardait le mineur et
tout le site avait énorm énormément
besoin de ces mineurs. Dans les 6 mois
qu'on suivi le ban des ce qu'on appelait
le ban du mining de de Bitcoin en Chine,
il y a je veux pas dire de bêtises parce
que c'est face checké mais plusieurs
dizaines de centrales hydroélectriques
qui ont déposé le bilan. Donc il y a eu
tout le syndicat des des
hydroélectriciens qui qui est remonté au
créneau et qui a dit "Mais c'est une
catastrophe économique, rendez-nous nos
mineurs, quoi." Donc euh
et la sau
pardon.
Non. Et la sau
voilà. Et la sau toujours dit-il
qu'aujourd'hui
il est trop vu, il a pas compris la
blague. He
non, moi je l'ai compris. Je sais pas si
euh
c'est quoi la sau c'est une sauce pour
manger hein. Non
Rick Mortti, ça vous parle ?
Ah ouais non ça je l'ai pas.
Je l'ai pas. Je l'ai je l'ai pas. Je
l'ai pas. Euh donc ce que je veux dire
c'est que même la Chine comme comme l'a
dit Alexandre, même la Chine avec qui
s'embarrasse pas de démocratie et qui a
tout pouvoir sur son territoire, le
parti communiste chinois, il a pas
réussi à vaincre ce truclà et en fait
ils sont rendus compte qu'ils ont tiré
plus d'avantage que ce que ça leur
créait comme souci. Donc euh
actuellement c'est fini. La Chine ne t'a
plus trop servi de
Tom et ensuite Alex. le projet même en
Europe d'interdire l'argent liquide à
terme. Euh motivation de la Banque
centrale européenne, l'argent liquide
au-delà de il parle même de 50 €
aujourd'hui et justement grâce aux
monnaie numériques de banque centrale
ensuite et l'hyperconnectivité en disant
on pourra lutter beaucoup plus
efficacement de manière beaucoup plus
efficiente contre le financement du
terrorisme. Vous pourrez surtout priver
une grande partie de la population de
liberté et les contrôler davantage. Et
donc là, il y aurait une structure
monétaire qui permet de faire quasiment
comme de l'argent liquide puisque c'est
à la fois un actif qui ressemblerait à
l'or et une monnaie qui ressemblerait à
du liquide puisque ce serait directement
de la monnaie banque centrale si je suis
votre raisonnement. Sauf qu'il y a pas
de banque centrale hein, de la monnaie
protocole Bitcoin et qu'il y en a jamais
plus finalement si vous avez du Bitcoin
comme le Louisor en gros quand même.
Voilà. Sauf que comme je disais
précédemment au début de l'entretien, il
faut quand même pas oublier une chose
pour tous ceux qui nous écoutent.
Dites-vous, est-ce que je détiens du
Bitcoin ? Bon, je le détiens pas sur la
blockchain. Moi, j'ai mis 2000 dollars
sur une plateforme d'change.
Moi, ça fait 8 ans que j'ai des
bitcoins. Ils ont ils ont jamais vu une
une truc exchange. G
ils sont tout tristes, ils sont tout
seuls quoi.
Mais non, mais ça ça n'existe pas pour
un bitcoiner. On laisse pas ses bitcoin
sur un exchange. On passe notre temps à
avertir sur Twitter, ne laissez pas vos
Bitcoin sur un exchange. C'est des noobs
qui font ça. Mais
est-ce que vous êtes Non, mais vous
appelez ça des débutants, mais je vous
dis c'est quand même 90 % du volume de
transaction en Bitcoin. Les chiffres
non, vous en avez aucune idée.
Mais si, mais ils sont pas mais ils sont
publics, vous pouvez le trouver. Vous me
dites la moitié. Ils sont pas publics.
Vous parlez du volume des
cryptomonnaies.
Je parle du volume d'échange de Bitcoin.
Le volume d'échange de Bitcoin, c'est 90
% sur les plateformes d'échange.
Ah, je croyais que vous disiez sur
Binance. Ouais, à la limite, pourquoi
pas ? Ben c'est pas ben voilà il y a
rien qui
donc ça veut dire que on est quand même
en train de parler finalement sur le
volume d'échange de Bitcoin réellement
de Bitcoin qui ne sont pas inscrits sur
la blockchain mais qui finalement sont
considérés comme étant la propriété de
ceux qui pensent les avoir au même titre
que les créances à la banque commercial.
Non, je peux tout à fait utiliser Pmium
demain pour faire une transaction. Euh
ça aussi c'est interdit de rebondir sur
l'autre invité. D'accord. Mais non, ben
parce que
ce que je suis en train de dire c'est
que tout le monde est en train de se
faire avoir. Premièrement, on croyant en
avoir du Bitcoin parce que ne pensez pas
que vousz vous ayez votre Bitcoin, vous
n'avez rien du tout.
OK, Alex va répondre à ça.
Sébastien, ensuite rebondiras sur Alex
et je lirai trois questions d'internet.
D'accord. On
on réitère à chaque fois sur la même
confusion. Euh le
Attention he Juvénil, je te suis à l'œil
hein. Bien sûr. Je voulais pas je suis
très Non, je m'en remettrai, il y a pas
de problème. Je je suis très clean
depuis le début. Moi j'ai insulté
personne.
C'est juste insulte.
C'est pas moi qui en a dit vous avez une
belle.
C'est vrai que ça été le plus courtois.
Oui.
C'est monsieur à ma droite qui moi je
suis très le monsieur à la droite c'est
Tom Benoît. D'accord. Tom. Donc je
tenais à dire que je suis parfaitement
courtois. Le problème c'est qu'il y a
une confusion que j'ai que je en fait
c'est
alors comment lui expliquer cette
confusion ? Mais je en fait je pense
qu'elle est entretenue. Donc c'est pour
ça je j'ai je en fait je savais
tellement qu'elle allait venir que j'ai
commencé le propos là-dessus en disant
euh Bitcoin c'est pas pareil que crypto
et Exchange c'est pas pareil que
Bitcoin. Et résultat on ne fait que ça.
Quand nous on parle de on va se faire
une transaction en Bitcoin là en 2
secondes, il nous répond euh ben en fait
non parce que Binance. Quel est le
rapport ? En fait c'est moi si je lui
donne 10 € il me dit oui mais BNP mais
quel est le rapport ?
Ben parce que la plupart des gens dans
la société fonctionnent avec la BNP
quoi. Voilà c'est comme ça parce on pas
le choix. Et oui ou c'est ça la vi sur
Bitcoin ils ont le choix
un dernier mot là-dessus pour rebondir.
OK, question internet d'ailleurs pour
Sébastien question. Je suis absolument
d'accord avec Sébastien, mais juste une
question que pense-il du fait qu'un jour
le ou la secrétaire au trésor se
réveille et trouve sur son bureau la clé
du wallet de Satoshi et il est
clairement à l'ouest sur ce sujet le
monsieur.
Donc imagine-toi, tu as, je relie la
question,
un million de Bitcoin
qui tombent.
Ouais,
on va dire 100 millions qui tombent. Et
donc OK, j'ai compris la mise en
situation. La question est qu'est-ce
qu'elle fait de ça la secrétaire au
trésor ? C'est ça.
Qu'est-ce qu'elle peut faire avec ça ?
Est-ce qu'elle peut influencer le cours
? Est-ce qu'elle peut faire sauter le
cours ? Est-ce que
Bien sûr, elle peut influencer le cours
avec euh avec 5 % de la masse monétaire.
Donc effectivement, elle peut tout
vendre d'un coup et ça fera chuter un
peu le cours pendant quelques temps.
Alexandre, tu veux répondre ? Tom, tu
réponds ? Autre question. Question
Takine pour vous inviter. Je vois trois
personnes en train de se faire une place
au soleil dans un domaine qui semble
aussi absurde qu'énergiv.
Sont-ils convaincus qu'ils participent à
la décentralisation
à terme du système bancaire accessible à
tous entre parenthèses auquel cas.
Bravo, fermez la parenthèse. Ou bien
assumet-ils leur statut de mercenaire de
la bulle crypto dont la visée principale
serait de siroter des my ta salvador ?
Il y a re la confusion dans la question
entre crypto et pas de my taille au
Salvador.
Non mais
peut-être je ne sais pas. C'est en fait
c'est toujours revenir au même au même
au même problème he c'est que oui dans
le monde des cryptos il y en a une bonne
pelleté la quasi totalité en tout cas
une grande majorité qui sont des projets
des arnaques, des ponsis des scams de ce
que vous voulez. Nous depuis tout à
l'heure, on parle de Bitcoin. Donc en
fait ça n'a pas de c'est alors je vais
peut-être l'expliquer différemment.
Quand les gens parlent des cryptoactifs
ou des cryptomonnaies, peu importe,
enfin cryptoactif est un terme plus
générique et il mettent tout ça dans un
même sac, ils se rendent pas compte que
c'est l'équivalent de faire la même
chose pour le monde des actifs
traditionnels. Qu'est-ce que je veux
dire par là ? c'est que ça ne viendrait
à l'idée de personne de faire une
analyse dans laquelle il met à à égalité
une obligation d'état américaine, un
Picasso, de l'immobilier,
un titre d'action d'une entreprise, un
meuble IKEA.
Quel est le rapport en fait entre tout
ça ? Il y en a aucun. Donc de la même
façon, s'il y a une bulle comme il y a
eu d'ailleurs il y a il y a un an sur
les NFT en œuvre d'art numérique, quel
est le rapport avec Bitcoin ? En fait,
il y en a pas le début d'un
commencement. Donc attention à cette
confusion parce que euh pour moi c'est
celle qui peut-être euh est à l'origine
de beaucoup de confusions dans le débat
public. Il y a un sujet Bitcoin qui est
un éléphant dans la pièce monstrueux qui
qui pèse aujourd'hui euh un peu plus de
1000 milliards et qui pesait zéro il y a
15 ans. Demain, ce sera probablement
plus. Euh le réseau Bitcoin sur la
blockchain Bitcoin, donc hors exchange,
c'est plus de transaction que Visa.
Chaque année, c'est 15000 milliards de
dollars pour 2023. Donc c'est c'est un
éléphant dans la pièce. On n pas besoin
de Swift, on peut s'envoyer des
transactions paire à paire, il y a un
enjeu géopolitique qui est monstrueux et
cet éléphant dans la pièce, il passe
dans le débat public à côté parce qu'il
y a beaucoup de gens pour qui c'est
beaucoup plus pratique de faire un
enfumage généralisé sur la crypto, tout
ça, c'est pareil. Donc en fait, on va
vous parler de telle crypto qui est un
scam, de telle plateforme au Bahamas qui
a fait faillite, de tel et alors enfin
quel est le rapport ? Donc c'est moi
pour répondre à la question, je suis pas
du tout dans le dans le mou de je vais
aller au Salvador siroter des cocktails
déjà parce que je suis pas un grand fan
d'alcool mais bon bien au salvador des
cocktails venir.
Mais mon enjeu moi je le raccroche la à
un petit peu l'histoire monétaire que je
viens de dire tout à l'heure et c'est un
enjeu qui est si je peux avoir un tout
petit développement là-dessus sur
l'environnement parce que il y avait un
mot énergivor dans le dans le propos de
la question. Pour moi, je pense que
pareil ici l'éléphant dans la pièce me
semble complètement
déconnecté. le problème
je pour recadrer le le le problème le
problème de l'environnement aujourd'hui
qui est qui est un problème absolument
majeur urgent
dans aucun scénario du GC on est capable
de respecter les accords de Paris sans
un volet sobriété qui soit important
en tout cas si je veux pas rentrer dans
ces débats là si vous pensez que le JC
est quelqu'un de crédible alors on n'y
coupera pas
sobriété heureuse
bien sûr le problème c'est que vous avez
un éléphant dans la pièce qui s'appelle
La monnaie, la monnaie c'est le
thermomètre et le sang de l'économie.
C'est partout. Tous les agents
économiques toute la journée dans toutes
leurs transactions partout sur la
planète utilisent la monnaie.
Mais c'est tout cassé la monnaie. Et le
problème c'est que justement le débat de
savoir si la monnaie est cassée, on ne
l'a pas parce que sur la finance, on va
avoir les sujets la finance responsable,
l'origine des flux, la RSE, tout ce que
vous voulez, mais le fait que dans l'ADN
du système monétaire, il meurt s'il y a
pas de croissance, que euh le système
inflationniste quand il fonctionne
atteint 2 % d'inflation et quand il ne
fonctionne pas, c'était encore 10,7 en
zone euro il y a encore un an ou de 10,7
pour que les gens se figurent, c'est
quand même un euro qui fait rien dans 5
ans, il a perdu la moitié de sa valeur.
C'est ça que ça veut dire. Donc tous les
5 ans, tous les 10 ans, vous perdez la
moitié de votre patrimoine. Qu'est-ce
que ça génère comme comportement
économique chez les agents économiques ?
Ça génère un comportement qui est très
simple, c'est que quand vous êtes un
agent économique et vous avez de
l'argent, vous avez trois choix devant
vous. Épargner et consommer et investir.
Quand vous avez de la monnaie fiate, le
choix de l'épargne n'est plus
disponible. Parce que
C'est pour ça que les Chinois tésorisent
comme des hamsters.
Bah parce que c'est beaucoup plus
intelligent de tésoriser dans l'or qui
est rare que de tésoriser dans un dollar
où vous êtes à la mercie d'une puissance
à laquelle vous êtes riv et qui peut en
imprimer autant qu'il veut. Je rappelle
la dette américaine aujourd'hui tu as
35000 milliards de dollars. On rajoute
je crois qu'on a dépassé maintenant les
intérêts sont le premier budget du
gouvernement américain. Donc euh on est
dans une forme d'accélération de cette
fuite de la monnaie. Euh et je conclus
par ça en disant que justement le sujet
éléphant dans la pièce au-delà du fait
que Bitcoin est l'éléphant dans la pièce
du sujet crypto dans le sujet
environnement et Bitcoin tout le monde
passe son temps à s'écharper pour savoir
si le mining c'est 100 TW ou 90 TW. Sans
jamais préciser d'ailleurs parce qu'on a
fait la comparaison tout à l'heure que
100 TW c'est à peu près la consommation
des sèche-linges aux États-Unis et que
tout le monde en a rien à faire des
sèch-linges aux États-Unis mais qu'on en
fait des pâes à caiss pour Bitcoin. Oui
mais c'est quand même et
je termine et je termine. Bon cracher de
l'air chaud sur le sur les vêtements
qu'on a la flemme d'étendre pour les 1 %
les plus riches de la planète. Je pense
qu'il y a d'autres choses en priorité
mais bon bref euh sur l'idée sociale des
sèch-linges, je suis pas là pour ça.
Mais le le sujet d'éléphant dans la
pièce, c'est de dire que aucun agent
économique dans le système monétaire
actuel ne peut respecter les accords de
Paris. Et on l'a vu parce que on met un
petit Covid là pour le coup, on était
sur les accords de Paris he - 4 %
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre.
Mais qu'est-ce qu'on a fait ? On a
doublé la masse monétaire parce queil
fallait payer les gens restés chez eux,
parce qu'il fallait continuer à
consommer, parce qu'on ne pouvait pas
sortir de ce système-là. Donc vous
pouvez faire autant de cop que vous
voulez.
Ça ne sert à rien. Tant qu'il y a un
éléphant qui s'appelle la monéfiate,
l'ensemble des comportements des agents
économiques de cette planète ne peuvent
pas aller vers l'épargne, c'est-à-dire
la sobriété et le temps long. Vous êtes
forcé de consommer ou d'investir. Et ça
se traduit dans des comportements
d'ailleurs qu'on peut voir chez les
bitcoiners. C'est peut-être un peu
contreintuitif, mais quand vous
connaissez des bitcoiners et qui font
des achats euh type comme j'ai pu faire
malheureusement, mais en 2015, l'achat
d'un verre de vin contre du Bitcoin, ce
qui fait donc aujourd'hui probablement
5000 € le verre de vin, euh le le le
bitcoiner moyen, des gens qui font des
sangrillas avec du mouton cad. Ah ouais,
exactement. Le le Bitcoin moyen est en
fait en réalité,
vous étiez jeune à ce momentlà, si je
peux me permettre, j'étais majeur. Je
rassure tout le monde. Euh le Bitcoiner
moyen bien sûr, le Bitcoin moyen est en
fait très sobre. Vous en trouverez plein
qui maintenant sont passés dans un
comportement économique qui est en fait
parfaitement rationnel par rapport à
leur monnaie de référence. C'est-à-dire
est-ce que j'ai besoin de ça ? Non.
Alors je reporte mon achat. Et ça vous
ne pouvez pas avoir ce raisonnement dans
le dans la
Alors alors Tom va reprendre la parole.
C'est c'est c'était les sèche-linges ou
les sèche-cheveux ?
Sèling sècheeling ça consomme beaucoup.
Je suis pas fanatique des
sèche-lingelinges parce que c'est
Ah mais des sèche-cheveux, je suis sûr
que si.
J'en ai pas l'utilité.
Nous on pasé avec Sébastien des
disons que ça ça abîme le linge. Mais
par contre que
ça abîme les cheveux aussi.
Ouais aussi. Ouais, d'ailleurs mais que
ce soit les 1 % les plus riches qui se
servent des sèchelinges,
trêve de plaisanterie, le constat que
vous faites Alexandre est assez exact
sur bien des points, c'est-à-dire la
militarisation de la monnaie, l'excès
d'impression monétaire pendant le Covid
et comme je le disais, je le dénonce
également, là où vous vous trompez,
c'est par rapport à la solution et je
vais vous dire pourquoi. tout
simplement. Non, même pas parce qu'elle
ne serait pas bonne, mais parce que si
j'arrive demain en vous disant voilà, il
y a quelqu'un qui a inventé qui
s'appelle Satouhi ou un autre nom, un
système qui a été baptisé Company Coin
et qui permet de procéder à du salariat,
de la facturation sans passer par les
autorités parce qu'il y avait trop
d'imposition. Sur la monnaie, il y a
trop d'impression monétaire et sur le
les contrats, vous faites un CIDD, vous
salariés, vous en avez pour une fortune,
vous payez le double. Moi, je pense que
j'ai envie d'embaucher mon jardiner en
pire tout pire. C'est-à-dire lui et moi,
je lui dis t la pelouse et puis moi je
te donne de la valeur et trava ça
s'appelle du travail au noir. Voilà.
Sauf que le Bitcoin, c'est pas de la
monnaie illégale, on le permet. Vous
voyez bien la distinction et c'est pour
ça que je vous dis que les autorités
aujourd'hui et les régulateurs sont en
train d'autoriser quelque chose qui
permet totalement de contourner ce qu'on
qualifie de souverain économique. La
monnaie parce que la monnaie fiat
fiducière c'est quoi ? une monnaie qui a
cours légal, qui est imprimée par une
autorité centrale qui est indépendante
parfois de Net mais qui est une
organisation suprême et qui est reconnue
comme ayant cours légal. Et c'est
pourquoi la France en l'occurrence dit
aujourd'hui depuis 2002 ou les
États-Unis depuis bien plus longtemps
pour le dollar ici si vous voulez payer
vos impôts, vous payez avec du dollar ou
avec de l'euro. Vous payez pas avec du
Bitcoin, vous payez pas avec une action
LVMH, vous payez avec de l'euro. C'est
de l'euro qu'on veut nous. Voilà. Donc
quand on nous dit le Bitcoin pourrait
finalement devenir une alternative
favorable à la monnaie qui a été
galvodée, dont les préceptés,
je vous dis mais si les autorités
étaient prêtes justement à laisser
entrer Bitcoin dans la bergerie, il
n'aurait pas laissé la monnaie être
galvodée tout simplement. La réponse,
elle est là. Pourquoi est-ce que vous
croyez d'un seul coup, ils vont vous
dire bah tiens, il y a quelque chose qui
apparaît qui va parfaitement à l'opposé
justement de notre système monétaire où
on peut imprimer de la monnaie, où on
peut faire de l'impression monétaire, où
on peut avoir le contrôle, c'est
centralisé, on peut vraiment tout
contrôler à la fois sur et là finalement
on laisse les gens se débrouiller entre
eux, ils peuvent faire passer leurs
transactions comme ça. il nous laiss pas
et donc
mais donc oui et donc moi je vous dis
toutes les autorités centrales
aujourd'hui, l'Autorité des marchés
financiers, les États, les
gouvernements, la Banque centrale
européenne s'il n'était pas dans une
covivance toute particulière comme il y
en a beaucoup depuis plus d'un siècle he
ça n'est pas nouveau, interdirez tout
simplement Bitcoin parce que Bitcoin est
un concourent pour la monna fiat et
qu'avoir la main sur la monnaie est
essentiel pour les banques centrales.
C'est quoi ? Pourquoi ?
Ben c'est parce qu'ils ont tout à fait
conscience que la monnaie effectivement
a été dévoyée, que ses caractères ont
été dévoyés, que le système était en
train de s'effondrer parce que le
système monétaire autant au niveau
bancaire effectivement est de plus en
plus fragile, de plus en plus précaire
et que et qu'il allait y avoir une
polarisation de système alternatif.
Parce que par contre ce qui va se passer
c'est que dans l'effondrement
aujourd'hui du système financier tel que
je le pressends, tel que je le vois, je
vois éclore d'ici les années qui arrive
mais très rapidement dans les 3 5 10 ans
plort à plort de système alternatif pour
faire passer des paiements pour
travailler et que les États et les
banques centrales ont préféré justement
faire une belle promotion à un système
alternatif qui pourrait être d'une façon
ou d'une autre contrôlé. Voilà.
Alors comment il serait contrôlé ?
C'est pas déconner ce qu'il dit. Si
complètement. Mais alors à 2000 % on est
à Non mais encore une fois moi ça fait 8
ans que j'entreprenant le Bitcoin. Les
autorités ne m'ont pas aidé Tom. Elles
ne m'ont pas aidé. Elles m'ont poussé
dehors de mon pays que j'adore. Il faut
que vous compreniez ça.
C'est un harcèlement. J'ai eu cinq
contrôles fiscaux en 8 ans.
Ça c'est personnel, on en a tous après.
Non, c'est pas personnel. C'est
l'entreprise c'est l'entreprise Bitcoin.
Vous voulez même pas dire où elle est
logée. Vous pourrez pas entreprise est
dématriculée à Nant. Enfin, toutes les
entreprises qui on été contrôlé, c'est
des entreprises françaises. Donc, on a
vécu un véritable harcèlement bancaire
d'État et tout ce que vous voulez. Vous
pouvez pas dire que l'État nous aide,
mais si vous voulez, si vous voulez,
admettons, c'est madame Lagarde qui qui
sosi la camoto,
pardon, mais si vous aviez entrepris
dans notre écosystème depuis tout ce
temps, ça serait tellement évident pour
vous qu'on n'est pas aidé par les États
ni aux États-Unis ni en Europe. Enfin,
c'est juste fou quoi. J'ai quatre
enfants, je suis en train de déménager
tellement on est menacé.
Ouais. Non mais c'est vous allez sur la
corde sentimentale. J'ai quatre enfants,
ça n'a rien à voir ça. On fait tous des
affaires. Moi j'ai pas d'enfant mais je
veux dire j'aurais des enfants, je vous
dirai pas j'ai deux enfants, j'ai ça
c'est ça n'a rien à voir les contrôles
les archer au pays rac pourquoi parce
que moi moi quand je vous dis
pardon, j'ai quatre enfants, je dois les
déscolariser, les mettre dans un nouveau
pays en Amérique du Sud en ça n'en pour
Guillon à la cantine vous plaisanter ou
quoi ? Ce que je veux dire c'est que
c'est compliqué beaucoup plus pour un
père de famille avec plein d'enfants que
pour un célibataire de changer de pays
comme ça. Si je le fais, c'est contrat
est forcé. C'est ce que je suis en train
de vous dire. Vous voulez pas
person.
Ce que je veux vous dire c'est que les
entrepreneurs du Bitcoin dégagent de
France depuis 2010 parce qu'on a été les
premiers en Europe. C'est bien parce que
on était pas à l'aise dans ce pays-là et
qu'on se sentait en danger. Et donc moi,
il faut vraiment que je me sente très en
danger pour bouger avec ma famille. Donc
c'est pas un truc personnel que je vous
raconte. Écoutez un peu ce que je vous
dis. Au lieu de beauté en touche comme
ça, on qu'est-ce qu'on en a à faire ?
Moi, j'en ai pas des enfants et tout.
C'est hallucinant. Je vous dis toute ma
cellule familiale doit changer de pays.
Arrê de parler mais je voilà je
toute ma cellule familiale doit changer
de pays. C'est pas la même chose que
vous qui veut des affaires et qui
bougez. Ça n'a rien à voir. Donc bref,
si vous voulez que ce soit madame la
garde Satoshina comme auto, allons-y.
Mais qu'est-ce que ça change ? Et là, on
est en train d'enterrer le débat sur des
trucs mais qui qu'on a résolu depuis des
années et des années tous ensemble. Et
là, vous revenez sur des vieux trucs et
on est en boucle là-dessus. Donc ça ça
n'apporte rien au débat. Moi, je
voudrais répondre au spectateurs parce
que il dit "Pourquoi on fait ça en gros
hein ? Est-ce qu'on fait ça pour boire
des des
Est-ce que tu es un anard ?" Parce que
moi j'ai connu le Bitcoin, c'était que
des anards qui faisaient du Bitcoin pour
payer ses cafés, hein.
Non, moi je suis pas du tout un anard.
Moi, je suis quelqu'un qui quand j'ai
découvert Bitcoin, ma recherche c'était
de comprendre pourquoi il y avait un tel
déséquilibre dans un monde en croissance
depuis l'après-gerre et pourquoi il y
avait toujours autant de pauvres.
Contrairement à ce que nous annonce la
Banque mondiale qui
Tu partais de loin toi ?
Oui, je partais de là. Ouais, bien sûr.
Ouais. C'estd que moi je je voyageais
énormément. J'ai beaucoup voyagé.
Tu faisais quoi avant ?
Je travaillais pour une boîte qui
faisait de l'agroforesterie à Singapour
et donc il plantait des arbres, des
plantations en Asie du Sud-Est,
notamment en Thaïlande et à Singapour.
Là où ça va être compliqué en terme de
réchauffement climatique,
ça l'est déjà parce qu'en Thaïlande
cette boîte là a coulé à cause de de de
deux saisons des pluies consécutives
pratiquement où les arbres ont crevé de
d'inondation. Euh parenthèse, mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que je voyagais
beaucoup et je voyais cette cette misère
galopante partout et je voyais à côté la
Banque mondiale qui disait "Le
capitalisme a sorti les gens de la
misère et tout ce qui est juste une
énorme manipulation. C'est pas du tout
ce qu'on constate sur le terrain. Et
puis le seuil de pauvreté était à 1
dollar en 1990.
1 dollar aujourd'hui il a 1,90.
Voilà. Si on s'était
et le prix du Big Mac a été à combien à
l'époque et maintenant il est à combien
? En tout cas, la multiplication était
bien plus que que 90 % supplémentaire.
Ça a plus que doublé. Donc, on a même
pas doublé le solut de pauvreté. Alors,
si on s'était
contenté de le corriger de l'inflation
tous les ans, aujourd'hui, on serait à
450 dollars. Donc si le seuil de
pauvreté était à 4,50 dollars, il y
aurait beaucoup plus de pauvres dans le
monde et on pourrait pas tout le temps
sans arrêt les libéraux dire "Le
capitalisme a sauvé les gens de la
pauvreté, tout ça, n'existe pas." Voilà.
Et donc, j'en suis arrivé à la
conclusion que le problème était
monétaire et j'ai découvert l'effet
quantillon. C'estàd que plus on est près
du robinet bancaire, plus on se gave et
il y a pas de redistribution. La fameuse
euh le fameux revuissellement n'existe
pas. Et donc c'est là que j'ai commencé
à m'intéresser à la monnaie. Et donc moi
ce que j'y ai vu quand je me suis
vraiment impliqué et moi quand je me
suis impliqué dans le milion, je me suis
impliqué professionnellement. C'est j'ai
arrêté mes activités, je me suis lancé
là-dedans parce que j'y ai vu quatre
points, trois points d'abord. Le 4è, je
l'ai découvert en travaillant dans
l'écosystème. Le premier point, c'était
l'inclusion financière. Aujourd'hui, il
y a 40 % des adultes dans le monde qui
n'ont pas de banque. Donc, ils sont
totalement interdits de rentrer dans une
une mondialisation qu'on dit heureuse ou
qu'on voudrait heureuse. Mais pour eux,
c'est le seul commerce qu'ils peuvent
faire aujourd'hui à l'heure d'Internet
où ils pourraient parler au monde
entier. Ils peuvent parler au monde
entier, montrer ce qu'ils savent faire,
mais ils peuvent pas prendre l'argent,
hein. Donc, vous pouvez avoir un site
internet dans un village au fond du
Congo, euh faire un un artisanat local
qui est magnifique, avoir un succès fou
sur internet, sur votre site internet,
mais ne pas pouvoir le vendre. Et
Bitcoin d'un seul coup permet
Oh, c'est faux. Ah
non, c'est pas faux. Euh et Bitcoin.
Alors, vous allez pouvoir me trouver des
petits cas au mais les 40 les 40 % de de
débancarisés de d'adultes qui n'ont pas
de banque, qui n'ont pas accès à la
banque, ils existent. C'est une réalité.
Après, vous
internat surtout, hein.
Non,
c'est beaucoup pour ça qu'ils ont pas de
banque aussi. Non, non, non. Maintenant,
maintenant mais vous encore une fois là,
vous êtes sur un sujet, vous le
connaissez pas du tout.
Ah oui, c'est vrai. Ouais. Oui, j'ai
tellement peu lu de ma vie, vous savez.
C'est pas une question de lire, c'est
que moi j'y vis en Afrique donc je sais
un peu comment ça se lance. tout le
monde aujourd'hui, même au Congo, dans
la jungle des Verunga, a un téléphone
portable. Il y en a au moins un par
village. Il y a internet absolument
partout. Il y a des il y a des
satellites aujourd'hui quand vous avez
euh oui, on fait du chocolat, il y a
internet hein. Mais ce que ce que je
veux dire, c'est que le l'inclusion
financière qui était qui était permise
par que je voyais comme euh permise par
Bitcoin euh évoluait à la vitesse de
l'équipement en téléphone portable qui
est fulgurante.
C'est vrai ça,
fulgurante. Donc d'un seul coup euh
Ah non, mais ça c'est juste, je suis
d'accord. L'inclusion financière était
limitée comme ça. Toujours pareil, 40 %
des banquisés alors que l'équipement en
téléphonie grimpait comme ça. Les
africain ne sont pas passés par le
téléphone à fil, ils ont pas connu, ils
sont passés directement au GSM et donc
ils ont internet dans le dans leur
smartphone. Donc ils ont accès à cette
monnaie. Donc l'inclusion financière,
c'est indéniable. Bitcoin c'est le
premier truc qui m'a sauté vos yeux. On
peut faire de l'inclusion financière
avec ce truclà. Il y avait pas d'autres
cryptomonnaies, hein, c'était Bitcoin,
Bitcoin euh quand j'ai commencé à à y
réfléchir et et donc Bitcoin permettait
ça. 2e chose qui était très importante,
c'est la résistance à la censure. Et la
résistance à la censure, c'est pas juste
dans le protocole une résistance à la
censure des transactions, c'est une
résistance à la censure d'un dictateur.
Et aujourd'hui, vous avez 30 % des gens
dans le monde qui vivent sous le jou
d'un dictateur. Et l'intérêt de Bitcoin,
c'était de pouvoir faire des
transactions dans ce pays. On ne à la
barbe du dictateur. Donc pour moi, ça
c'était extrêmement important. Et
aujourd'hui, les associations de
résistance dans des pays comme la
Russie, par exemple, les opposants en
Poutin se servent beaucoup du Bitcoin.
Human Right Foundation, son directeur
aujourd'hui est un Bitcoin convaincu. Il
il explique à tout toutes les tous les
mouvements de résistance dans le monde
qui adhèrent à Human Right Foundation
d'utiliser le le Bitcoin. Donc ça c'est
financé comment Human Right Foundation ?
par les dons essentiellement, hein. Mais
euh Human Right Foundation euh c'est pas
parce que le directeur technique et
ultra Bitcoin qu'il en fait la promotion
auprès de de ses adhérents euh que c'est
pas financé par des euh par des des
agences américaines, c'est fort
possible, j'en sais rien parce qu'il est
quand même il est pas il est pas comme
nous. Euh ce que je veux dire en tout
cas, c'est que ces associations-là
utilisent Bitcoin et les femmes
iraniennes hein euh peuvent utiliser
Bitcoin alors que sinon elles sont
coincées, elles ont pas accès euh au aux
échanges. Et euh et le 3è sujet, c'est
leur de cheat aussi, non ?
Oui, oui, oui, pourquoi pas ? La
première utilisation de énorme de
Bitcoin et qui l'a popularisé, c'est un
petit c'est
SCAD où on vendait de la drogue. Voilà.
Et le fondateur de SC est en prison pour
250 ans, je crois. Mais il y avait un
troisième sujet qui était important et
ça c'est ce que vous avez raconté tous
les deux, vous êtes d'accord là-dessus,
c'était
le la monnaie fiduciaère qui perdait
toute valeur parce qu' adossait à rien
et donc l'idée c'est de créer un nouvel
étalon monétaire. Et ma dernière pilule
orange, j'ai commencé le Bitcoin en
2015. En mars 2015, j'ai vraiment
compris que c'était ça les talons
monétaire qui qui allait s'imposer. J'ai
assisté à une conférence à l'Institut de
France qui était organisée par
l'académie euh
l'académie politique et morale. Morale
et politique. Euh et les trois
animateurs de cette réunion, c'était
Pebro, Tricher, Jean-Claude Tricher et
de la Rosière que vous avez reçu. Euh
poste bonjour.
Ouais. Bon, Jacques de la rosière que
j'apprécie beaucoup et
tricher un peu moins.
C'est ça
peu importe. Et tous les trois le but de
le but de ça c'était de le titre de
cette conférence c'était d'inscrire aux
objectifs de développement durable de
l'ONU la création d'un nouvel étalon
monétaire. Donc moi je vais à cette
réunion là, je suis complètement épaté
et je vois les trois gars qui font leur
discours et qui en gros font un énorme à
coule pas suite à 2008 hein que la
finance marchait sur la tête et que tout
ça c'était dû au fait qu'il y avait plus
d'étalons monétaires. Donc de la rosière
proposa un retour à l'or mais en sachant
que c'était extrêmement compliqué parce
que l'or avait failli en tant qu'étalon
et que ça allait être difficile de le
rendre moins faillible. Pebro plaidé
pour une régulation bancaire beaucoup
plus simple en bon banquier et Jacques
de la rosière euh non Jacques de la
rosière était pour l'or et tricher
tricher disait qu'il faudrait inventer
un nouvel étalon monétaire quelque chose
de numérique mais qu'on y arriverait
jamais en gros il voulait l'inscrire aux
objectifs de développement durable de
l'ONU mais il savait pas il savait
pertinemment que les États ne se
mettraient jamais d'accord sur la
création d'un nouvel étalement monétaire
il a dit pourquoi
pourquoi les États se mettraient jamais
d'accord parce qu'il sait très bien que
les États se mettent jamais d'accord il
y a pas il y a jamais d'unan
l'unanimité, ça n'est jamais arrivé.
Donc on en était là, il fallait créer
quelque chose mais c'était impossible.
Et alors que Beiton l'a fait, Satoshi
Nakamato l'a fait. C'est pas les États
qui sont mis d'accord pour créer cet
étalon. il est sorti de la société
civile aujourd'hui
et aujourd'hui il est proposé au monde
et il sera adopté comme étalon monétaire
à coup sûr, j'en suis convaincu, euh par
le par la base exactement comme l'or, ça
a pas été décidé que l'or devenait
monnaie universelle et talon monétaire
universel par un gouvernement. Ça s'est
imposé de soi-même et partout partout
dans le monde. Et le Bitcoin va
s'imposer parce que il est en train de
prendre énormément de valeur, que c'est
un c'est un actif extrêmement solide,
infiscable, incensurable et que les
États qui commencent à en accumuler vont
réaliser que c'est ce qu'il y a de
mieux. Et donc ça va devenir un étalon
monétaire qui va certainement
contraindre comme l'or contraignait les
comptabilités nationales à plus de
sobriété, arrêter de faire d'imprimer de
la monnaie pour tout et n'importe quoi.
Donc voilà, pour moi c'est c'est pour ça
que je suis bitcoiner, c'est pour
soutenir cet écosystème qui est en train
de naître. Moi quand j'ai commencé, je
pensais qu'on verrait pas le Bitcoin et
talent monétaire et même pas qu'on en
parlerait avant 30, 40 ou 50 ans. Donc
moi, je suis très surpris de voir la
valeur qu'il a pris au civil. J'en suis
ravi. Euh quand il vaudra 500000 ou
600000 dollars, il s'imposera de
lui-même comme un état monétaire. Il y a
toujours 30 % de plusvalue sur la vote
de Bitcoin en France.
Oui,
que si on les vend
sur les plusvalues des ventes.
Mais vous avez fait le Bitcoin à à 9 €
vous l'avez misé.
Ah non, moi je l'ai connu. Ça valait 200
dollars déjà.L
moi je suis pas un early, je suis arrivé
à la bour en 2015. C'était
déjà 200 balles.
On nous disait que c'était trop tard.
C'est
Et donc maintenant c'est à combien ?
58000 balles. C'est à combien
? Euh 61000 dollars je crois
aujourd'hui.
Tom
il a dépassé les 60000 là. Il était il
avait baissé mais il a franchi les
60000. Il est donc premièrement la
monnaie la plus sûre aujourd'hui ça
serait laquelle ? Les DTS finalement les
droits de tirage spéciaux du FME. Si on
part d'un principe assez dissident déjà,
plus le dollar plus l'euro. Donc des
gouvernements qui s'entendrait comme
l'axposé Sébastien précédemment
effectivement pour créer un nouvel
étalon. En effet, ça pourrait être un
étalon. Les briques, ça en avait parlé
qui serait basé sur les matières
provises, les matières premières et un
panier de devise. Ça pourrait être ça.
Et un peu l'or aussi. C'est ce qu'ils
avaient dit le 22 août 2023 l'année
passée et finalement c'était un peu trop
tôt pour avancer. Ça n'arrangeait pas
les Chinois qui voulaient encore garder
une forme de monopole avec le yan et lui
faire prendre de la valeur. Et
d'ailleurs, c'est intéressant
aujourd'hui d'observer que la politique
chinoise est euh finalement
insidieusement un peu la politique
américaine des temps passés.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils sont en train de de
ils entretiennent une courbe des taux
assez euh harmonieuse. qui prennent soin
de pas
exagérer sur l'impression monétaire et
le rachat de titre pour tenter d'avoir
UAN qui prennent un peu de valeur au fur
et à mesure et qui puissent leur
permettre d'avoir plus de crédibilité
auprès notamment de l'Indonésie, du
Japon, de l'Inde, c'est-à-dire de tous
les pays très proches et également de
l'Arabie Saoudite par exemple qui se
sert un peu du comme monnaie d'échange
même sur des matières premières
énergétiques, ce qui est une première
depuis quelques temps. Et par rapport au
Bitcoin, ce que dit Sébastien
précédemment est juste sur toute la
ligne, mais c'est simplement la
globalité et la fin qui ne tient pas du
tout. C'est qu'on est en train de vous
dire tous les banquiers centraux se sont
dit, on est en train d'essayer
d'inventer justement cette nouvelle
monnaie un peu raisonnable, ce nouvel
étalon qui permettrait de restructurer
la monnaie. Mais on ne parviendra pas à
s'entendre. On ne parvient pas à
s'entendre. On narrive pas avec l'eau,
on narrive pas à créer sa structure.
Mais là, on est en train de nous dire
finalement que tiens donc il en est
apparu une sortie de nulle part il y a
15 ans et qu'elle va s'installer avec
autant de facilité que l'or en 3000 ans
ou 4000 ans. C'est ce que ce qui est en
train d'expliquer mon voisin de de
droite. Le Bitcoin n'était pas là il y a
15 ans et vous me dites comment l'or est
devenu finalement l'étalon. Ça s'est
fait petit à petit. Absolument.
Et donc ça veut dire que vous présagez
peut-être que le Bitcoin sera étalon
dans 2000 ans mais j'ai pas l'impression
que c'était l'objet de votre propos.
Vous vous êtes en train de me dire que
dans les 10 ans ce sera baclé.
50 ans
voilà 50 ans à échelle de de plusieurs
milliers d'années. 50 ans c'est rien du
tout.
Tout va beaucoup plus vite aujourd'hui.
Et monsieur me disait précédemment
Alexandre mais tu vous rendez pas compte
pendant des années, on a bataillé auprès
des autorités justement pour que le
Bitcoin soit reconnu. On nous a fait ça
a mis énormément de temps. Énormément de
temps. Ça a été 10 ans. Donc ça veut
dire que en en 10 ans si il est reconnu
par l'intermédiaire, je vais pas revenir
sur tout ce que j'ai dit mais et même
ici l'autorité des marchés financiers
reconnaît Binance
non mais qui fait passer des volumes de
transaction de Bitcoin. et il est
principalement de Bitcoin. La première
crypto qui passe la première crypto qui
passe sur Binance, vous pouvez pas me
dire que c'est pas Bitcoin, c'est
Bitcoin. Et vous le savez très bien.
Coin Base, vous pouvez aller n'importe
où, vous savez. C'est pas
non mais euh euh Coin le
euh voilà qui a été racheté par
euh euh récemment d'ailleurs et mais
vous pouvez aller sur n'importe quel
site d'actualité zone bourse où vous
verrez très bien que voilà le la
première les premiers volumes de
transaction de cryptomonnaie c'est c'est
Bitcoin voilà sur Binance. Et donc ça
c'est approuvé c'est une réalité ça a
été approuvé.
Approuvé c'est enregistré
c'est approuvé comme Non non c'est faux
ce que vous dites. C'est faux. Quand je
dis que c'est approuvé c'est que c'est
enregistré. comme société ayant la
capacité de faire passer des
transactions en cryptoactif. Et ça
correspond à une approbation ça monsieur
parce que si une société est
enregistrée, ça veut dire que moi demain
j'enregistre une société avec un code
APE qui a un numéro de tiret, je
l'appelle agence immobilière Benoît.
Elle est enregistrée, elle est approuvée
à partir du moment où la Chambre de
commerce me donne une carte
professionnelle qui me permet d'exercer.
Et là, l'AMF a donné son approbation en
disant "Nous reconnaissons cette société
comme ayant la capacité de faire passer
des transactions en interprétation ou
c'est euh gravé dans le mar ce que
alors une société qui aurait que
l'enregistrement à partir de janvier,
elle a plus le droit." Donc c'est voilà,
mais c'est
encore une fois, il y a beaucoup de
confusion dans les dans les choses qui
sont énoncées parce que on reconfond
crypto, plateforme d'échange, Bitcoin et
cetera et on confond aussi également une
chose et je pense que ça pense ça sort
du raisonnement de de Tom, c'est que
typiquement prenons le le cas des
États-Unis avec la SEC qui a donc
bataillé dans le camp de ceux qui ne
voulaient pas entendre parler de Bitcoin
pendant 10 ans dans des procès et qui a
perdu son procès et qui la mort mort
dans l'âme a été obligé d'annoncer que
finalement ils allaient tolérer le fait
qu'il y avait des ETF sur le marché
américain. Je précise d'ailleurs que
Gary Gensler donc est le patron de la
SEC
ETF Exchange
les fameux indices répliquant le Bitcoin
donc les les les Bitcoin papier entre
guillemets. Euh je précise qu'il n'a
d'ailleurs même pas respecté la loi
puisqueil était il avait beau être
contraint par la loi d'accepter le
Bitcoin et d'être ce qu'on appelle
mérite neutral, c'est-à-dire que on
n'attend pas de la SEC qu'elle dise l'or
c'est bien ou le bois c'est mal. On
attend de la SEC qu'elle fasse son job.
C'est-à-dire dire on va offrir un cadre
de sécurité pour les investisseurs.
Malgré ça, le jour où ça a été forcé par
un tribunal, je rappelle qu'aux
États-Unis la séparation des pouvoirs
est un peu plus mieux assurée qu'en
France, mais je va pas lancer le débat.
Le le Gary Gensler a publié ce jour-là
un truc qui disait "Ouais, on a beau
être mérite neutral mais Bitcoin, je
tiens à vous rappeler que c'est nul, ça
finance le terrorisme, ça détruit la
planète et cetera." Donc il a beau avoir
perdu son procès, il a même pas
abandonné la bataille. On a pris 10 ans
et on confond ici le sujet du mérite
neutral avec le sujet de l'approbation.
Lorsque l'AMF dit "Telle entreprise euh
selon la loi PACET en l'occurrence 2018
qui va être remplacée par le règlement
MIKA, je vais pas embêter les gens avec
des avec voilà, mais en gros la loi
européenne, la loi européenne qui va
s'appliquer à partir de janvier. Euh
quand on euh rentre là-dedans, le le
règlement européen ce qu'il dit c'est
pas euh Bitcoin est bien ou mal.
D'ailleurs, il a longtemps essayé de
dire Bitcoin est mal. Je reprécise
qu'ils ont essayé d'interdire le proof
of work. Ça a été proposé comme
amendement. On a eu certaines députés
européennes dont je ne citerai pas le
nom qui ont proposé d'interdire la
propriété privée parce que pourquoi pas
euh
non
bah si interdiction des des
portefeuilles self custodier
et c'était Sandrine
c'était pas Sandrine. Ah
c'était Madame Aurore les gens
reconnaîtront. Euh donc cet amendement
existe he Paul Tang Aurore en
l'occurrence qui écrit interdiction des
portefeuilles autohébergés. Donc vous
motif de l'amendement je cite presque de
tête empêcher la sortie du système
réglementé. Mais selon Tom, ceci
constitue une aide formidable puisque
évidemment c'est toléré. Donc ça c'est
les genres d'abonnement qui juvénil tu
as pas apprécié hein.
Non mais c'est pas une question du
juvénil, c'est juste qu'en fait ça ne
correspond pas à la réalité. Ça fait 10
ans ma boîte ça
la sécurité chis le Bitcoin comme une
marchandise comme une matière de faisais
ont jamais reconnu les rang essayer de
faire un Alexandre pour aller aux
États-Unis en disant je suis allé en
Iran l'année passée. Ils vous diront pas
c'est vrai qu'on est plus fâché. Ben le
rapport c'est que les Américains ont
pour habitude sanctionner la vi finir.
Ouais. Ouis. Je parler
dans la loi américaine, il y a un
embargo sur l'Iran. Donc la SEC, elle se
positionne par rapport à la loi. Si elle
respecte la loi, il y a l'embargo sur
l'Iran. Dans la loi américaine, si c'est
une commodity, il y a pas lieu d'être
mérite non neutral. Donc la SEC s'est
pris un procès. Au bout de 10 ans,
l'état de droit fonctionne et dit à la
SEC et ben en fait, vous avez pas le
droit de faire ce que vous avez fait. En
France, c'est pareil. On a la MF qui dit
depuis un certain nombre d'années, bon
après encore un sujet sur la
surveillance financière et sur le fait
que la MF aujourd'hui
je peux faire une digration de 10
secondes, je peux pas. Je
la MF aujourd'hui d'ailleurs nouvelle
présidente qui était précédemment
directrice générale de la FBF euh rien
en soit déjà drôle, enfin pas si drôle
que ça d'ailleurs, mais bon c'est un
autre sujet. En France, on a la
reconnaissance de la capacité à ouvrir
des services financiers sur des choses
qui sont à peine définies par la loi.
Mais la loi aujourd'hui ne peut pas se
positionner. Ils sont d'ailleurs bien
dans la panade parce que soit ils disent
que c'est une monnaie et dans ce cas-là
ils viennent de déposer les armes, soit
ils ne le disent pas et dans ce cas-là
ils n'ont pas de raison de l'interdire
parce que précisément c'est pas une
monnaie selon eux-mêmes. Et en fait
quand on regarde dans les c'est même pas
dans les sous-titres dans l'implicite de
tous ces textes réglementaires qui font
200 pages, il y a toujours des indices
qui sont laissés typiquement. Il y a pas
de TV à appliquer à la vente de Bitcoin
contre d'autres monnaies. C'est bizarre,
je connais pas beaucoup de services sur
lequel on applique pas la TVA à part la
monnaie. Il y a une jurisprudence de la
Cour européenne là-dessus pour un
Suédois de mémoire. On a un tout un
paragraphe dans le nouveau règlement qui
s'appelle Transfer of funds regulation
qui ne s'appliquait avant dans son
paragraphe que aux pièces au aux pièces
au billets à la monnaie scripturale et
fiducière et maintenant ils ont rajouté
virgule et des cryptoactifs. Mais
qu'est-ce que ça vient là si
c'est pas de la monnaie ? Donc en fait
c'est pour les crédibiliser comme
monnaie absolum pour les faire rentrer
dans un cadre réglementaire qui le cadre
réglementaire européen entier est pensé
pour que ce soit fait par des filiales
de groupes étrangers et des banques
européennes. Donc les les purs players
européens, ils passent leur temps à se
plaindre depuis 15 ans parce que nous
notre boîte on en est à presque 10
fermetures de compte bancaire. Donc une
par an si vous comptez bien. Monsieur
Gouspiou ici est obligé de déménager
avec sa famille. On on le on lui a fermé
plusieurs fois son compte bancaire y
compris personnel. En fait, vous rendez
pas compte que vous êtes
Non, mais d'un côté, il y a monsieur
Buspillou et de l'autre, il y a quand
même la Security Exchange qui reconnaît
Bitcoin comme matière première.
Après 10 ans de procès, contrat est
forcé parce qu'il respecte la loi. Enfin
Tom, où vous voulez en venir ? On a fait
10 fois le tour de cette question. On
Non, c'est fini. Les États-Unis les
États-Unis ont créé le Bitcoin. On vous
l'accorde si vous voulez et on passe
autre chose parce que je suis sûr, je
suis sûr je suis sûr qu'
Oui, vous me dites "Non, non, les
États-Unis non, c'est bon. Les
États-Unis ont fait le Bitcoin. Vous
l'avez dit, les gouvernements sont à
fond pour le Bitcoin." OK. On vous
l'accorde, on vous l'accorde mais est-ce
que Non mais il y a d'autres Je pense
qu'il y a d'autres questions des gens.
Il y a tellement de de Bitcoin, il y a
pas que ça
pour votre invité assis à gauche. Donc
ça doit être Seb
vu qu'il ne voit jamais le rapport entre
ce que dit Tom et le Bitcoin.
Oui.
Quelle menace lui voit sur le Bitcoin à
minima, quel défaut voit-il au Bitcoin ?
À l'écouter, c'est magnifique. Il n'y a
aucun défaut au Bitcoin. Oh, il y en
avait des milliers de défauts qui ont
été corrigés au fil du temps. Il y en
aura certainement d'autres à corriger.
Non, souvent ce qu'on considère comme
des défauts sont des sont des
caractéristiques du Bitcoin. C'est
indispensable à son fonctionnement. Donc
s'il y a quelque chose moi qui me
chagrine, il deux choses qui me
chagrinaient parce que quand on décide
de mettre toute son énergie et de de
changer de job et de se lancer
là-dedans, toutes les questions que que
Tom se pose depuis qu'il a commencé à à
mettre le doigt là-dedans, on se on se
les pose à vitesse grand V pendant des
années et on n' pas toujours les
réponses. Et donc j'avais vu une chose,
c'était le fameux euh 1 million de
Bitcoin que détient Satoshi Nakamoto qui
qui n'existe pas.
Si ils existent, ils sont sur la bché.
Mais lui il s'attach
mais lui n'existe pas. Il a disparu en
tout cas et donc il y a 5 % de la masse
monétaire qui là appartient à un gars.
Et donc effectivement à une époque où le
cours était 200 dollars 500 dollars
quand moi je l'étudiais ça paraissait
extrêmement dangereux. Euh ça allait
toujours autant hein. S'ils mettent un
million de Bitcoin sur le sur le marché
je pense qu'on aura une chute
considérable du cours. Donc ça c'était
un souci. Et le deuxième souci qui moi
me marquait qui était hyper important
c'était que la Chine avait la grande
majorité. on parlait de 51 % tout à
l'heure avait la grande majorité du
mining mondial 60 % et donc ça c'est un
véritable danger parce que si à cette
époque-là les Chinois avait compris
qu'il suffisait qu' qui ferme toutes les
fermes et surtout tous les fabricants de
machines euh les assies, les fameuses
Aziqu sont chinois. Donc la Chine
maîtrisait toute la chaîne.
Voilà c'est ça. C'était beaucoup plus
flagrant de dire à l'époque les Chinois
ont inventé le Bitcoin et ça ne rapporte
qu'à eux que d'imaginer que c'était les
Américains qui avaient inventé le
Bitcoin avec leurs agences
gouvernementales. Ils avaient tout. Ils
auraient pu le tuer et non, ils ont
préféré faire ce truc que j'ai dit là,
bannir le mining, laisser partir une
partie des mineurs et exporter cette une
grosse partie du mining au Kazakhstan et
aux États-Unis comme je disais. Bref,
ils ont perdu leur chance de d'hyiler le
le Bitcoin. Alors, ils auraient
peut-être pas réussi mais il y avait une
grande possibilité avec 60 % du mining
de de faire un tort considérable au
Bitcoin et le cours ne s'en serait
peut-être jamais remis. Voilà. Donc et
ça c'était les deux défauts principaux
que je voyais et le premier existe
toujours. Il y a toujours un million de
Bitcoin dans la nature et c'est un
véritable danger pour le cours sur une
durée limitée et le deuxième danger a
disparu parce qu'aujourd'hui le H rate
est beaucoup mieux réparti dans le monde
et le plus gros mineur du monde à peu
près 25 peut-être 30 % du mining, c'est
les États-Unis.
Question internet quit de l'impact
écologique des technologies blockchain.
Le Bitcoin a-t-il par conséquent un
avenir ? Qui prend la question ? Ah, je
pense que je suis obligé de la prendre.
Allez,
vas-y, vas-y.
D'abord, il y a pas de technologie
blockchain, il y a la technologie
Bitcoin qui utilise une blockchain.
Et donc ça c'est un protocole qui
effectivement est gourmand en
électricité. Il a besoin d'électricité.
C'est sa c'est c'est la base de
d'utiliser de l'électricité et la suite
de la question. En fait, euh
je je vois pas je vois pas le lien en
fait. La fin de la question, c'est
est-ce que le Bitcoin a-t-il par
conséquent un avenir ?
Mais par conséquent de quoi ?
Ben par rapport à la consommation
énergétique. On a dit pour
ben pour entretenir les deux du Bitcoin,
comme je le disais précédemment,
l'intégralité vous avez
l'intégralité du système Bitcoin
aujourd'hui pour l'entretenir, c'est la
consommation électrique du Danemar.
OK. Donc quelle est la question ? Est-ce
que c'est durable ? Si ça se développe,
ça sera un pay comprenez la question.
Oui. Non mais la question elle est pas
compliqué. Non mais elle est elle est
pas exprimée correctement parce qu'on
compris.
Oui, je sais que vous l'avez compris
parce que c'est votre truc. Bon bref euh
donc vous énervez pas sinon je continue
les blagues.
Alors l'idée l'idée euh qu'il
si on développe si on développe ces
question l'idée c'est est-ce que c'est
durable ? Est-ce qu'on va pouvoir
continuer à consommer de plus en plus
d'électricité au fur et à mesure que le
prix du Bitcoin va monter parce que
c'est lié. Plus il va monter plus on va
avoir besoin d'électricité. Ça c'est
indispensable. C'est incontournable et
indéniable. Et mais ça ne pose pas de
problème. Il faut savoir qu'il y a une
électricité disponible dans le monde qui
est considérable. Voilà, on parle
toujours de crise d'énergie. On manque
d'électricité. J'avais vu Jean-Marc
Daniel l'année dernière, il était venu à
la télé pour dire on n' plus
d'électricité pour le mining. On en a
plus. Il y en a plus. Sauf que à partir
du 15 mai jus du 1er mai jusqu'au 15
août, on a fermé une centrale nucléaire.
On l'a retiré du réseau français parce
qu'on avait trop d'électricité par
rapport à des décisions politiques. On
ça c'est par rapport aux décisions de
l'Union européenne de la France, les
accords qui sont pris. Bah bien sûr que
si vous le savez très bien.
Non mais non je le sais pas très bien
parce que c'est pas ça la réalité. Je
suis désolé. les décisions
environnementales aujourd'hui avec les
maisons passives et les permis de
construire qui correspondent à un cahier
des charges, un char normatif qui vous
dit "Vous n'avez pas le droit de
construire si votre domicile consomme et
vous a consommé un peu plus que la
normale et un peu plus que ce champ, ça
correspond quand même à une volonté de
limiter la consommation énergétique."
Alors je comprends ce que vous voulez
dire, mais ça n'a rien à voir avec la
fermeture de cette centrale. La
fermeture cette centrale.
Non, ça n'a rien à voir. Ou oui, je bien
sûr. En fait, on a on a un potentiel de
production électrique qui est très
supérieur à la consommation française
pendant l'été. Euh c'est le principe
d'un réseau hein, c'est-à-dire qu'on on
constitue un réseau électrique une
puissance installée en fonction du pic.
Or le pic euh il y a un pic journalier
le matin et le soir, il y a un pic euh
annuel les 3 mois d'hiver. Et donc il
faut répondre à ces pics. En pic, on
consomme trois à quatre fois, parfois
cinq fois plus que dans la durée moyenne
de la normale. Donc on a tout ce
réservoir d'électricité qui est très
important.
Pendant cet été-là où on a coupé cette
centrale parce qu'on avait trop de jus,
on a quand même continué à vendre
l'électricité à prix négatif à
l'Allemagne ou des fois zéro. Donc en
gros, on sait plus quoi faire de notre
électricité. Les gens pensent que si on
a trop d'électricité, on met le câble
dans le sol et c'est fini. Mais non, une
électricité, elle doit être transformée
en chaleur à un endroit ou un autre.
Vous savez ce qu'ils font les Russes ?
Ils allument l'éclairage public en
pleine journée.
Bien sûr, bien sûr. Mais il y a pas
qu'en Russie, on le voit dans beaucoup
de pays. Il faut bien faire quelque
chose. Quand quand les gens, c'était la
mode il y a 2 ans, il y a des gars
qu'est- qu' les les enseignes pour aller
éteindre les enseignes et les gens
applaudissaient en bas. Les gars, vous
applaudissez à une augmentation du prix
du kilwh par EDF. Cette électricité là,
elle est propre. C'est le nucléaire qui
l'a produit la nuit. Donc que les
enseignes soient allumées ou pas allumé,
ça change rien pour la planète. ça va
changer juste pour votre facture. Voilà,
c'est ça qui est important. Et le
mining, c'est exactement ça. En gros,
aujourd'hui, la puissance électrique
mondiale permettrait de produire entre
trois et quatre fois plus d'électricité
que ce que le monde absorbe. C'est la
réalité d'un réseau. C'est comme ça
justement à cause des pics et tout ça.
En France, c'est moins. En France, on a
un parc qui permettrait de produire deux
fois plus d'électricité que ce qu'on
produit. Ce qui est record, ça veut dire
qu'on a un réseau extrêmement bien
maillé avec des voisins qui achètent nos
surplus. Mais n'empêche qu'il y a quand
même ce surplus, on pourrait quand même
produire plus d'électricité. Cette
centrale qui était fermée là, elle
aurait pu tourner tout l'été, alimenter
du mining. Voilà. Donc je vois le petit
sourire.
Donc ce que je veux dire, c'est que le
mining, il se il se positionne là dans
ce différentiel entre la capacité de
production et la production réelle,
l'absorption réelle. C'est c'est pour ça
qu'on est capable de créer un nouveau
pays comme la Suisse ou la Norvège ou je
ne sais quel autre pays vous avez cité
sans rajouter des installations
électriques. C'estàd qu'on a créé un
pays l'équivalent d'un pays comme la
Norvège donc je sais pas combien de
millions d'habitants sans créer de de
structures électriques. Ça veut ça
prouve bien que le Bitcoin vient prendre
les surplus les extra capacités les
centrales sur lesquelles
on a une grosse centrale qui produit peu
d'électricité au moins une grande partie
de l'année. Voilà. Et donc c'est pour ça
que le mining de Bitcoin peut multiplier
par 10 son absorption électrique par 100
par 150 par 200 par 300. Il y a
largement la place dans le monde.
Largement. Le
l'expérience de terrain de de Sébastien
en fait elle est elle a été difficile
difficilement audible ces dernières
années parce que les voilà les
bitcoiners non j'étais avec toi.
Vous connaissez bien tous les deux. Oui,
depuis longtemps même écosystème. Donc
forcément
euh le elle était difficilement audible
parce que euh justement il y avait que
les bitcoiners qui étaient confrontés à
la réalité du terrain et qui venaient
acheter ses surplus d'énergie. Et donc,
on a eu tout un moment pendant lequel
euh alors allez regarder parce que c'est
difficile à croire mais le World
Economic Forum nous avait dit en 2017
euh fin
non non en 2015 qu'on aurait bouffé
toute l'électricité de la planète avant
new week fin 2017 euh d'ici 2020 on
aurait consommé plus que la planète
c'est écritou
c'est écrit le World Economic Forum nous
disait d'ici 2020 Bitcoin consommera
plus que la planète sans se dire que
pour consommer plus que la planète faut
miner sur Mars littéralement parce que
si on consomme plus que la planète
Forcément, on n'est pas sur la planète.
Donc on on était dans ce genre
pas forcément. Là, vous mélangez la
capacité énergétique avec la
consommation. Mettons bah si, mettons
que la planète par exemple se mette à
l'arrêt, il y a une crise, on consomme
presque plus. Ça veut pas dire qu'on a
pas la capacité de déployer de
l'énergie.
Je je je fais je fais juste une
inclusion mathématique.
Si le minage est sur la planète et qui
consomme plus que la planète,
il y a pas besoin d'aller sur Mars. Ça
veut dire que là c'est une inclusion, le
minage est sur la planète. Mais regarde
le raisonnement est débile. Bon
non mais vous avez compris ce que j'ai
dit c'est important. Ben je vous pouvez
vous concentrer 20 secondes. J'ai pas
parlé depuis un moment. Je vous
expliquer quelque chose de simple. La
planète a une consommation énergétique.
On peut parfaitement partir du principe
que cette consommation est parfaitement
indépendante de sa capacité à produire
de l'énergie. C'est
ce que vient dire Sébastien.
Voilà. Oui mais c'est moi qui vient de
vous le dire. Donc il y a pas besoin
d'aller sur Mars si Bitcoin se mettait à
consommer plus que la planète à cet
instanté.
Mon propos n'était pas celui-là, mais
bon, c'est pas grave. Le propos, c'était
de dire qu'à l'époque, on était inondé
d'absurdité parce que évidemment
qu'aujourd'hui, non seulement sur le
principe c'est absurde, mais en plus le
chiffre final en 2020 c'était en dessous
de 0,05 % ou encore moins de la de la de
la consommation électrique mondiale.
Donc là, ce qui est bien, c'est que
maintenant le propos de Sébastien et le
mien, il est maintenant
complété du consensus scientifique. Donc
le j'allais dire la balle a changé de
camp. Euh moi, si vous me demandez quel
est l'impact écologique euh de Bitcoin
en particulier, je peux vous citer une
étude de Cornell, je peux vous citer une
étude d'Oxford, je peux vous citer une
étude d'UCL, je peux vous toutes elles
sont p reviewed, tout ce que vous
voulez. Oxford dit quoi ?
Euh toutes ces études-là globalement
disent à peu près la même chose. Elles
sont chacun sur leur spécialité mais bon
euh faudrait
repointer tel résultat pour telle étude.
Mais elles disent plusieurs choses. La
première c'est que le Bitcoin
effectivement agit comme les bitcoiner
l'avaient dit. C'est-à-dire que en fait
quand on comprend le modèle économique
du minage, c'est à peu près évident,
c'est que le minage c'est une activité
qui a des coûts fixes au sens capex,
donc des dépenses de capital qui sont
importantes, il faut acheter des
machines, mais qui ensuite en terme de
coût variables, c'est 90 %
d'électricité. C'est quasiment que ça.
Donc le travail de Sébastien et de la
plupart des mineurs dans le monde, c'est
de chercher l'électricité pas chère.
L'électricité pas chère dans le monde,
c'est certainement pas la centrale
pilotable fossile en concurrence avec la
zone urbaine. Ça n'a aucun sens. Se
brancher aux réseau urbains en France et
payer son électricité à 15 ou 20
centimes le kWh, le mineur, il fait
faillite dans la semaine. Ça n'a aucun
sens. Le kilwh le moins cher, c'est
celui qui se trouve en zone de surplu
parce que précisément on est dans une
zone de prix négatif. Donc
le Texas par exemple,
le Texas par exemple est effectivement
un endroit où il y a des comptés entiers
dans lequels 25 % du temps les prix sont
négatifs. Le Texas c'est un des un des
endroits du des États-Unis où le mix
électrique est le plus vert. Ça doit
être 35 % de NR maintenant. Sauf qu'ils
atteignent un plafond de verre. Quand on
est un producteur de NR et qu'on dit "Je
vais m'implanter au Texas" et qu'on te
dit mais en fait 25 % du temps tu vas
être obligé de payer tes consommateurs.
Ben en fait le producteur de NR il dit
"Bah ok, j'ai rien à faire ici. J'ai pas
envie d'avoir un business model dans
lequel 1 heure sur 4 c'est moi qui
paye." Donc il arrête plafond de verre
de déploiement des ENR. le ce que ces
études montrent qu'à pratique à à
l'appui puisqu'on le disait tout à
l'heure maintenant le Texas il y a
environ 3 GW de puissance installée en
minage ce qui est plus que leur capacité
euh à mobiliser par l'éolière et le et
le sol que ça
c'est plus que
aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup plus que on
est plus près de 15 GW c'est 12 % de la
puissance installée totale. C'est dingue
c'est énorme. Pour reprendre le
raisonnement, mais en tout cas moi je me
basais sur les Aircodes qui est le
l'équivalent d' Nédis au Texas qui
publie des rapports. Le dernier était il
y a 6 mois ou 1 an, qui disait qu'on
était à 3 ou 4 GW en tout cas
d'installer. Bon bref, en tout cas c'est
dans ces ordres de grandeur là. Euh
pourquoi c'est absolument évident du
point de vue du business model, c'est
que ils ont un avantage les mineurs par
rapport à tous ceux parce que on entend
souvent "Oui, mais on pourrait mettre
des hôpitaux à la place ou des écoles".
Ben non, parce qu'en fait c'est les
seuls qui sont capables de s'arrêter sur
demande
autant de temps qu'on veut et sans
conséquence pour la chaîne logistique.
C'est-à-dire que si Seb arrête ses
machines demain, Bitcoin continue de
tourner, il s'en fout. Donc euh à
l'inverse, si vous avez parce que les
autres qui satisfont ces ces ces
contraintes de ce qu'on appelle des
programmes de demande response ou
d'effacement en français, ça va être des
usines d'aluminium, des usines d'acier
et cetera qui sont très énergivores.
Mais vous arrêtez pas une usine
d'aluminium plus de 3h, sinon il faut la
raser. Le l'appareil industriel marche
plus, les les fournisseurs, les clients
sont en détresse totale. Vous pouvez pas
faire ça.
Les fours sont en détresse
et tout le monde est en détresse. Il
faut raser l'usine, ça coûte des
milliards. Le mineur, il s'arrête. On
l'appelle bonjour, vous arrêtez dans les
dem. Ouais, OK. Bien sûr, on arrête. Et
on arrête. Ce qui fait que aujourd'hui
dans le minage, on a non seulement le
consensus scientifique qui dit ça, qui
dit bah en fait effectivement on l'a
constaté sur le terrain que les les
mineurs contribuit à la stabilité du
réseau et qu'ils apportaient des ENR sur
le réseau. Ils disent un autre une autre
chose, c'est que les mineurs servent de
charognard pour tout ce qui est euh
déchets, notamment de méthane qui est un
gaz particulièrement dangereux parce que
c'est 80 fois pire que le CO2 à court
terme pour la planète. Et en fait le
méthane aujourd'hui, il est émis en gros
à 30 30 30. Je le fais très rapidement,
mais 30 % c'est l'agriculture, 30 %
c'est les déchets, 30 % c'est les
exploitations pétrolières qu'il
rejettent en coproduit du pétrole en
gros. Mais c'est des endroits qui ont
tous pour euh caractéristiques communes
d'être isolés. C'est-à-dire que personne
ne veut habiter à côté euh d'une
décharge et accessoirement le pétrole ça
se prend en Sibérie ou dans le désert,
ça se prend pas dans une zone urbaine.
Donc le problème que ces gens
pour l'instant euh le problème que ces
gens-là ont c'est que ils se retrouvent
avec un déchet parce que quand on perce
une exploration pétrolière par exemple,
on sort du pétrole mais on sort aussi du
méthane et en fait on sait pas quoi en
faire. On on se retrouve alors je suis
au milieu de la Sibérie. J'ai le choix
entre brûler mon méthane sur place
ou les venter parce que rien à
Voilà. Hop
des torchères torch les fameuses torchè
donc on brûle ou bien je construis un
gaz auod du sur 800 km qui va me coûter
euh peut-être ou 5 millions d'euros le
kilomètre
qui va être pété par les ucrê pété par
le froid la météo qu'il faut entretenir
n tout ça pour balancer un coproduit
dont je ne sais pas quoi faire de la
production au milieu de la Sibérie. Donc
que font ces gens-là ? Alors je vous
donne des chiffres qui sont ceux de
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie.
Chaque année dans le monde, c'est 150
milliards de mètres cubes de gaz qui
sont brûlés par torchè et 55 milliards
qui sont éventés, ce qui est encore pire
parce que dans ce cas-là, ils sont même
pas brûlé en CO2. Les deux ensemble, 205
milliards de de mètres comm
électrique de l'Union européenne qui est
juste brûlé tous les ans. Et quand vous
brûlé ou éventer et quand vous demandez
à l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
est-ce que est-ce qu'on fait des progrès
sur le méthane qui est pourtant, c'est
les Nations- Unies qui le disent, Inger
Anderson, directrice exécutive du
programme des Nations unies sur
l'environnement, qu'est-ce qu'elle nous
dit ? Le levier principal pour
l'humanité pour lutter contre le
changement climatique à court terme,
c'est le méthane.
Semaine dernière, ça a été dit ça.
Ouais.
Alors, peut-être redit mais ça elle l'a
dit en 2020 2021 déjà. Mais la suite de
ce raisonnement, c'est quoi ? C'est bah
du coup, on doit faire des efforts sur
le méthane. Que nous dit l'Agence
Internationale de l'énergie ?
Que
quasiment texta depuis les années 2000,
nous n'avons fait aucun progrès et
l'humanité brûle et torche autant de
méthane qu'il n'en brûlait il y a 20
ans. Pourquoi ? Parce que c'est
économiquement pas rentable. Donc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Bah on met du
minage et ça on a Conocophilip le fait,
Exon Mobile le fait. Je Sébastien, tu
dois le faire aussi, j'en sais rien. Je
connais pas tes activités.
Donc tout ça, c'est des c'est des cas
d'usage qui existent et qui ont en plus
pour particularité qui est absolument
génial, c'est que tout ça est compatible
avec un scénario compétitif pour
reprendre nos amis du JC. Dans le JC, on
a plein de scénarios, les SSP dans
lequel en gros on dit est-ce que les
gens vont collaborer dans le futur ou
pas ? Et le GC nous dit, il y a un
scénario qui est vraiment terrible,
c'est le SSP3 dans lequel en gros
rivalité régionale, les gens
s'intéressent au nationalisme,
résurgence des problèmes de sécurité, de
guerre et cetera. quand on lit, on a
l'impression que ça décrit en gros le
quotidien et que le scénario 1,
c'est-à-dire tout le monde collabore, on
sert la main à l'ONU et tout va bien
n'arrive jamais. Bah, il se trouve que
le GC nous dit "Ben en fait, scénario 3,
il y a rien qui peut marcher en scénario
compétitif." Donc, on va vers 4 degrés
de réchauffement climatique. On va tous
crever. Donc il faut collaborer. Ce que
le mineur dit c'est on va pas arrêter
d'essayer de collaborer. Mais moi j'ai
une solution qui est compatible avec le
scénario 3 parce que mon incitation
c'est pas une réglementation décidée
dans un bureau, ça met 20 ans à être
pondu et ensuite il y a des instations
où moi je vais passer par le côté, je
vais payer des amendes. Non, c'est en
fait si je suis pétrolier et
qu'aujourd'hui je brûle mon méthane avec
du minage, mais en fait je suis plus
rentable que mon voisin. Donc je vais le
faire tout simplement. Moi-même, j'avais
porté le le projet de le faire sur du
méthane de biogaz de de site
d'enfouissement, de le faire en France.
C'est des choses qui se font déjà en
Amérique latine, en Asie du Sud-Est. En
France, on peut pas le faire à cause de
de l'État notamment, hein. Euh tout
simplement parce que bah il y a euh le
prix euh de EDF garanti, LAADEM prend 60
% de la connexion au réseau et cetera.
Donc bref, je vous le fais en version
très courte, mais c'est globalement
inenvisageable en France hexagonale. Euh
c'est possible de le faire. Il y a un
vrai euh business case euh dans les
endroits insulaires Guadeloupe,
Martinique, Corse, Réunion et cetera.
Mais il y a d'autres problèmes.
Toujours est-il qu'aujourd'hui oui on
éteint des torchères et c'est juste fou
quoi. Il y a que nous qui somons faire
ça. C'estàd que d'aller sur un champ
pétrolier totalement isolé parce qu'en
fait la technologie elle est simple.
C'estàdire que au lieu de brûler ce gaz
on le transforme en l'électricité.
C'estàd qu'on le met dans une
génératrice où il est parfaitement bien
brûlé.
C'est une turbine.
Ouais. En fait la problématique de la
torchère c'est que ça brûle à 98 % le
méthane en temps normal. Mais par grand
vent, par grand vent, ça peut descendre
à 55 60 % de métal.
Ça particule un peu sur le côté, non ?
Ah non, mais ça tue des gens partout
autour, hein. Des champs pétroliers pe
peuvent être responsables de 2000 3000
morts par an. C'est c'est des chiffres
qui sont assez connues hein. La plus
grosse centrale au charbon de d'Afrique
du Sud, c'est 6000 6000 par an. En
Polne, pareil, Belâteau, c'est 6000 par
an. Et c'est les mêmes euh à peu près
les mêmes euh résidus qu'on trouve dans
le dans le méthane, enfin dans le dans
les torchères. Donc quand il y a
beaucoup de vent, il y a que 50 % ou 60
% du méthane qui est brûlé. C'est hyper
grave et euh il y a pas de solution
parce que la solution c'est de prendre
ce gaz, le transformer en électricité et
donc euh bah les exploitants pétroliers
c'est ce qu'ils font. Ils font ça avec
un petit conteneur de 800 kW et ça leur
permet de d'alimenter leurs outils, tout
la lumière du chantier. Mais c'est tout.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils vont faire de cette
électricité s' mett le plus de
containers ? Nous, on leur dit nous on
est mettez plus de containers et nous on
absorbe tout et c'est ce qui se passe
hein. Donc aujourd'hui on est à Oman
si on mettait des data center à la
place.
Alors je vous donne la réponse
immédiatement immédiatement. On a monté
la j'ai convaincu le gouvernement de
Doman de faire du mining. Ils avaient
ce qu'ils appellent une data city qu'ils
étaient en train de construire qui avait
un gros avantage, c'est qu'ils ont une
faille d'eau froide et qu'il pouvaient
aller chercher l'eau glacée et donc
refroidir les data center. C'était
l'idée géniale qu'ils avaient. Et donc
il y avait là 800 MW de disponible pour
faire cette énorme data city. Bon, je
leur ai expliqué que ça marcherait
jamais parce que un data center c'est
pas du tout comme du mining. Il faut le
gaz qui qui va se transformer en
électricité mais il faut une autre
source d'électricité. Si vous avez
qu'une seule source d'électricité même
avec une batterie d'ondleur de batterie
de tout ce que vous voulez, il faut
absolument deux sources voir trois
sources redondantes d'électricité. Il
faut deux sources internet. Enfin, il y
avait pas du tout ce qu'il fallait sur
leur site. Donc, j'ai dit au ministère
de l'énergie, par contre le mining, on
peut le faire. Et le ministère des
transports et de l'aïti est venu
inaugurer la ferme, a couper le ruban.
On parle de en 2021 ça. Alors que la
banque centrale d'Oman venait
d'interdire le Bitcoin dans le pays,
hein. Et donc, je lui ai dit, "Ben moi,
j'étais pas très rassuré de livrer mes
conteneurs parce que votre banque
centrale vient d'interdire le truc
quoi." Il m'a dit "Ah non, je lui dis
"C'est interdit le Bitcoin dans votre
pays." Il me dit, "Qui a interdit le
Bitcoin dans le pays Je dis bah la
banque centrale, il m'a dit "Duis quand
les banques centrales font les lois ?"
Et voilà, ça a été fini. Euh donc en
tous les cas, pour eux c'est extrêmement
important. Ils ont tout ce gaz
dégueulasse. Le sultan veut absolument
que les torchères ne brûlent pas près
des plages et tout ça. Il veut en faire
un site touristique. Donc il a dit "Vous
me prenez tout ce gaz, vous le mettez
dans une centrale électrique à l'arrière
là 200 km plus loin ou 100 km plus
loin." Mais il y a pas de demande. La
centrale, elle existe, elle électrique,
elle existe. Il y a pas de demande. Donc
et ben quand il y a plus pas assez de
demande, les torchèes se rallument. Donc
là, nous on est là, on éteint les
torchères, c'est tout. Et personne
d'autre ne peut le faire. C'est ça que
les gens arrivent pas à réaliser. Dire
"Oui, mais cette électricité pourrait
servir à quelque chose de plus utile."
Mais non, tu m'as acheté le chocolat
desunga là. Ce ce chocolat
là, il est fait dans la jungle des
Virunga au Congo. Un pays en guerre. Et
le Tu veux que je te raconte un peu
l'histoire ?
Bien sûr.
Alors,
mais je veux bien que tu montres la
tablette de chocolat.
Voilà. Le chocolat qui est
Ça c'est toi qui fait ça ? Non non,
c'est le c'est le la fondation Virunga
dans le parc des Virunga, le patron du
parc des Virunga, le directeur qui est
un fonctionnaire de l'État congolais.
C'est un prince belge à l'origine mais
il est fonctionnaire de l'État
congolais. Donc il a la direction de cet
énorme parc. C'est un parc extrêmement
prestigieux. C'est le parc Albert avant
ça s'appelait c'est le premier parc
national d'Afrique. C'est il a été créé
il y a un siècle. on va fêter son siècle
l'année prochaine. Il a extrêmement de
valeur parce que d'abord c'est un
morceau de la deuxième forêt primaire
humide du monde après l'Amazonnie. Là
c'est un morceau important. Euh en terme
géologique, c'est montagneux. Il y a
aussi des plaines. Il y a un paquet de
rivière et surtout il y a la faune. Il y
a 80 % de la faune africaine qui est
réunie dans ce petit parc là. Enfin
petit parc, ça fait 7800 km². Et donc il
subit toute cette forêt subit une
déforestation dingue et surtout le parc.
Le parc est entouré d'à peu près 5
millions de personnes relativement
pauvres qui exerce une pression dingue
sur le le bois parce que l'énergie de
chauffe là-bas pour faire brouillir son
eau, c'est le charbon de bois. Donc on
coupe du bois, on le fait brûler sur
place et on vend le charbon le charbon
de bois au marché à Goma. C'est un
marché qui le charbon de bois c'est à
peu près 100 millions de dollars par an.
Donc c'est un marché hyper intéressant.
Ça ça intéresse tous les petits
braconniers qui viennent faire ça. Pour
résister à ça, Emmanuel de Nerod, donc
le le patron du parc a décidé d'amener
une électricité, une énergie
alternative. Donc l'électricité, il y a
plein de rivières partout dans cette
région. Je vais faire des centrales, des
centrales hydroélectriques. Donc là, il
est en train de construire sa 4è
centrale hydroélectrique
au fil de l'eau, je faut préciser.
Au fil de l'eau. C'est pas des barrages,
hein. C'est vraiment des des centrales
au fil de l'eau. C'est des petites
centrales. La plus grosse actuellement
fait 15 m. Il est en train d'en
construire une 4è donc de 30 m. Et sur
la troisième qu'ils ont construite, les
deux premières ont assez facilement
trouvé leur clientèle. Sur la troisième
qui sont construites, ils l'ont
construite à Ivingu dans un petit
village sur la rivière Louvirot qui
était hyper tranquille. Et pendant la
construction, ils ont commencé à se
faire envahir par les troupes rebelles.
À tel point que quand il m'a contacté,
Emmanuel Deod, il m'a dit "On est en
train de construire une centrale qui va
qui va sortir de terre au mois de
septembre. Là, on était en janvier et il
me dit "On a'ura pas un client parce
qu'on peut pas tirer les lignes
Et des cas comme ça en Afrique, j'en ai
trouvé je ne sais combien depuis et donc
il me dit en septembre on doit démarrer
la centrale, l'essayer tout ça et on
peut pas faire de test, on a pas de
client en face. Donc on est en train
d'acheter ce qu'on appelle un un banc de
charge. Un band de charge, un containeur
avec des résistances dedans pour pouvoir
tester la centrale. Je on va mettre un
conttainur un peu plus intelligent que
ça. Et et donc c'est l'idée qu'il avait.
Il a dit "Vous pouvez venir travailler
là dans la jungle dans un pays en
guerre. Il y a pas internet, il y a pas
de route, il y a pas de port, il y a pas
d'hôtel, il y a rien. Et j'ai une
centrale de 15 MW. Donc on lui a mis 12
MW de d'absorption de de container et on
le gère très bien. Mais on est
absolument la seule industrie en en
capacité de venir. Il a il a tout
retourné dans tous les sens, hein. Il s
dit "Qu'est-ce que je peux mettre là ?
Une hydrogène machin il y a rien. Il y a
personne ne peut travailler dans ces
conditions. Donc c'est une bonne dingue.
Alors ce petit cas là au Vironga est
facile à comprendre mais en fait c'est
le même modèle dans le monde entier.
C'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure,
le différentiel entre la puissance
installée et ce qu'on absorbe réellement
est énorme parce que les centrales sont
pas au bon endroit, pas parce que la
demande n'est pas régulière dans le
temps. Donc ça, cette extra capacité
électrique, elle est structurelle. Il y
a quelques groupes électriques qui l'ont
compris et pour eux, le Bitcoin mining
est une batterie économique incroyable.
Ça change complètement le rapport à
l'énergie. C'estàd qu'on a besoin de
construire beaucoup moins gros euh par
rapport à une absorption ou en tout cas
si on construit aussi gros qu'avant par
rapport à l'absorption, on sait qu'on va
rentabiliser le plus gros. Voilà, c'est
ça qui est très important à comprendre.
C'est pour ça que le développement du du
mining est est quasiment infini parce
qu'il y a encore beaucoup de de
centrales hydro qui sont en cours de
construction en Afrique et qui vont se
retrouver dans la même situation. On le
cas a une petite centrale de 15 m mais
en Éthiopie actuellement on est en train
d'installer 300 MW de mining parce que
sur les nouveaux barrages qu'il font.
qui font les barrages mais il y a pas
les réseaux encore. Ça va prendre 10 ans
pour faire les réseaux. Donc pendant 10
années, il va y avoir cette capacité de
produire de l'électricité qui est
perdue. Donc c'est là que le mining
vient, se concentre et fait plaisir aux
électriciens.
Question internet. Que va-t-il se passer
quand le minage sera terminé ?
Un stock fini égale une bulle
spéculative pour interrogation comme les
œuvres de Picasso.
Alors le minage le minage sera jamais
terminé.
Il faut bien comprendre qu'on a deux
sources de revenu nous les mineires. Il
y a les nouveaux les nouveaux bitcoins
qu'on qu'on fait apparaître. On les fait
on les crée pas, on les fait apparaître
sur la blockchain.
Vous les révélerz,
on les révèle exactement et donc ça ça
diminue. En 2140, on produira des PM de
Bitcoin, quelques Satoshi. Donc cette
source de revenu risque de diminuer
énormément, sauf si le Bitcoin vaut 1
milliard de dollars, mais j'y crois pas.
Et donc la deuxième source de revenu,
c'est les FIS, c'est les frais de
transaction quand on s'échange quelque
chose, quand on s'échange du Bitcoin.
Donc ça s'arrêtera jamais. En 2140, on
ne sera plus rémunéré que par les frais
de transaction et c'est c'est tout à
fait cohérent.
Alors fact check de fact check de refact
check pour Tom.
Tom raconte des bêtises. Les monnaies
sont souvent créées par des initiatives
privées puis reprises et monopolisées
par les États. Entre parenthèses voit
voir les travaux de Frederich von Hayek.
Bon, je vais répondre parce que Fréichek
fait partie des économistes les plus
brillants évidemment à cette personne,
cette femme ou cet homme qui dit "Tom
raconte des bêtises." Non, Tom raconte
pas de bêtises. Citez-moi dans
l'histoire une monnaie qui a été ensuite
reconnue comme ayant cours légal et qui
a été créée par quelqu'un qui utilisait
un pseudonyme et qui en réalité
n'existait pas mais qui pendant un temps
a continué à détenir une quantité de
cette monnaie. Levez-vous tôt parce que
vous n'en trouverez pas. Voilà ma
réponse.
Et il y avait pas internet en plus à
l'époque.
Et il y avait pas internet à l'époque en
plus mais on aurait tout à fait pu
imaginer qu'il y ait des matières euh
première qui soient reconnu comme en
cours légal. Mais à ce moment-là, on
aurait dit bah c'est euh euh Béber du
coin qui a décrété que c'était le bois
et plus le on dirait pourant. C'est ce
que dit AEC le l'internaute a raison.
C'est ce que dit AEC. Toi tu l'as lu
Alexandre je suis désolé les monnaies
sont créées par les commerçants et les
États se les approprient. C'est jamais
les États qu'on créé la monnaie. Ce sont
les banques centrales. Voyons,
vous avez un petit Non mais les banques
centrales, c'est une invention l'euro.
Attendez, on va quand même se dire moi
je suis pas un fanatique de l'euro, mais
si je peux prendre un peu la par siècle,
il y avait pas de banque centrale
quand
il y a trois siècles.
Oui. Non mais il y a les premières
banques centrales c'est il y a un siècle
et demi. Non mais alors là vous partez
donc avant il y avait pas de monnaie.
Mais s'il y avait des monnaies mais
c'était pas le même système monétaire.
On est bien d'accord. On est bien
d'accord mais c'est pas ce que dit le
monsieur.
Et ben moi je réponds à ce monsieur et
je vous réponds par la même occasion.
c'est que quand on parle des monnaies,
évidemment qu'on parle des monnaies dans
le système financier actuel,
c'est-à-dire à l'heure actuelle, on peut
le voir hein, c'est au 19e siècle avec
les banque centrale, il y a la banque de
France mais il y a pas Breton Woods.
Alors on dit donc là c'était le système
actuel, non ? Et après si je vous dis
Breton Woods, on vous dira il y a les
talons or. Et après si je vous dis après
la la fin de la convertibilité, vous me
direz "Ouais mais il y avait pas encore
le numérique. Donc l'endettement des
États se faisait pas de la même façon."
Évidemment qu'il y a eu des évolutions
mais en tout cas le système monétaire si
vous observez la situation en 1935 même
avant qui est le
Breton Woods ben vous aviez déjà la
banque des règlements internationaux. Je
dis pas le contraire.
C'était pas la question du monsieur. Lui
lui ce qu'il dit c'est que la monnaie n
pas marché c'est ma réponse hein. C'est
vous avez parlé pendant un quart
d'heure. Je crois que c'était pas la
question du monsieur. Venez de tenir
monologue de 20 minutes monsieur. Ça
correspondait pas à la question que je
sache donc je vous réponds. Bien sûr que
si ça répondait à la question. Le
chocolat, le chocolat du Congo, ça
correspondait à la question de
le chocolat il a besoin d'électricité.
Ben ce que je suis en train de expliquer
sur la BRI également, voyons. Donc ce
que je suis en train d'expliquer, c'est
que l'euro a été créé par une banque
centrale.
Temporaliser la question, elle est elle
l'est pas. On parle de monnaie et qui ne
sont pas inventées par les États. C'est
une invention des commerçants de tout
temps. Ça a été comme ça. On peut pas
réduire l'histoire humaine qui dure
depuis des millénaires sur les 150
dernières années. Enfin, ça n'a aucun
sens. Ça c'était pas la question du
monsieur. C'est pas comme ça que je la
comprends. Donc vot
c'est la réponse de monsieur ou c'est la
mienne ? Parce que voilà on sait tout.
Vous
vous inventez que il y a toujours eu des
banques centrales pour faire toujours
pas leur donner un carré de chocolat qui
puisse s'arrêter.
Non mais par contre je peux les mettre
entre guillemets d'accord. c'est que
effectivement la question qui a été
posée disait en gros les monnaies sont
des initiatives privées qui que les
États se sont accaparés ce qui est
factuellement vrai d'un point de vue
historique. En fait Tom répond sur la le
système économique actuel en disant ce
n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui.
Aujourd'hui on a un système Fiat dans
lequel la monnaie est décrétée par
l'État et elle est forcée par le cours
légal par la coercition. Mais en fait ce
sont deux choses différentes. C'est on
peut très bien et je je terminerai par
ça ce que Tom en gros dit. Bon bah, vous
regardez dans les deux derniers siècles
ou peu importe d'ailleurs vous ne
trouverez jamais de monnaie créée par je
sais plus quelle était ta phrase,
un pseudonyme qui n'existe pas. Voilà,
puisque pour le Bitcoin, il faut quand
même rappeler pour ceux qui le saurent
pas que le créateur du Bitcoin n'existe
pas hein. Sin
non, je sais pas ce que ça veut dire
existe pas.
Satos Shinakamoto a un état civil. Non.
Ah donc toute personne qui a pas d'état
civil existe pas.
Ah bah oui officiellement oui. Pas 40%
de la population. Non, mais pas comme le
fondateur, vous le savez très bien, mais
non, mais vous pouvez pas être reconnu
comme étant le fondateur d'un protocole
qui prend une une ampleur aussi
phénoménale, aussi grande que le
Bitcoin, en ayant un état civil qui
n'existe pas.
Le siu
il est japonais, vous connaissez
beaucoup de japonais qui sont à la tête
finalement, on en sait rien.
Voilà, donc il n'existe pas. C'est pour
ça.
Il est de la creuse.
Ça s'appelle un pseudonyme. Bluetooth
non plus n'existe pas. En pasigé de
balancer, on sait comment ça s'est passé
? On sait comment ça s'est passé pour
inventer le Bluetooth ? Il y a eu des
enjeux, il y a eu des sociétés qui ont
gagné de l'argent, il sont immatriculé
par un des invité de régulier de
de Sky qui s'appelle Bluetooth.
Ouais. Ouais. Te rattrap gaffe parce que
tu es pas dans les virunga là, tu vas
tomber d'un coup. Vous
prenez le bon exemple, vous savez
pourquoi ? Parce que Bluetooth que je ne
connaissais pas, il n'existe pas. Mais
si par contre les existe et si les
services veulent le retrouver, ils vont
le retrouver hein.
Ça dépend. Ah, ils vont mettre tous les
moyens mais ils vont le retrouver. Alors
que sur Bitcoin même la NSA est
dépassée, il n'arrive pas à remonter les
premiers ordinateurs. Vous savez qu'il
ont mis les premiers Bitcoin et la NSA
là, ils sont totalement dépassés.
La grande force de Sat.
Toutou s'il veut se cacher, tu le
trouves pas.
Ah ouais, il y a plus fort que Bitcoin.
Le dernier propos sur cette question,
c'est surtout que je trouve que la la
réponse que tu proposes en fait, elle ne
elle répond à côté parce que euh
par je le dis, le le parallèle
historique que je ferai, c'est euh c'est
euh Gérard Terry 96 qui nous dit à la
télé mais enfin vous imaginez, on va
verser les les 100 millions
d'utilisateurs du Minitel sur internet.
Vous n'y pensez pas. Avez-vous déjà vu
réussir un réseau qui et puis rentrer là
avec moi ? Bah
le rapport c'est que vous avez un
raisonnement qui est photographique,
c'est-à-dire la photo d'aujourd'hui,
est-ce que Bitcoin est une monnaie
partout dans le monde ? Bah la réponse
est non à peu près. Maintenant nous on a
pas
d'accord avec ça. C'est pas une monnaie.
Ah si c'est une monnaie bien sûr. C'est
une monnaie en devenir. Bien sûr. C'est
une
métamonnaie en devenir c'est pas pareil.
Attention là aujourd'h c'est la monnaie
du Salvador.
C'est précisément ce que j'ess Non mais
parce que la réponse pour le fait est un
peu plus intéressante que le départ.
C'est la monnaie du Salvador. Pourquoi ?
parce que le Salvador a décidé de lui
donner cours légal.
Ça veut dire que pour reconnaître qu'une
monnaie est une monnaie, vous en arrivez
de vous-même assez naturellement que
c'est parce que Net lui a donné cours
légal. Vous voyez comme le cheminement
est intéressant. Vous l'avez fait seul.
Bien sûr, c'est votre référent pour
vous. Non mais attendez, c'est quand
même incroyable. Vous ne dites qu'une
monnaie ne peut être que d'état. Je vous
dis que c'est la monnaie de l'État
salvadorien. Donc je suis pas en train
d'abonder dans votre sens. Je vous dis
pour aller dans vot dans votre histoire
puisque la monnaie n'est
Moi, j'ai pas d'histoire hein, je fais
du constat. Bien sûr, vous dites que la
monnaie c'est que l'État donc c'est une
monnaie puisque un état l'a adopté.
Voilà. Donc en fait le débat monnaie il
est réglé parce que d'une certaine enfin
a d'ailleurs il y a qu'en France on a ce
débat là ce qui est assez drôle il est
réglé parce
du dollar et de l'euro. Discutons plus.
Bah sauf à dire que le Salvador n pas
très différente. Elle est très
différente. Mais
c'est c'est libre à vous de le dire euro
yen Bitcoin c'est pareil. Pourquoi
parler de parler de ça ? Voyons.
Alors la couronne islandaise c'est une
monnaie ou pas ? Oui mais c'est
différent là vous savez
Oui mais bah oui bien sûr mais parce que
parce
c'est autant d'habitants la Suisse et la
Salvador
et c'est la même taille enfant non mais
il y a des humains et puis il y a
d'autres
je peux vous répondre en 10 secondes
vous avez une banque centrale suisse qui
est inscrite qui participe aux réunions
de la banque des règlements
internationaux on est d'accord
donc si on participe pas à la réunion
des banques règlements internationaux on
n'est pas une monnaie
pas au sens en tout cas du système
monétaire
c'est exactement ce que je dis c'est
répondiser
la question sur aujourd'hui vous
réservez un raisonnement photographique
ce que nous on essaie d'avoir voir c'est
c'est quoi les caractéristiques
fondamentales de Bitcoin, c'est-à-dire
techniquement pratiquement
c'est rare, c'est divisible, on peut
l'auditer, on peut la transacter, on
peut donc maintenant la question qui
reste et qui subsiste, c'est une analyse
à postterrioriste, c'està-dire une
analyse devant nous. Nous, on a la
conviction que ces caractéristiques
fondamentales étant réunies, il va
réussir à réunir le consensus social qui
crée qui fera le fait que ce sera
adopté. après
et la légence des régulateurs et des
États qui diront "C'est vrai, on va vous
signer un plan." Ce qu'Alexandre oublie,
c'est quand même le l'aspect
maiavellique de la dimension
maiavellique à la fois dans le business
et c'est pour ça qu'il y a de
l'espionnage industriel qui a des
concurrences. Comme je le disais
précédemment, euh demain moi je veux
créer une plateforme en disant "Mais
vous échangez entre vous de particulier
à particulier, vous vous salariez, il y
a trop d'imposition à côté. Est-ce que
vous croyez qu'au bout d'un moment, on
va vous dire bah oui oui votre
plateforme marche bien ?" Ben c'est
illégal. Pourquoi ? parce que ça
concurrence le système des chambres bah
vous c'est vous
c'est vous qui venez de le dire hein là
le
le système dans lequel non pas du tout
je parle de votre système
parce que vous venez de me dire c'est
illégal illégal le système dans lequel
on contourne les taxes que vous voulez
faire quoi celui-là est illégal mais
créer Bitcoin c'est pas illégal
si c'est illégal
non mais de s'en servir comme d'une
monnaie c'est illégal ah bon vous avez
vous avez le droit
ah bon il y a eu il y a des gens qui ont
créé des monnaies parallèle à part les
monnaies locales, les bons, les coupons
les les coupons à la fête foraine hein
mais par contre des gens non mais
c'était ça les monnaie local ça le fait
rire parce qu'on vous donne un copain on
vous donne 5 € mais il vaut plus rien
une fois que vous sortez de la flotte
foraine du village hein mais par contre
des gens qui ont créé des systèmes
monétaires alternatif s'appelle Bernard
ils sont au trou pour 125 ans. La
réalité elle est là vous la réalité
c'est que vous créez pas une monnaie
parallèle et vous ne vous ne créez pas
une
monnaie le Nigéria c'est suffisamment
grand pour vous ou pas ?
Non mais là vous me parlez d'un pays
Ouais. Bah oui, donc je vous parle d'un
pays parce que votre angathinakamoto
c'était ni un empereur ni un chef d'état
ni un pays que sauvage. Nigéria 230
millions de personnes euh il y a entre
selon les différentes études entre 30 et
50 % des gens qui ont de du Bitcoin.
C'est interdit.
Et
il y a une banque centrale qui est
contre. Il y a une banque centrale qui
essaie de mettre son Inaira qui est
d'ailleurs une faille totale. Le pays
est en train de s'effondrer. La monnaie
s'est fait dévaluer deux fois de 50 %
l'espace de 2 ans.
Alors donc ben vous m'expliquez qu'il y
a pas de concurrence. Là
ce que je vous explique c'est que vous
me dites ça ne peut pas être une monnaie
parce queil y a un empereur qui dira
non. Et moi je vous dis il y a un pays
23 millions d'habitants qui est la
première économie d'Afrique premier
exportateur de pétrole d'Afrique qui en
fait export en quoi en dollar. J'en fais
sans arrêt des transactions avec le
Nigéria. Mais pas ben parce que c'est on
parle pas de leur monnaie là-bas. Tout
se fait en dolleur. Vous allez pas dire
vous vous
vendez faites transiter du sucre euh au
Nigéria et vous verrez si vous payez pas
dollar. Ben oui.
Non, si vous faites à l'export. Oui,
c'estàd
mais c'est pour ça que je vous dis
parpendre dans des pays et des groupes
de pays comme l'euro en tout cas la zone
euro où il y a une monnaie qui est quand
même un outil euh de pouvoir auprès des
entreprises, auprès de la population, au
service normalement même de la
population hein, ça serait le pratique
de la monnaie. N'allons même pas dans
ces détails là et aussi au service des
États. Vous pensez que les dirigeants et
les régulateurs vont vous dire mais vous
avez raison, on va se laisser voler la
vedette. Vous venez vous venez de dire
que oui, c'est eux qui c'est eu qui font
la promotion du
coup ils font la promotion. Comprenez
très bien. Je vais vous répondre, vous
le savez très bien. Et vous faites
l'idiot depuis le départ et vous le
savez très bien. Je vous dis que s'il
n'était pas à l'origine justement de ce
faux concurrent qui est soi-disant
décentralisé, à partir de là, il n'en
ferait strictement pas la promotion
parce qu'essayer d'inventer quelque
chose qui permet de contourner les
sanctions russes, essayer d'inventer
quelque chose qui permet de faire
travailler au viendra vous empêcher de
faire monsieur. C'est pour ça vous non
absolument pas je vous précise parce que
vous feignez de ne pas avoir compris ce
que vous dis c'est incompréhensible je
vais dire un truc qui vous compris mais
j'aimerais bien savoir comment vous
fonctionnez
ouvert le chocolat donc le prochain
je je voudrais juste dire un truc qui va
ça va être bizarre mais ça va nous
mettre d'accord c'est ça qui est drôle
lui c'est un filou parce qu' il fait sa
blague mais il reprend la parole
bien sûr mais c'est parce que
tu veux du chocolat
j'en ai déjà eu suffisamment je suis au
régime tout ça nonle ça pas grossir le
chocolat
D'accord.
Non. Alors le propos que je voulais dire
c'est que
garde la parole en plus hein. Est-ce que
vous lui autorisez ?
Moi je lui autorise ou
parce qu'en plus je mett tout le monde
franchement je suis
manger chocolat extrêmement pour toi et
cetera.
En fait on dit la même chose c'est que
si si je vais vous expliquer c'est que
il y a un objet un OVNI peu importe un
actif ce que vous voulez qui a été créé
par un mec random sur internet ou un
groupe de personnes. C'est pas grave le
truc bon vivote tout le monde s'en fout
et puis au bout d'un moment il y a
Wiklix qui se réveille qui dit bah en
fait c'est bien PayPal marche plus donc
on va nous envoyer de l'argent. la CIA
machin se réveille Enco, ils disent
"Bon, on va regarder ce que c'est."
Satoshi disparaît de la circulation et
puis l'histoire de Bitcoin continue. Ce
que vous dites, c'est en fait vous
pensez vraiment que des gens aussi
puissants que les régulateurs, la banque
centrale et cetera et cetera vont
laisser faire. Et en fait, c'est là
qu'on va être très triste entre
guillemets d'être d'accord, c'est que
précisément parce que les pouvoirs
publics, les régulateurs et cetera ont
plus de pouvoir en Europe qu'ils en
ralentissent l'adoption. Et donc on va
se retrouver marron comme des voilà
parce que bah c'est ce que vit
Sébastien, c'est ce que je vis depuis 10
ans, c'est ce que beaucoup de gens
vivent. On passe notre temps à se faire
fermer des comptes bancaires, à se faire
chasser, à se faire traiter de
terroristes, n na nana, tout ce que vous
voulez. Résultat, on va se réveiller
dans 15 ans, il y a aucun problème. Tous
les endroits où la puissance publique
n'aura pas été assez forte pour le
faire, c'est-à-dire soit l'état de droit
est fort, soit euh l'inverse, il est
inexistant et donc en fait, il y a une
forme de vide intersidérale qui se crée
en mode état failli. Tous ces
endroits-là qui constituent en fait une
très grande partie de l'humanité en fait
vont se l'approprier et vont créer un
effet de réseau là-dessus. Et nous, on
va arriver comme on l'a fait pour
Internet où je rappelle que le Minitel
était encore disponible en 2012. Mais
vous savez pourquoi ? parce que il y a
c'était créé déjà par un ancien euh de
France Télécom. Oui. Donc c'est qu'avec
le Minel c'était très bien pour
courtcircuter la NSA.
C'est c'est parce que c'était le réseau
centralisé, c'était contrôlé pour le
coup.
C'était tellement archaïque.
En fait, il y a plein de raisons pour le
Minitel.
Ce que je veux dire par là, c'est que en
fait on on euh nous on le on déplore,
c'est-à-dire que ce qui ce que décrit
Tom, c'est c'est en fait
pour internet, les Américains n'auront
pas de pouvoir dessus quoi. C'est
si bien sûr qu'ils auront du pouvoir
dessus, mais on dit pas la même chose.
Ce que je dis là, c'est que l'Europe
effectivement essae de tous nous mettre
des bâtons dans les roues parce que
c'est même ce que vous décrivez. Vous
dites "Vous pensez vraiment qu'ils vont
laisser faire mais je vous garantis
qu'il laissent pas faire. Ça fait 10 ans
15 ans parfois pour certains qu'on se
prend des B." Répondez-moi clairement là
vraiment. Pourquoi est-ce que l'autorité
des marchés approuve ? Pourquoi
approuve quoi ?
Ben, on en a parlé plusieurs fois.
Approuve une société gigantesque. Non,
mais elle approuve une société
gigantesque qui fait passer des volumes
de transaction énormes de Bitcoin. Ce
qui facilite la propagation de Bitcoin
auprès de du public. Parce que si vous
n'avez pas médiatique et pourquoi elle
approuve ça ? Dites-moi pasouve
vous dire. Non là quand même
elle par la
mais non absolument pas l' juste un
détail
ou
pour la qualité d'écoute
de nos auditeurs pas tous en même temps
je vais taper là on pose une question je
vous laisse la parole mais la réalité
pour que ce soit clair pour les audite
c'est quoi la réponse de la vôtre Tom
et ben moi je vous le dis elle la prouve
parce qu'il faut que les cryptomonnaies
existent et soient de plus en plus
amalgamé à des monnaies à de véritables
monnaies sinon et je Je peux même vous
dire pour travailler dans les médias et
depuis des années,
j'ai pas compris la réponse,
ben je suis en train de vous parler et
que dans les médias, il y a bien des
choses
que l'on ne veut pas voir se répandre
auprès de la population et que les
gouvernements ne veulent pas voir se
répandre. Et ça peut être il y a très
longtemps et aujourd'hui certains vous
direz euh on va même pas entrer dans des
détails, mais même la cigarette par
exemple et on l'a interdit et on a
enlevé la cigarette de de Zoou de
Luciluc et on lui a mis une paille dans
la bouche pour pas que les enfants aient
envie de fumer. Et donc sur les
cryptoonnaies bizarrement là il y a
aucune censure. Voilà, vous avez
premièrement
c'est une réunion.
Non non mais ça répond pas à ma
question. Pourquoi
même aux États-Unis ? étais aux
États-Unis il y a 3 mois aux États-Unis,
vous avez
répondez pas à ma question la question
pourquoi pourquoi la MFS ça ? Pourquoi
les États font ça ? Pourquoi les États
facilite Bitcoin et me donne de l'argent
au sous-main pour que je réussisse mon
entreprise ? Expliquez-moi pourquoi.
Non, mais c'est ce qu'il a l'air de
dire. C'est juste hallucinant répondre
sincèrement.
C'est juste hallucinant.
On en a tellement souffert. Vous
voulez que je vous réponde.
Vous savez très bien.
Non, je le sais pas. Je comprends pas ce
que vous
allez mal le prendre parce que si vous
étiez réellement simplement passionné de
Bitcoin, ben vous feriez l'effort de
discuter et de comprendre les choses et
vous ne findriez pas depuis le début de
notre échange de ne pas comprendre et de
vous agiter de partir du côté de la
cheminée en disant "Non, non, mais je
comprends pas ce que vous êtes en train
de me dire alors que vous le comprenez
très bien." Et
je poser une question simple, quel est
l'intérêt des États de faire ça ?
et ben l'intérêt des états et que les
systèmes, je vous ai répondu
précédemment il y a quelques minutes,
que les systèmes décentralisés qui vont
jaillir ne soient pas des systèmes
réellement décentralisés sur lesquels
les États et les autorités n'auront
jamais eu un droit de regard. Là, voilà
la question, la réponse à votre
question. Voilà tout à le système
monétaire est en train de s'effondrer.
S'il s'effondre, on sait qu'il va y
avoir autre chose et on sait qu'il va y
avoir Vous allez en Turquie aujourd'hui.
OK. Donc il aura le Bitcoin et les États
aident à ça. OK. Quelle quelle quelle
mainise ils vont avoir sur le protocole
? À quoi ça va les servir ?
Ah non, ils n'uront pas de main mise.
Voilà, il y a la fondation Bitcoin aux
États-Unis, la plateforme d'change
Bitcoin parle
c'est un truc qui avait été créé par
vous êtes vous travailler dans le
Bitcoin, vous connaissez pas la
fondation parce que ça n'a aucun
intérêt, ça n'a aucune
ça n'a aucune puissance la fondation.
Non, on vous demande pas si ça de la
J'ai pas beaucoup d'asses pour Bruno
Lemer mais je le connaissais hein.
Non, mais la fondation Bitcoin ne
représente rien. Voilà, on l'a oublié la
fondation. Mais
c'est comme si vous me dites "Vous
connaissez pas Bitcoin France ?" Non, je
connais pas Bitcoin France ni Bitcoin
Europe, ça n'existe pas. La fondation
Bitcoin n'a aucun pouvoir.
Ah mais Bitcoin New Zealand, tu connais
? Non.
Alors, je vais vous dire à quel point
franchement ça
monsieur est là pour propager que le
Bitcoin est sorti de nulle part. On voit
bien de Sébastien. Voilà. Non mais vous
vous êtes là pour soutenir une idée que
tout le monde balance depuis 15 ans,
c'est la NSA comme d'autres. Vous savez
il y a quelques mois effectivement sur
un plateau de télévision où on pose des
questions sur Bitcoin, j'ai exposé le
même raisonnement mais en 4 ou 5
minutes. Et effectivement ça a été très
allègrement relayé. À partir de là dans
la foulée pendant 3 semaines, il y a des
personnes qui m'ont contacté sur et sur
tous les réseaux. J'ai même reçu des
courriers postaux de gens qui ont voulu
entrer en relation avec moi et le
message était le même systématiquement.
Monsieur Benoît, je vous écoutais parler
d'économie depuis des mois. J'ai
énormément de considérations indestime
pour vous.
J'en ai aussi.
Voilà. Mais surtout ne vous
décrédibilisez pas. Quel dommage ce
serait. Je vous accorde 1 heure et demi
au téléphone pour vous expliquer
pourquoi Bitcoin n'a pas pu être créé
par les les l'état profond américain.
Des sujets sensibles. Tapez Tom Benoît
sur internet. Vous en trouverez beaucoup
que j'ai traité, énormément. Je n'ai
jamais été contacté de la sorte
seulement lorsque j'ai parlé de Bitcoin.
Et monsieur qui est Sébastien qui est à
ma droite depuis des mois, je sais pas
si vous m'aviez contacté, peut-être,
peut-être pas, mais en tout cas, vous
relayez systématiquement sur Twitter des
posts en disant Tom Benoît va encore
croire que la Sainte-Vierge revient sur
terre comme il croit que Bitcoin est
créé par la NSA. Au risque de fâcher les
fans de Tom Benoît, Bitcoin prend de
plus en plus. Et je vois des messages de
cet ordre là. systématiquement vous
relayez sur les réseaux. Quel est votre
intérêt de relayer tout ça sur Tom Beno
?
Alors, quel est votre intérêt d'arriver
là ?
Est-ce que j'ai parlé de vous sur les
réseaux moi ?
Non, mais est-ce que vous
c'est le monde à l'envers. Alors
bref, je vais vous dire un truc pour que
vous compreniez que non, les États sont
pas derrière Bitcoin parce que si vous
voulez, c'est une une affirmation qui
est absurde mais qui est très difficile
à contrer parce que personne ne sait qui
a créé le Bitcoin. Donc ça peut être un
gars de la NSA. C'est tout à fait
envisageable. Je vous expliquer pourquoi
l'État français Je vous expliquer
pourquoi l'état
Je voulais une preuve voulez une preuve
parce que apparemment
me faire passer pour un fou si vous
aussi vous pouvez vous poser la question
dans l'absolu.
Mais bien sûr que la question s'est
posée mais est-ce qu'
voilà 3 heures d'entretien parce qu'au
départ on devait même pas se poser la
question. Alors, c'est une question
d'historique. Comme je vous l'ai dit,
vous venez de débarquer dans le game et
vous croyez que toutes les questions qui
se posent à vous, vous venez de les
découvrir et que vous les vous vous
donnez votre science au monde pour
résoudre les problématiques. Ça fait 15
ans qu'on y pense. Enfin, moi
personnellement, ça fait 8 ans. Il y a 8
ans sur les forums, déjà, il y avait des
pages entières de de gens qui disaient
"C'est la NSA, c'est la CIA." Mais en
fait, on s'en fout dès qu'on est on
connaît bien le MIT, on s'en fout un peu
de savoir qu'il l'a fait parce que ça ne
donne aucun pouvoir au concepteur. Aucun
pouvoir. Le seul qui a un pouvoir, c'est
Satoshi Nakamoto parce qu'il a 1 million
de Bitcoin. Mais sinon, il ne peut plus
intervenir sur son protocole. Plus là,
je fais une diéressant.
S'il y a une entité qui détient 80 % de
Bitcoin, elle ne prend pas le contrôle
de Bitcoin.
C'est pas le cas.
Non, mais si elle si une entité venait à
avoir 80 % de Bitcoin, est-ce qu'elle en
prend le contrôle ?
Si ma tante en avait, on l'appellerait
mon nom.
Si une entité venait avoir.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça ? vous
dire aujourd'hui par exemple qu'il y a 1
% de la population mondiale qui détient
99 % des richesses. C'est une réalité.
Est-ce
comment s'appelle votre oncle ?
Si on parle sérieusement, est-ce que ce
que je dis j'ai un peu Ah ben parce
qu'elles sont intéressantes. Est-ce que
ce que je dis est vrai ? Si 80 % du
volume de Bitcoin était détenu par une
entité, est-ce que cette entité en
prendrait le contrôle selon les la
réponse est oui. Monsieur
la réponse est non monsieur. Vous
connaissez pas du tout de quoi vous
parlez. C'est hallucinant. En quoi le
fait d'avoir 80 % des Bitcoin va me
donner autre chose qu'un pouvoir de
fluctuation du prix ? C'est le seul
pouvoir que ça va me donner.
Ce que j'appelle le contrôle, c'est
aussi le pouvoir de la fluctuation de la
valeur.
Bien sûr, c'est sûr, si j'ai 80 % des
dollars, je vais contrôler le le cours
du dollar. Ça n'a aucun sens.
Parce que si vous en vendez, vous faites
baisser en train de faire une
démonstration. Alors
finis sa démonstration, ensuite je pose
deux questions et ensuite français nous
a
en plus bagage.
L'État français ne nous a pas harcelé,
nous a pas fait de contrôle vital, rien.
L'État français est très volontaire.
Alors, je vous donne un exemple. Alors
celui-ci avec le Bitcoin, il nous
pousse, il nous pousse dans le dos là.
On sent le vent, il nous pousse.
Mais vous prenez votre cas personnel. Je
prends pas mon cas personne. Laissez-moi
parler. La cour des comptes l' reconnu.
La cour des comptes l'a reconnu dans un
rapport de dire on met 10 ans après les
banques rest. Pardon mais là en fait
c'est parce qu'il disent c'est
personnel.
Sa femme et ses enfants c'est personnel.
Je suis désolé. Bah je il est évident
que c'est plus difficile de déménager
avec toute sa famille que tout se
importe si vous voulez ce genre
d'attaque gardez-la pour vous. Ça m'est
égal. Je parle pas de mon cas personnel,
je parle du mining. Le mining c'est une
activité qui aujourd'hui on l'a dit fait
plusieurs gigw aux États-Unis et rend
énormément de service à la carte
électrique au grille d'électrique Texan
du Missouri et d'autres d'autres états.
Moi en 2017 j'apportais cette idée à
EDF. J'avais ce même constat. On a une
puissance électrique installée qui est
énorme pour une consommation qui est pas
toujours à la hauteur. On vend de
l'électricité presque gratuite. On a
capacité de mettre des conteneurs sur
toutes les centrales hydroélectriques,
sur toutes les centrales nucléaires de
France de façon à éviter ce qu'on a vécu
cet été. Si on avait commencé à miner en
2017 comme je l'ai proposé aujourd'hui
EDF serait à la tête, on a fait les
calculs hier soir avec mes associés
entre 5 et 7,7 milliards de dollars
qu'on dette
plus de dette chez EDF. Attends, on a
créé un partenariat, j'ai réussi à
convaincre ADF, on a créé un partenariat
avec la direction générale d'EDF qui m'a
envoyé deux équipes. Donc deux équipes
EDF Nouvelles énergies et la direction
de l'hydroélectricité de Grenoble. Ils
sont venus. L'ingénieur hydroélectrique
lui a tout de suite compris l'intérêt et
quand il est rentré, il a passé un appel
d'offre. Je l'ai avec moi l'appel
d'offre et EDF achète deux conteneurs de
mining.
C'est juste dingue hein. Si on avait
continué dans cette voie aujourd'hui,
encore une fois, on aurait gagné à peu
près 5 milliards et DF aurait gagné
hein. Euh et donc euh et ben cet appel
d'offre a été euh annulé par la
direction générale des DF. Ils ont
retiré l'appel d'offre. On a perdu la
chance de devenir le leader mondial du
mining en France. C'est pour ça quand je
vois les gar du niggler qui viennent et
qui disent "Mais on nous a coupé l'herbe
sous le pied". Mais c'est exactement la
même chose qu' on s'est on a sacrifié
cette possibilité de valoriser de
l'électricité perdue par idéologie anti
Bitcoin. Et après, on va me dire que
l'État a soutenu Bitcoin mais c'est
juste l'inverse de toute notre
expérience. Donc vous pouvez arriver
avec toute votre intelligence Tom, mais
vous allez pas remplacer notre
expérience et ce qu'on a vécu et le
feeling qu'on a, on sait très bien que
les États nous détestent, déteste
Bitcoin et on tout fait pour nous mettre
des bâtons dans les roues. Vous pouvez
répéter sans arrêt que c'est les états
qui nous poussent. C'est c'est juste
l'inverse et cet exemple d'DF le montre.
C'est quand même le prouve.
OK. Question. Je voudrais trois livres
importants qui ont compté pour vous
nécessaire à la communauté Alia. Alex,
je sais pas si j'irai jusqu'à 3 mais de
et
on interdit le livre de Bruno Lemire.
Non, tu es pas prévu.
Lequel des seul
les
Non,
le livre de Marlen Chapa. Non, pas du
tout.
Le
le premier c'est on en a parlé tout à
l'heure, c'est un bouquin de de Haïek,
c'est la route de la servitude qui est
un super bouquin qui explique en gros
effectivement alors qui est écrit par
Aek donc il a un économiste autrichien
autrichien puisque l'Autrichien ça veut
dire c'est une chapelle économique
d'être autrichien mais lui il est
autrichien et il vient d'Autriche et il
a écrit en 43 après s'être exilé
évidemment d'Autriche pour des raisons
assez évidentes il vivait au roy
Royaume-Uni et il décrit euh en fait un
petit peu le côté inévitable de euh des
utopies socialistes, on va dire, de de
cette période là. Et donc c'est assez
froid et en fait c'est finalement assez
actuel quand on le lit. Euh le deuxième
euh c'est euh un bouquin de Lynalden qui
est une macroéconomiste américaine qui
s'appelle Broken Money euh et qui est
assez limpide. Alors il faut avoir le
temps de lire 500 pages, mais qui prend
l'histoire monétaire sous le prisme
technologique euh ce qui est un prisme
qui est rarement pris. Euh et qui est
donc du coup très intéressant parce que
il amène à euh au pourquoi du comment et
en fait là-dessus, on était à peu près
tous d'accord, le système actuel est
éclaté au sol en fait en version en
version rapide euh qui ne peut pas
fonctionner, que c'est une fuite en
avant et que c'est un petit peu on a
abordé la question très rapidement de
finalement pourquoi on retournerait pas
à l'étalon or. En fait, c'est un livre
qui essaie d'expliquer pourquoi on ne
peut pas retourner à l'étalon or. on
retournerait dans la même machine des
réserves fractionnaires, des billets et
cetera et donc on retournerait dans le
même dans les mêmes problèmes. Et
effectivement, ce livre n'est pas un
bouquin Bitcoin mais c'est un bouquin
d'une macroéconomiste avec un un une
formation d'ingénieur et qui aboutit
comme conclusion vers ces derniers
chapitres de dire en fait le le la plus
belle opportunité monétaire pour
résoudre ces problèmes aujourd'hui
s'appelle Bitcoin. On ne sait pas si ça
va réussir mais clairement sur les
candidats c'est celui qui a le qu'elle
vend en poupe.
Mon petit 3è
un petit 3è non on n'est pas obligé
mon propre bouquin. Non je vais pas
faire de la pub chich.
Allons-y. Bitcoin et cryptomonnaie
facile pour les néofites. 2e édition qui
vient de sortir en septembre
19,90
même pas 13 € je crois.
D'accord. pas cher.
Vous prenez combien de
Bon, pas grand chose d'auteurs, c'est 5
% quelque chose comme ça. Non, je vais
pas faire ma fortune dessus a priori
Tom trois bouquins.
Le premier que j'apprécie beaucoup et
que j'ai cité dans une émission et son
auteur m'a contacté à la suite de ça qui
s'appelle la monnaie et qui est édité
chez Fire et je m'étais trompé dans une
précédente émission justement, je me
souvenais plus du nom d'auteur. Je
disais chez Odil Jacob et donc il
s'appelle la monnaie chez Fire qui est
brillantissime. C'est
Jacob, c'est une bonne maison aussi
hein.
Ouais. Ouais, absolument. Ouais,
absolument. C'est Jacques de la Rousère
qui est édité chez Audit Jacob et qui
sort d'ailleurs en dernier ouvrage. Mais
ce livre donc sur la monnaie chez
Fillard et qui retrace l'histoire à la
fois de la monnaie des banques centrales
d'hier à aujourd'hui avec les
prospectives que l'on a l'on a fait ce
soir et qui est absolument brillant. en
second. Après euh il y en a un que
j'avais cité ici, c'était d'Arthur
Chopener qui a toujours été mon livre de
chevé aisme sur la sagesse dans la vie
qui m'a bouleversé, que je lis encore et
qui est que je tiens d'ailleurs de mon
père qui est toujours là hein par contre
par ailleurs et qui a qui était tombé
par hasard sur ce livre lorsqu'il avait
16 ans et qui a changé sa vie. Michel
Benoît, mon père, qui a bouleversé ma
vie à moi aussi parce que ça m'a fait
euh avoir un regard beaucoup plus
limpide, beaucoup plus ciselé, beaucoup
plus précis, beaucoup plus froid,
beaucoup plus moralisateur sur ce que
Chopen a rappelé Jant le le grand
problème de l'existence. Et puis après
en troisème un livre récent en tout cas
qui m'avait beaucoup marqué, c'était
effectivement celui de Jacques de la
Rosè qui s'appelaitusion
financière.
Voilà. Ouais.
en finir avec l'illusion financière et
par chez Audil Jacob il y a 1 an et demi
et qui est de de très très bonnes
factures et je dis pas ça par rapport à
l'amitié que je lui je lui
on lui passe le bonjour et je complète
la liste de livres de chez Chopen H avec
l'art d'avoir toujours raison
Ouais qui est un petit
qui est obligatoire si vous regardez la
télé
si vous regardez la télé il faut lire ce
livre avant
ça va vous aider et ça va même bien vous
aider
il y a Léon Blois Barbé Dorévili plein
de choses qui vont plus Seb, trois
bouquins.
Euh bah comme c'est Bitcoin, je voulais
proposer des B des bouquins Bitcoin.
C'est mon préféré. Ça c'est un livre
français dans le texte.
Attends, on va le cadrer.
Le arrive.
On est bien la cadreuse d'ailleurs.
Donc ça c'est la première édition, il aé
il a été réédité l'année dernière. Euh
c'est donc Bitcoin la monnaie à céphale
et c'est écrit par Jacques Favier et
Adlit Calbataille.
On reconnaît bien la pâte de Jacques
Favier. C'est un normal un historien
normalien qui a un super style et le
bouquin dit tout sur Bitcoin. Moi je
l'ai découvert en 2017 donc ça faisait
déjà 2 ans que je travailler dans le
Bitcoin à fond et j'y ai appris plein de
choses. En tout cas c'est un livre qui a
répondu à beaucoup de mes questions.
Comme je le disais à Tom tout à l'heure,
on a réfléchi des années et des années.
Moi, j'ai j'ai étudié longuement le
Bitcoin et si j'avais eu ce livre quand
j'ai démarré, j'aurais gagné un temps
fou. Donc je le conseille à tous les
gens même si même qui s'y connaissent un
peu déjà en Bitcoin qui travaillent
dessus depuis un moment. Et si vous avez
encore des questions, il y a la réponse
dans ce bouquin. Euh le deuxème c'est la
face non c'est l'énergie face caché de
la monnaie. C'est de Pierre Noisa, c'est
le président de la boîte où travaille
Alex. Vous avez complètement oublié ce
détail.
Tu me donneras le numéro d'ailleurs
Pierre Pierre Noisa, il est excellent.
Lui, c'est un ingénieur polytechnicien.
Tout le monde se connaît. Ça change les
numéros.
Fais pas ton malin toi. Fais
pas ton malin. Il connais quand même
beaucoup plus. Fais pas tout mal.
Et donc voilà, c'est un livre, je l'ai
pas fini et je l'ai oublié au Salvador
donc je l'ai pas fini mais euh donc
c'est c'est tout sous le le la monnaie
sous le prisme de l'énergie et c'est
très intéressant. Et le troisième que
j'avais prévu c'était le livre d'Alex et
de Claire Blava de Balva. Pardon.
On se connait bien.
Moi je commande le bouquin de Sébastien.
C'est c'est un manuel qui est très
facile d'accès, qui est très vulgarisé.
Donc là c'est pour c'est très bien pour
les débutants.
Ton bouquin c'est comment ça s'appelle
Tom ?
Lequel ? le tien
le dernier il concernait l'architecture
donc c'est pas vraiment le sujet de ce
soir aisme sur l'architecture qui a été
préfacé par Rudericioti qui est un ami
par ailleurs et grand prix national
d'architecture.
Alors un conseil pour les jeunes
générations. Qui est-ce qui commence
le plus vieux ? Le boomer.
Ah c'est moi qui commence.
Ouais. Et on finira par le plus jeune.
Allez.
Euh
c'est pas évident de s'adresser aux
jeunes parce que avec 20 va confesse.
Non non.
euh
regarder Singer Viiew, je pense que
c'est un un bon moyen de d'acquérir une
partie de sa liberté. Donc essayer de de
penser à la liberté. chez quand on est
jeune, c'est pas quelque chose qui nous
importe parce que elle est elle est
évidente. En tous les cas, moi quand
j'étais jeune, adolescent ou jeune
adulte, la liberté était évidente en
France et ce qui nous intéressait
à nous c'était l'égalité et
éventuellement la fraternité mais
surtout l'égalité et c'est une grosse
erreur. La liberté, je dirais précède
tout. Donc pensez à être libre et pensez
que la liberté n'est pas gagnée
d'avance. Euh c'est une lutte de tous
les instants.
Alex,
c'est difficile de s'adresser à la jeune
génération. Je considère que j'en fais
encore un peu mardi euh
par rapport aux gens que je vois qui
sont euh pas qui sont soit encore en
école ou qui en sortent. Moi je dirais
que
la chose qui m'a le plus marqué c'était
quand on entre dans le monde
professionnel, le monde des grands entre
guillemets. Euh en fait on se rend
compte qu'il y a un côté très théâtral.
On est persuadé quand on est jeune que
les adultes savent ce qu'ils font.
Et en fait pas du tout mais pas du tout.
Euh et donc il y a un côté euh osé en
fait. Il y a plein de choses sur
lesquelles vous êtes bien plus au
courant que beaucoup de gens qui se
prétendent adultes ou experts depuis
longtemps. Euh et en fait si vous
essayez euh vous verrez que parfois euh
voire souvent ça se passe mieux que ce
qui était anticipé. Vous avez pas de
honte à avoir. Euh vous pouvez essayer,
vous pouvez rater, vous pouvez
recommencer et si vous le faites pas
maintenant entre guillemets, vous
risquez de le regretter plus tard.
Tom
que tout glisse sur vous comme de l'eau
sur les plumes d'un canard. Ça c'est la
première des choses dans la vie
sentimentale, dans les affaires, dans le
business, dans la vie en société surtout
soyez absolument impassible parce qu'on
vous apprend pas à être impassible
justement. On vous apprend à sautiller
de partout, à être hypersensible, à être
heuré encore plus aujourd'hui avec une
société de fragile, avec une société de
gens dépendants ultra peuré. Et moi ce
que je dis c'est soyez fort avant d'être
libre parce que c'est un étant fort que
vous serez libre et soyez parfaitement
indépendant, toujours totalement
indépendant. Sachez nommer les choses.
Ne tombez pas dans le panneau moderne
qui fait qu'on peut vous expliquer que A
et B, que B et A. Non, mal nommer les
choses, c'est contribuer au malheur du
monde. C'est Camu qui le disait. Et
aujourd'hui, ça s'avère de plus en plus
exact parce qu'aujourd'hui, on ne sait
plus nommer les choses, on ne sait plus
gérer sa santé. On fait des politiques
de santé publique alors qu'on fait des
politiques de pathologie publique en
réalité. Donc les jeunes, le conseil que
je peux vous donner qui vous qui avez
mon âge en quelque sorte à la rigueur
faites comme moi. Ça paraît prétentieux
de le dire mais moi je fais des
affaires, je travaille beaucoup et
pourtant il y a pas
je fais beaucoup de sport
et je fais beaucoup de sport et il y a
pas un jour où vous me verrez manger
quelque chose de malsin pour moi. Si
vous consommez quelque chose, pardon
du cavior. Je crois pas que
non des frites. Tu manges des frites ?
Non absolument pas. Je mangerai jamais
une frite moi. Tu confonds là. Non non
tuas pas
fait comme toi de manger une carrière.
en danger du camé soir pas de frit mais
je veux dire non non mais vous me verz
manger quelque chose de malsin évitez
les produits transformé soyez attentif à
vous en priorité dites-vous que votre
premier capital c'est votre santé c'est
votre capacité à être mobile à
comprendre si vous n'avez pas de
protection en santé aux États-Unis par
exemple ben vous serez en bien meilleure
santé si vous vous prenez soin de vous
plutôt que si vous êtes malade en France
ça c'est la première des choses à
comprendre donc prenez soin de vous
faites des affaires et pensez à
l'instant présent je vois des gens,
c'est le dernier mot. Après, je vois de
plus en plus de gens paumés qui ont mon
âge. Je parlais avec un ami qui a une
fille qui a mon âge à peu près assez
récemment, qui a fait de grandes écoles,
qui sait pas où elle va, qui sait pas où
elle est et ça c'est le gros problème de
ma génération aujourd'hui. Donc faites
des coups sur l'instant, créez votre
écosystème et avancez sur l'instant.
C'était pas des frites, c'était des
éperlants. Autant pour moi.
Voilà. Absolument
freit
freit. Alors comme ça tu connais du
monde, ça se discute.
Je te rassure, tu étais là toi.
Moi j'ai pas mangé des perç.
Moi j'ai mangé des frites pour le coup.
Messieurs,
merci pour cette émission.
Merci à toi.
Ben merci de nous avoir reçu. Merci à
vous.
Merci à vous.
Bonne soirée.
Merci.
[Musique]